nope I am here all right great we're
going to start off
's see
who's representative
buard would you please lead us in the
Pledge of
Allegiance I will thank
you I pledge
allegiance flag of
thees to the Republic for which it
stands unto God indivisible with liberty
and justice for
all thank
you1 a script here folks please bear
with
me as chair of Labor industrial and
rehabilitative Services committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor and as a result
of covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referring to the committee an
executive session may follow please note
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar of the
general court
website the notice for this meeting's
notice complies with house Rule and RSA
91a anyone who has problems accessing
the meeting should call
271 3600 or email
HCS
lg. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adj Jed and
rescheduled Christine Dyer is a staff
member assisting us today please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking
the roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
state state whether there's anyone in
the room with them during this meeting
which is required under the right to no
law Mr clerk you call the rooll thank
you infant time here in the L seaworth
present in the L
abani on Zoom at
work I'm gonna ask you to repeat that
representative avalona you broke up you
are at work and please
continue get are at work employees
around and pres thank
you k here in the
L myself in the L lunz good morning I'm
home in my office in P ham
alone I'm here at my home office in
Manchester nobody else here turot turot
here in the
El here at home alone in the
room boy here at home
alone
HFF here at the
L
Sullivan excuse me here I'm in in my
home office alone in the room my wife is
in the
house
Susy here in my house alone but my
daughter is in the
Housey I'm home in my home office in
Manchester my assistant will be coming
in and out during the
day K Hill
at home in New Market alone in the room
he
sylvestra
home Linda I'm sorry that was not
auditable audible would you uh could
barely hear what you were saying you try
again please yes I'm
home I was reading lips very well
SMI I am alone in my home office and uh
good to see
everybody
Tumi Tumi at home in Nashua alone my
wife's in the house
somewhere
rard I'm home alone in Manchester
however sometime after 11 a service
person will be in the
house
here
elev everyone
[Music]
thank is going to be a long day we have
a number of people um testifying on our
second bill so uh just want to make sure
everyone um is prepared for this um I
know people have contacted me they'll be
in and out and that's acceptable
uh we'll be taking some breaks as we go
through and the chair Vice chairman will
be sitting in for me um as well during
today's activities so that being said
the um I would like
to open the executive session unless I'm
missing anything
unless unless I'm missing anything or
asking any questions anyone has any
questions of me uh general not having to
do with our second uh hearing
today seeting n thank you very much I'd
like to open the executive session on
House Bill
501 call on um Vice chairman seaworth
for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
move for
itl second motion the floor is uh itl by
representative seaworth second by
representative turot you may uh wish to
speak to your motion uh thank you Mr
chairman uh this is a bill everyone I'm
sure remembers we had two hearings on it
uh the original form of the bill I think
everybody had some issues with and so an
amendment was brought in um that was
considerably more
reasonable however uh what we learned
during the second public hearing is that
um the university system both the
community colleges and UNH were amenable
to satisfying the goals that were set
forth in that
Amendment and um it seems that we're on
a path where they could accomplish uh
everything that's intended without
actually having to
um push it through in in legislation and
when we can do something directly with
the Departments rather than pass
legislation I think that's generally
preferable and so for that reason um I'm
asking for an
itl and you know we can wait and see
what kind of progress is made and maybe
revisit it sometime in the future if
it's unsatis fact thank you
representative any comments in the
L seeing none comments online
representative kill yes uh thank you Mr
chair
and I would agree with uh the remarks
from the um Vice chair uh it is
encouraging that the both the university
and the uh community college system were
willing to uh uh comply with the with
the goal of making the compensation
available and you know for adjunct as
well as uh full-time faculty I think we
can see from the actions of the uh
finance committee taking $30 million out
of uh the Governor's School
infrastructure fund to put put it to
shore up the uh University and the co
community college system that were going
to be funded but at least flat funding
them which is kind of flat funding is
about all we do here in New Hampshire
when we when we're not having enough
money going into either system which is
why we export so many young people to
out of state universities because the
tuition is cheaper and they don't come
back so I think we we do uh we do hope
to uh perhaps s sort out the business
maybe there'll be a merger maybe there
won't but we want to make sure that
we're paying faculty uh to do the work
that they're doing to the important work
of educating our students thank you Mr
chair thank you representative kahill
yes and representative kahill you um
have the video now uh on uh on YouTube
where the
um I don't remember uh the chancellor or
the woman's name the president of the
community college system when I asked
her specifically will you provide this
information and she agreed to do that
and we already know the university
system information is available so um
let the labor committee know if uh that
information is not provided to you when
you request it thank you Mr chair it was
good to see that a uh solution hopefully
um could come of this um with people
participating and cooperating versus
having a piece of legislation any
additional comments in the uh
online
I don't see any hands folks so I'm going
to go ahead with the motion on the
floor is in expedience to legislate by
representative seaworth seconded by
representative
turot
Mr clerk please call the
rooll and then please folks if you would
um indicate your names and your vote
thank you
seaworth representative seaworth votes
yes
avalani rep representative avalani vote
Yes
tum representative Callum votes yes mcky
myself vote
Yes nunz represent n votes yes Warden
Warden votes yes on
itl T representative turkot votes
yes rout votes yes
V votes
yes
Sullivan Sullivan votes yes
Susi Susi votes yes Bui representative
Bui votes yes
kill kill votes yes
Destro
Schmid votes yes Tumi Tumi yes Bard rard
yes Check vot Yes
infantine infantine votes yes 20 to zero
the vote being 20 to zero without
objection this will be placed on the
consent
agenda I see no so thank you very
much I'm going to close the hearing
executive session on Hospital 501 and I
have a few announcements for the
committee there was a request made to
place House Bill
107 um which was the increase in the
minimum wage of $22.50 cents on the
consent agenda as inexpedient to
legislate when I requested by the when I
made the request um by the uh or to the
house clerk he informed me this could
not be be done because it had already
appeared in the in a calendar um so we
will have to bring it to the floor I'll
be it briefly even understanding that
some of the sponsors and the committee
uh would have liked to uh changed their
mind and would have liked to have seen
it on the um on the Cent agenda that not
happen um by rule and our protocol so um
it will be on the house floor and I
believe neither side will speak but that
is the ruling of the the
clerk um the second issue that came up
was we had the bill uh Michael please
remind me he's at 589 FN regarding y um
prophylactic use or
approval 589 the um we had retained that
bill
here and
um then uh representative kahill and I
along along with Department of Labor
went
through the initial bill the
amendment
um agreed with the what was intended
what the amendment did what the process
was I then wrote to each one of you with
five attachments an
outline of how to follow the bill and
what was done and what was intended and
I believe u I did not receive any
dissenting opinions on what I was
presented I then requested that the
clerk allow us to bring the retain Bill
back into the committee so we could vote
on it again that is not
allowed technically on the house
floor we could do
that the clerk recommended and requested
that we not really do that because
having so many bills being retained and
with the marathon session we have to
have on the 7th 8th and 9th of April um
they did not want to get in a situation
where all retained bills came out on the
floor it had been done 18 years ago in
one certain circumstance it was relay to
me that it was an extremely
important uh to the entire State and
that's why that was done that way so I
then uh discussed with representative k
Hill about trying to find a Germain bill
either in the house or the
Senate to attach it
to um uh there was nothing in the Senate
that that represent kill could find I
was looking for it I'm still looking for
something to do that then the request
was made um to attach it to one of our
existing pieces of legislation out of
this committee which would have been
House Bill
305 which can only be done on the
floor um I I passed that around um and
there was not on um Republican caucus
there was not a lot
of interest in doing
so
Bill 589 but some because of the bill
305 which apparently um is
not being received over well
overwhelmingly by the entire
house um if also
the a mass amount of bills that we
have it was recommended that we not do
this so that is the circumstance where
now um I'm open for discussion and
further representative Adent has been
uh yes thank you ch you may speak um I
would I mean I'd recommend just pulling
it out on the FLT you know like I know
you said there's not a huge appetite for
that because it'll unleash this wave of
a bunch of bills coming out on the floor
as much as I would love all the retained
bills from various committees this year
come out on the house floor there's not
votes for that so if this one does I
think it would be an isolated
incid M um uh it is the um all right I I
will let everyone speak before I make my
comments um thank you for your comments
and I couldn't think of I was trying to
say you will recognize to speak my
apologies it's early we're just getting
started anyone else here in the
L seeing no comments here any
online representative kill thank you Mr
chair uh yeah in in light of the uh
circumstances while I while I believe
the members of the committee would
support uh 589 now that they all
understand what it does and what it
doesn't do I don't want to uh I don't
want to sync the other Bill 385 which is
also important to protect our you know
long serving uh firefighters so I I
think that the best thing to do at this
time would be to to wait till next year
unfortunately another year on this issue
but I think that's the best uh plan
forward not not being one to remonstrate
but we do spend a lot of time on the
floor talking about talking about silly
sometimes and this is not a silly one
but uh let's just uh take the better
path of Valor and uh we wait till next
year and hopefully nobody else uh has
this unfortunate
experience thank you representative
kahill representative
Sol thank you Mr chair um I have to
agree with my colleague rep kahill um
that um this bill would have a much
better chance coming up clean and Alone
um in the next U session uh rather than
than um having a what could be a fairly
confusing floor action um in the um
Sports plex so umun we have to wait but
I think that's the best course of action
that way both bills hopefully can get
through um thank you any other
comments well I agree with what you
would like with representative kahill
representative Sullivan I am still
trying to find something uh through the
senate or Commerce Committee to see what
we can do I do believe it is ready to go
and it's and and it's something that um
probably should be
done I
cannot
uh tell any Representatives they cannot
do something on the floor I cannot tell
any of you you were you were forbidden
for making a motion on the floor you all
have your choice to do as you choose um
we just do want to get this uh bill pass
so I I will leave it at that unless
there's any other additional
comments okay thank you very much it is
9:21 we're going to take a 30 minute
recess while I put together um a list
I'm G to come back at 10 minutes of 10
uh I do have I do have a few hands so um
just let me finish my comments and I
will
recog I will come back at 10 minutes of
10 and outline how we're going to handle
um today's hearing um on House Bill 61
representative Adent followed by
representative S I just wanted to follow
up on the last comment you made um I
wasn't planning on pulling it off in the
floor um because like I just think it
you know doesn't make a whole lot of
sense for us to get technicality the
cler's office but if it were to be
pulled out on the floor with the
amendment that you and representative
kill worked on the attached to the
legislation would have called off fled
on
[Music]
FL lad I believe the bill would have to
come
out someone would have to move the
amendment the amendment would have to
pass then the the so would have to
happen
that so first you'd have to get the
motion to bring it out then the motion
with then the amendment the first one
would be the first order of business on
that bill that one okay thank you
representative
solivan as I said I think we would like
to avoid a confusing process on the
floor um with a lot of work to get done
um the um I also just wanted to say that
during our break I'd like to do a quick
um Democratic caucus um so we could sign
off from here and sign on to the same
Zoom that we used
yesterday
okay very well thank you folks I will
see you at 10 minutes of 10 um well to
outline the procedure for the rest of
the day thank you very
much we are going to mute the uh volume
here in the
lrv and I need to go through this to
determine the order of speaking because
I have tell some people
saying
so a Massachusetts company bids
on 9 minutes
so
all right
[Music]
folks
okay we have 84 people signed up to
testify there probably a few more
I
have six
legislators um signed up a number of
lobbyists and a number of members of the
public I'd like to keep the speeches of
testimony to four minutes or
under um and we're going to um hear the
um elected officials first some of the
lobbyists next and then the other
individuals yes representative buard I
do see your hand I do know you have um
you are one of the six uh wanted to make
sure you understand uh if you
testify um on behalf of the bill you
will not be able to ask questions during
the remainder of the
hearing uh after looking at the number
of people signed up to
speak I do feel that my issues probably
will be covered so I would like
to uh not
testify understood thank you Bard
repr did I see your hand raise okay all
right thank you repres Bard
um and then I have one individual that
specifically asked me to member of the
public wanted to speak before 11:30
because they have to go to what I they
have take their husband to um Al
Alzheimer's treatment so I'm GNA let
that individual speak before 11:30 and
then everyone else we will speak really
as they signed out
uh I will be calling three names in the
individual to speak and then two
additional names so people know a little
bit ahead of time we don't want to waste
a lot of time you know calling on people
and then having them not available so
we'll try to give their
names in
advance um any questions or any
objections
to the
process okay representative infantine
it's Christina is there someone willing
to keep time if you wanted to keep that
four minute um marker someone to let um
just to keep the four minutes I have a
uh time watch on my phone I was GNA kind
of keep eye on it I I'd like everyone to
have the opportunity to speak I've seen
many
um committees where they reduce people's
time down to one minute or whatever
while it will be a long day for us I
would like every everyone really has the
really wants to speak to allow them to
speak
today um so yes we will be here a while
um I will keep the four minutes here and
um if it really goes longer during the
day we may have to reduce that but
um I want everyone to have their say so
I will keep it here and try to give
people a nod when it's someone is
preaching uh four minutes representative
kahill yes uh Mr chairman and this
probably for Christine as well do we
know who these people are with the phone
numbers I don't know how we would call
on them if we don't know who they
are what we'll do is we'll have them
raise their hand um using the um the
star six button um they should be able
to raise their hand when their name is
called thank
you uh representative kill did you just
ask how do we
know I I did I missed that question
please yes I did ask him you know
because all I see is a all I see is a
phone number and I wouldn't know which
person that was well I will be
introducing the individual in the town
so
um Mike Lynch Londoner New
Hampshire okay I did see that I was when
I was perusing that very long list I saw
that someone signed in as uh not my real
email and something else for their name
but it's a wild place
I haven't seen that one but I will be
looking for those great thank
you were asking about sen John yes
Senator Reagan I do thank
you Mr
chairman reprentative it uh as long as
we've got four minutes here I seeing how
it's mik kahill's birthday perhaps you
could get the song out of the way now
yeah I did not know that I think we
should all okay I now wait a minute I
said I said I was gonna be in my
birthday suit if you sing to me you'll
have the
consequence I can that is your choice
let's not do
this is that a
dear I'm gonna risk
itday
to
birth
toy
[Music]
birth
bir
to we could be the labor committee
chorus no you don't want me to put that
camera back on Happy Birthday Michael
thank you thank
you
[Music]
very good guys very
good stopwatch ready to go everyone's
ready to
go
for your edification
Representatives we have 222
people submitting support
1,73
opposed zero
neutral 82
testified those numbers yes are the most
current kind of makes you wonder doesn't
it Mr
chair why we would have such a bill
before us you
know I can answer that but I don't want
to it's not for a for not is not for
me Michael you could be as long as a
session today I look forward after the
session to having the
annual Barley House beer with you
Michael it is
it is now 10:00 a Eastern Standard time
I would like to open the hearing on
Senate Bill
61 for the people logging on um we have
a large number of people want to testify
today if everyone testifies for four
minutes that's includes questions
we will be here for a little over almost
six hours which we're willing to do uh I
will be
calling elected officials first followed
by uh lobbyists and then members of the
public I will announce three names so
that people know who is up to speak and
who the people the second and third up
and I will continue each time someone's
done so folks that are paying attention
online and wish to testify know when
their names um will be be coming up
please keep your
um testimony as succinct as possible
this moment Michael to take this
possible and please be courteous I
understand this is a um a very sensitive
issue to some uh we we ask your
testimony to be thoughtful and
respectful representative kill thank you
Mr chair I do see the name of the
honorable Shawn Morrison a former member
of the labor committee and a Hampton
firefighter I I hope we can get him uh
on early so he in case he has to do some
Duty or
something what it Shan
Morrison representative Kale did you say
sha Morrison yes I see I saw his hand up
hands down
oh there it is again on the list I'd
like to um first
call Senator John Reagan to to
uh introduce his bill Senator are you
with
us yes I am
present recognize speak thank you
Senator thank you uh Mr chairman and
members of House
labor I am Senator John Reagan from
Senate District 17 and I bring to you
today Senate Bill
61 affectionately known as right to
work you have been bombarded with so
much
information some of it is true and some
of it has proven ridiculously
false many union members believe they
are supporting co-workers by opposing
right to
work you often excuse the price of union
dues believing that they pay for
attorneys and business agents but often
they are used to influence political
elections the difficulty with being a
legislator is often trying to Divine
what is true and what is not
true we have all promised to do what is
best for all citizens of New
Hampshire and this is
at least the fourth time that I've
introduced The Right to Work
bill but I believe that the numbers that
you have seen supporting economic
Advantage for
States enjoying Right to Work
protection to be true and that is why I
brought it back
again and I think it makes New Hampshire
a more desirable place to do
business my session has started in the
Senate so I am not going to take any
test any questions you'll have plenty of
input coming at
you
today so I hope you use your best
judgment decide what is true and act in
the best interest of New
Hampshire thank
you thank you
senator
next up is representative Kaplan
followed by representative Abramson and
Horgan representative
Kaplan yes hello good morning can you
hear me yes sir thank you Mr chairman
and thank you members of the labor
committee I'm a representative Tony
Kaplan representing uh mayor Max 6 the
towns of hener and Bradford
I'm a 20 plus years public educator and
Union member and uh I can tell you one
of the things I've been most grateful
for as a father and husband and someone
committed to giving my kids the best
possible advantage in life is uh
belonging to a union and to guarantee
decent wages job protections and health
care that come with working as a public
school teacher in a union covered
workplace I remember going to hker town
meetings and people complaining about
the teacher is getting a raise how come
I don't make that much how come I don't
get that level of Health
Care and I always responded that number
one the rise in school spending has very
little to do with teacher salaries but
more importantly why aren't we trying to
raise everyone up instead of tearing
some of us down every job and every
workplace should be adequately
compensated and one of the keys to
getting there is collective
bargaining unions based on worker
solidarity and stick sing together to
get better conditions and wages are an
essential component of a prosperous
America that's what built the middle
class every student of American History
knows that for a fact the peak year of
union membership by percentage was
1954 the 1950s and 60s were the years
that grew an American middle class that
was the pride of the world with
prosperity never before
seen Rising wages year after year in
almost every sector and almost every
demographic
and it was built on Union membership and
Manufacturing transport skilled and
unskilled
labor but the tide began to turn as it
does and the corporate Elites struck
back with the Reagan
Administration the great communicator
President Reagan who's really the
spokesman for this new but actually old
as the hills ideology that the rich and
their riches should be Unleashed and
this would give rise to a new sort of
growth an Economy based on wealth
trickling down from above instead of
growing out from an expanding middle
class part of that was breaking the
power of unions by deregulating and
opening up to globalization all designed
to increase the power of Corporations
and business profits but we've seen the
result the collapse of the American
middle class over the last few
decades and the rise of levels of
inequality last seen at the beginning of
the 20th century when we had cities
teaming with pennes immigrants and
Countryside full of Hard Scrabble Farms
while the robber barons Rockefellers and
carnegies lived high off the Hog on
their
Estates that's the level of inequality
we're living with
today today's average hourly W wage has
just about the same purchasing power it
did in
1978 following a long slide in the 80s
and 90s and bumpy inconsistent growth
since
then in fact according to the Pew
Research Institute in real terms average
hourly earnings be more than 45 years
ago in January
1973 that's the context for the right to
work laws or Right to Work For Less laws
that have been passed in 27
States they are a legacy of the ideology
of liberal free market economics that
taught that freeing up Capital to do its
thing would shower us with unprecedented
riches well it hasn't worked out that
way as we've seen so-called right to
work laws are what happens when the rich
and Powerful begin to consolidate their
gains through taking over the political
system it would help guarantee for the
businesses that run the American economy
a permanent underclass a new American
proletarian unable to push back against
the tide of inequality and dependent on
government for any protections that it
could
seek and why would we want this in New
Hampshire this has nothing to do with
the New Hampshire Advantage the New
Hampshire Advantage isn't about racing
to the
bottom why would you race to the bottom
when you're not near the bottom already
the New Hampshire economy is pretty good
we've got one of the lowest unemployment
levels in the country with median wages
just above the national average why
would we want to enact this legislation
when we can see the results in the 27
states that we have the economic policy
Institute attributes so-called right to
work laws with a 3% decline in wages for
Union and non-union workers and states
that have passed these laws 24% of jobs
in 2019 were in low-wage occupations on
almost a quarter jobs compared to 14%
low wage jobs in states without
so-called right to work
laws we don't want or need more low-wage
jobs here our low wage workers are
already struggling as it is with wages
that don't meet their needs in housing
food and other Basics that's not the New
Hampshire Advantage the New Hampshire
Advantage is not about reducing people
to beggy what we need in New Hampshire
is the ability for low wage workers to
enact Improvement in their lives through
forming a union and bargaining with
their employers whether it's Amazon or
Walmart or a grocery store chain and as
we bring back Manufacturing in new
sectors whether it's high-tech
bioengineering or offshore wind these
new skilled workers in these industries
will see better and faster gains if they
are able to bargain collectively with
their employers to provide the kind of
jobs with guaranteed wages that our
state needs to become a place where
everyone can Thrive not just survive
so-called right to work laws are not
about anyone's Freedom you're not free
to Sher your responsibility as a citizen
so why should you be free to Sher your
responsibility as a worker to your
fellow workers when you're covered by a
collective bargaining agreement workers
in a union workplace who don't want to
become full members of a union are
already protected by the National Labor
Relations Act and can choose that path
but with this law it makes free writing
on the backs of a collective bargaining
process out as something Noble when in
fact it is simply
destructive so I urge you
representatives to look at this bill for
what it is not what it sounds like it's
an attack on our prosperity and on our
ability to build a sustainable economy
please keep this bill off the house
floor and do your part for the people
and economy of New Hampshire thank
you thank you representative Kaplan are
there any questions for the
representative in the
lob seeing none are there any questions
for the
representative online
Zoom San thank you very much
representative Kaplan thank you is
representative Abramson followed by
Horgan and Perez representative
Aon uh thank you very much Mr chair can
you hear me yes we can all right uh
thank you my name is representative Max
Abramson representing the Sea Coast
towns of Hampton Hampton Falls and seab
Brook I am here on my my own behalf just
giving my own own opinion um I did
actually read sb61 when it came over um
what I'm uh what I'm opposed to in the
bill is some of the specific language I
did send an email last night with an
amendment and legislative Services just
uh this morning sent an updated version
of that email with a correcting a typo
so I I've sent that along as a uh
Amendment
107h um but I just wanted to highlight a
couple of of Provisions that have been
added in
um absolutely not opposed I absolutely
support voluntary unionization and I I
not against the a simpler Michigan style
right to work law however uh Senate Bill
61 contains a lot of additional
Provisions that shouldn't be included in
right to work um proposal to the house
uh one is it in proposed uh RSA
273- d section 4 um it probably the wor
provision which would uh is part five
which is added in which would prevent
contractors from being able to use a uh
labor union exclusively for their hiring
a lot of companies um rather than going
to a temp agency prefer to go to a union
shop um and those unions usually um
either require or recommend or offer
some type of discount on mandate
contributions uh in exchange for going
through them exclusively private
companies and Manning agencies are
allowed to do I don't see any reason why
uh a trade Union shouldn't be allowed to
um and more important than that is
companies are facing Rising liability
costs and hiring through a union is is
um hiring exclusively through a union is
a way to uh greatly cut down on that
cost I talked to a small business owner
who was paying $2,000 a month on in
insurance I think he had only one
employee um and big part of that was
liability um that was for you know
hiring and discrimination and harassment
uh coverage uh another one is uh
dsection 5 um which
includes uh a an unfunded mandate saying
every employer who receives such an
authorization from an employee shall
have a duty to promptly notify the
employee in writing that the employee
May revoke an authorization at any time
by giving the employer 30 days written
notice um that presumes it there will be
forms printed out the problem with some
of these these provisions and also in
section 7 the uh the notice to be posted
is that a lot of job sites es both Union
and non-union are are traveling I work
in road construction and we go from
bridge to highway to overpass and go
over a mile or two mile of roads in a
single night and um it's not practical
in some cases to Simply you know bring a
bullt and board along or it's not
possible in some cases to to post this
in a a prominent location it's a it's a
little bit of a an aggravation I think
it it would just cause unnecessary
problems for employers um there's
another provision in in in section six
that says that uh uh the union couldn't
authorize a boycott well a boycott
usually refers to purchasing um we just
accept the right to boycott a
company um as consumers is is just a
choice that we have so I I I didn't
agree with
that so I proposed uh in the amendment
pulling that out also um the penalties
it um some states have this 90day jail
penalty but the way it's applied in this
bill um if you have a subcontractor who
is required to move under a
grandfathered clo shop contract they
would have to sign into that clo shop
contract but this bill takes effect
immediately takes effect upon passage so
any subcontractor who was forced to go
who had to as necessity of the job to go
under the Union's jurisdiction and had
to sign into that same existing labor
contract uh would then be in Jeopardy of
a $1,000 fine um imprisonment not
exceeding 90 days or both and a
misdemeanor
conviction um I I think that that's kind
of excessive and I don't see that
anywhere else in contract law um section
11 duty to investigate it it becomes
another mandate on the Attorney
General's office and on every County
attorney would have to investigate every
single complaint um even if it seems
like a spous complaint um and shall
prosecute all persons violating all uh
any of its Provisions that
changes uh right to work which is
normally a civil cause of action it
would change it into effectively
criminal law um and it it's again it
would it seems to violate separation of
powers because it it it takes away the
discretion that prosecutors have to
recognize that many of the case cases
and violations they have are trivial and
not worth uh uh going forward with or
they may not have sufficient amount of
uh of uh uh evidence to go forward and
and obtain uh a grand jury indictment or
uh criminal charges against someone and
they would have to take the case to
trial anyway um and finally the
effective date um this act shall take
effect upon passage in my Amendment um
17h
107h uh usually when we have bills
especially coming through Commerce and
Municipal and County we have them take
effect January of next year where
possible so that we can go through the
enrollment period and ensure that there
aren't any conflicts with other bills
that have been passed this session there
probably wouldn't be one with s
sp61 uh but the Department of Labor and
other agencies uh would have to update
their forms and they need a certain
amount of time to do that and it's more
efficient to just do that uh after the
session is over and update all their
Forms and Publications um at the end of
the year so
um the the biggest issue is that we have
a lot of members who've committed to
supporting a Right to Work bill that's
known and understood in other states um
I think TW what did they say 27 other
states have already enacted a a simpler
Right to Work bill U now the Senate has
has come forward with a version that
contains a lot of additional language
that probably shouldn't be in law might
be unconstitutional and may cause um
other enforcement problems and may uh
throw the entire proposed law into the
courts and subject them to
various um uh legal challenges that
could that could put the state in a bit
of a quagmire so my preference is UHS
could you could you wrap it up please my
preference is just to put a well-known
Michigan style right to work law in
front of the house and let the members
decide it uh something that's better
understood thank you very much are there
any questions for representative abson
here in the L seeing none any online on
Zoom see none thank you very much
representative a I ask everyone to try
please just just stick within the four
minutes please representative Horgan
followed by representative Perez
followed by uh beter and Becket
uh representative Horan are you with us
um yes hopefully I'm unmuted um so my
name is Timothy Horan I represent
straford County district 6 the towns of
Durham and Madbury and um I I'd like to
thank the uh member from sebr for his
presentation he pointed out many many
things that are wrong with the bill so
even if you like the bill there's a lot
of flaws with the way it's uh way it's
implemented and I certainly don't like
the bills it's just like one flaw
interesting flaw big about boycotting
boycotting is just the act of not buying
something and
that's that's that's totally impossible
to prove why it is you're not buying
anything like like for example I used to
buy lots of Goya baked beans Goya beans
until the CEO made some statements that
I hated but hard to prove like why I did
it I just decided to start buying other
cans of beans but anyway get back to my
written testimony which I sent you uh
last night and most of you appear to
have read so this is a so-called write
to Work bill but that phrase is a misn
number work is privilege not a right now
certainly workers do have rights but
this bill does nothing to protect those
rights in fact it makes it harder for
workers to act collectively to defend
their rights um pointing out something
else that's wrong with that the Des of
labor organization is so broad it takes
in you know even things like the
Committees that probably just about any
organization with more than uh four
three or four employees has to hear from
the employers employees concerns you
know even that something like that's
illegal but it's clearly it's directed
primarily at labor unions we all know
that and labor unions are less powerful
now than really any time in several
decades but still fast the blame union
bosses for all the ills of society I'm
only have to go no further than
Governor's press conferences where he
complains like every week about the
teachers union and the union bosses you
for um so so um and then on the other
hand carpet Executives they're revered
almost as if they were Gods you know
they're almost like considered
infallible but um unions are not perfect
it's certainly not infallible the people
who run them are certainly not perfect
um I I I've met a lot of them my years
as rep most of them are pretty good
people um but all institutions are run
by you know imperfect people um people
in charge of labor unions are in fact
more accountable the members than the
people run just about any other
institution fact even including the one
that we all belong to the New Hampshire
house um you know their leaders are
elected by their members every Union
routinely offers many opportunities for
members to participate um most locals
have more work than the volunteers who
are currently working to do they always
welcome more people helping out and even
though most incompetent union leaders
are keenly aware that their members can
leave at any time you know anybody can
quit their job um even the case of Union
shops where all workers required to pay
a fee to the union each and every
individual workers always free to seek
another job we have the right to quit
and there is no profession where
unionized employees totally monopolize a
job Market I would say even the lowest
paid quote unquote unskilled low skilled
worker is a professional like um just
about every job is difficult a working
person who objects to even a tangential
involvement in Union can always seek
employment with a non-union employer um
usually and almost always in the same
profession they've been doing all along
just with a different employer um the
vast majority cases however would be
foolish to quit a union job to seek a
non-union job since just to get away
from the union at at least because
non-un jobs pay less have fewer benefits
and offer worse working conditions or
probably put it more positively a union
job pay more have more benefits and
offer better working conditions um small
amount of money deducted for Union user
agency fees is vastly outweighed by the
advantages of working a union job so
even though there is no right to work
there is as I already said always has
been the right to quit um all this bills
make it harder for workers who love
their job to work together make sure
they're treated fairly and paid what
they're paid what they're worth um so
and also speaking of the right to quick
we we heard about the low unemployment
rate we do have a strong labor market
here in New Hampshire but one of the
reasons that is there's a lot of workers
who aren't participating in the labor
force I think part of it is because
working conditions are people don't
trust employers so we had more unionized
jobs there would be uh we would have
workers have more leverage over their
employers so I think um this bill is uh
well site the fact it does a very bad
job of doing what it sets out to do is
represent remember from CBR app pointed
out but the thing that it sets out to do
is uh is um not worth doing in the first
place so the whole thing is unnecessary
so I urge you to just uh itl the bill
even though I I certainly thank him for
the work he did on the amendment so um
that's basically it that's basically
what I say B what I have to say I'd be
happy to take any questions if you feel
like asking any thank you representative
Horan there any questions for the
representative in the
lob seeing none any questions for the
representative on
Zoom seeing none thank you very much
representative forgan thank you Mr chair
thanks representative Maria Perez
followed by McCain beter and Glenn
bracket representative Perez are you
with
us yeah thank you Mr Shar and thank you
all members of the committee my name is
Maria Perez I'm representing District 23
Milford I'm a union member and proud of
a wife a union member electrical union
member the right to work is Rong for new
Hunter we know that the safe especially
electricians as my
husband the the unions protect the
safety of people like my husband and
many other who work in an industries
that they they need to have safety
conditions in order to do their jobs in
order to make sure that they
have everything necessary to make sure
they come back to our houses in one
piece safety safe and
Alive we know the unions they've been
fighting for the rights of
workers this bill is not fighting for
the rights of the workers this is taking
away rights of the work is to be Union
to be part of the Union this is taking
away the right of people to fight for
their wedges so I believe sb61 is
completely Rong for our state is
completely wrong for all the uh
hardworking people in our state thank
you very much for your time and I will
take any questions thank you
representative for Reds there are any
questions in the lb for the
representative seeing none any on
Zoom seeing none thank you
representative Perez for your
testimony next up is uh McCain beter New
England citizens Right to Work followed
by Glenn
bracket and um Bob
Dunn uh McCain Breer you're recognized
to
speak thank you Mr chair chairman
members of the committee my name is
McCain beter and I am executive director
of New England citizens for right to
work on behalf of our tens of thousands
members and supporters I'm here to speak
in support of Senate Bill 61 and the
freedom of Association that it advances
this bill would protect every individual
from being compelled to pay union dues
or fees in order to work for a living
finally making New Hampshire the 28th
right to work state unfortunately under
current law in New Hampshire a union BOS
can choose to impose Monopoly bargaining
on workers taking away an individual's
right to negotiate for themsel they then
demand the government enforced authority
to extract user fees from that
unconsenting worker adding insult to
injury as polls show the vast majority
of Voters agree it's just plain wrong
this bill would guarantee workers the
right to decide for themselves whether
or not a labor union deserves their
financial support the same as any other
private
organization once when I asked if you
would support a controversial resolution
at a national Union convention former
iosa State Education Association
executive director Fred comr said hell
no we don't support it Iowa is a right
to work state we have to earn our
membership if we supported that we'd
lose too many members you see without
Right to Work protections there's little
incentive for Union officials to offer a
good service to their members they can
compel people to pay them either way
fact is good unions don't need Force
dues and bad unions don't deserve them
furthermore it's clear that right to
work would help New Hampshire's economic
Outlook from 2009 to 2019 the percentage
growth in people employed was 88.1% in
New Hampshire and 99.6% in all such forc
unionism States right to work states on
the other hand enjoyed employment growth
of
16.9% more than double hours it's no
surprise because his area development
magazine surveys have consistently found
anywhere from 50 to 80% of Business
Leaders and site selection Consultants
consider a state's rights work status
either important or very important to
their decisions furthermore residents of
right to work states enjoy roughly
$4,500 more in average cost of living
adjusted disposable income per year
clearly not only is Right to Work the
morally right thing to do but protecting
this Freedom will also help New
Hampshire workers and the New Hampshire
economy therefore I urge all of you to
join me in supporting Senate bill 61
thank
you thank you Mr peder are there any
questions for the presenter in the
L seeing none uh on online um
representative Susi you recognize for
question than you thank Mr bet bet for
taking the question um my question is
this if you have an employer and an
employee or group of employees who
decide that um the employee they're
going to organize in a
company um you think it's worthwhile for
that employer to have to negotiate a
separate contract for each
individual or is it better that they
negotiate a contract for the group as a
whole well the employer would have the
ability to negotiate contracts uniformly
on their end regardless of the Union
status of the
employees uh in general uh varying
contracts uh offer a benefit because it
allows the incentivization of more
productive work um which especially
younger workers which New Hampshire dly
needs tend to
enjoy any further questions on Zoom
see none thank you very much oh no I
apologize there's one
more thank you uh for your testimony
represent ad I had an elected official
reach out to me and say they signed up
to speak uh just recently representative
to okay thank you very much I did have
not have that I will now recognize
representative
tol followed by Mr bracket and Bob Dunn
representative tole are you with us I am
here honorable members of the labor
committee my name is Amanda Elizabeth
tol and I represent Chesire 16 which
encompasses the city of keen at large
workers are the backbone of the American
economy and organizing has bettered
their lives unions have brought us the
weekend child labor laws and sexual
harassment laws when union membership
was at its highest workers did better
prior to the 1980s when more workers
were unionized worker gains in
productivity were coupled with wage in
increases since then as union membership
has declined these have decoupled if
American workers had gotten wage
increases in line with increases in
their labor productivity between 1980 in
2008 the average wage in 2008 would have
been 2853 an hour
42.7% higher than it was the evidence is
clear that unions benefit all workers
how however as someone who ran and got
elected on an intersectional feminist
platform I want to talk today
specifically about how unions impact
women Children and Families the right
Prides itself on saying that they are
pro- family values the overall health of
a family unit is tied to the family's
economic well-being research has shown
that a decline in Union membership
negatively impacts all workers but it
even more drastically impacts women and
folks in marginalized communities unions
have helped to narrow both the gender
and the racial wage gaps the gender wage
Gap among union members is half the size
of the wage Gap among non-union members
female union members on average earn
over $200 a week more than non-union
members the racial wage Gap is also
smaller for union workers according to
the Center for economic and policy
research black union workers on average
earn 16.4% higher wages than similar non
Union black workers union members also
have increased access to healthare which
is essential for all including women
families and marginalized communities a
CPR report found that in the service
sector for example those in unions were
about 19 percentage points more likely
to have employer provided health
insurance further union membership
increases access to paid time off for
workers everyone deserves paid time off
but this is especially impact the
quality of life for women we all know
that women do the majority of caretaking
work in our society and in their
families they are twice as likely to be
Caregivers for an elderly parent and 10
times more likely to take a day off to
care for a sick child when women don't
have access to pay time off families
suffer this can put women in an
impossible position trying to balance
caregiving responsibilities with work or
making a decision to leave the workforce
and impact their families economically
when they cannot manage that balance 82%
of unionized workers have access to
paytime off as opposed to just 62% of
non-unionized workers labor unions
emphasize inclusion and elevation of all
workers as journalist Hannah Brooks
olssen has written whereas both the
private and public sectors have talked a
big game about closing gaps in reducing
unemployment levels of people of color
lgbtqia plus folks disabled people and
many other intersections of identity
organized labor has actively pursued a
more inclusive Workforce that offers
non-discrimination protections support
of unions in organized labor is a true
pro- family position for this reason and
to show support for all workers
regardless of race gender class ability
or sexual orientation I urge you to
oppose s
sp61 thank you for hearing my testimony
I'll be deferring questions
thank you representative tol there any
questions for the representative in the
L seeing none any questions for the
representative representative kill you
have a representative you have a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question uh you're no doubt as
previously noted I'm an ELD I'm an
elderly parent and uh you know you're no
doubt aware of what this committee and
the house are doing have done with paid
family leave so could you tell me a bit
more about how union workers have this
benefit and so many of the non-un
workers don't I am going to defer
questions for the union Representatives
on the call today all right thank you I
understood thank
you thank you representative kahill any
additional questions for representative
tol seeing none thank you representative
tol I apologize for missing you on the
sheet uh on my sign in sheet thank you
very much I'm going to uh move with um
on to uh Glenn bracket and if new from
Northwood New Hampshire AFL CIO followed
by Robert Don and Sean Morrison
represent excuse me Mr Becket bracket
thank you chairman inin time for the
record uh my name is Glenn bracket I am
the President of the New Hampshire AFL
CIO and today I'm here to testify in
opposition to S
sp61 now s sp61 and Right to Work bills
like it have made our way through our
legislature every session for the last
40 years and every session we have to
listen to the same bogus CLA claims
about growing our economy and protecting
workers freedoms and these claims couldn
not be further from the truth all that
right to work laws do is to suppress
wages lower workplace safety and reduce
the quality of Public Services that we
rely on in our communities if that
weren't enough these be these laws also
work to line the pockets of outstate
lobbyists and their billionaire funders
these bills are not about what's best
for workers it's about what's best for
exploiting them proponents of right work
claim that it protects workers from
being forced to join a union but as
everybody already knows federal law does
that in fact back in 2018 Governor Chris
anunu even acknowledged that there's
quote no need to pursue any additional
legislation unquote when it comes to
right to work in New Hampshire so why
are we still pursuing this legislation
and I think I can tell you why this bill
is a distinct attempt by out ofate
corporate special interest groups to
abolish unions altogether they really
couldn't care less about the freedom of
New Hampshire's workers real freedom is
the ability to stand together with your
co-worker and negotiate for things like
retirement security workplace safety
better benefits and that's precisely
what will go away if right to work is
enacted but don't take my word for it
let's look at some numbers on average a
worker in a right to work state makes
$8500 a year less than the average New
Hampshire worker the poverty rate and
right to work states is a staggering 11%
compared to New Hampshire's
3.7 and perhaps what's the scariest is
the risk of workplace death is
unbelievably
227% more likely in a right to work
state than it is in the state of New
Hampshire it doesn't take advanced math
skills to know that Right to Work
legislation would make our state our
economy and our Working Families worse
off over the past year our workers have
sacrificed so much and and many have
died to keep our economy going to the
covid-19 pandemic the fact that this
bill will make workplaces even more
unsafe is a slap to the face of the
essential workers our lawmakers t as
Heroes so with this in mind I'm asking
you to stand with the Working Families
of New Hampshire and vote no on Senate
Bill 61 thank you for your time Mr
chairman and members of the
committee thank you Mr Brackett any
questions here in the L I have one for
you Mr bracket how would an acting right
to work
make Union
shops unsafe or less safe as you just
said it makes it less safe because the
union has the opportunity if there's an
unsafe condition on a workplace the
union has the right to approach
management without fear of Retribution
or loss of job to say to management this
is unsafe if you don't if you're not in
a union you don't have just C you don't
have just cause protection your employee
at will coming forward in a non-union
job with a complaint about work safely
is likely to get you unemployed
quickly thank you any questions online
for Mr
bracket Sullivan you recognize for
question you're on mute
sir get off to a good start um Mr
bracket um the committee received SE
several um uh letters via email from uh
contractors um in fact groups of
contractors would sign on to uh at least
three or four letters um in opposition
to right to work uh could could you
explain or can you explain why it would
be that that um employers are opposing
Right to Work sure and and and I'm G to
I'm going to go parochial just for a
second here I'm an electrical worker
I've been a union electrical worker for
42 years this is how it works the
electrical industry the union with their
own money establishes a training center
there's no taxpayer money involved
there's no private money involved it's
Union money they establish a training
center we we hire we bring on people and
say Here's what we're going to do we're
going to bring you in free no expense to
you we're going to train you for five
years on all ask ects of being an
electrician at the end of five years you
will graduate as a licensed electrician
in the state of New Hampshire you'll
have a pension benefit and you'll have
health care we can place you in jobs
because we have agreements with
signatory contractors who love the fact
that they can ask for five or six
licensed electricians to go to the
shipyard on Monday and they know they're
going to get a qualified electrician who
can pass a security background who can
pass a drug test who's fully qualified
in OSHA and they don't have any worries
about the employee coming in but the
deal is when somebody comes in the door
in The Apprentice program they
understand that the way that their
training was paid for is those that came
before them paid so they get trained
there is no taxpayer money involved in
this and the agreement between two
private entities Union is a business we
pay taxes just like everybody else we
make a contract with an employer
that agrees with our funding mechanism
to train our employees because it's
win-win for everybody it is it is the
free market working together what Right
to Work would do would make the
agreement that the unions have the
unions that train their people and
provide them it would make the contract
we have with our employers illegal we
couldn't have the agreement we've had
for 50 years that has worked for
everybody and I think altogether you're
going to see between 50 and 60
businesses who aren't real happy with
the state of New Hampshire is still
messing with this um and I I got to tell
you I don't understand why the
legislature wants to get into contracts
between two private businesses I don't
understand that but I'll leave that to
someone else to explain thank
you thank you are there any additional
questions Representatives seaworth you
recognized thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you Mr bracket for your testimony
in answering that last question you were
talking about the funding for training
programs and I was wondering in in terms
of this bill does that funding come from
agency fee or is that funding only from
uh union
members
um it comes directly from union
members that's that's the
agreement thank
you
any additional
questions the L see no hands online
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman the next call H Bob Dunn
followed by Shan Morrison and Greg Moran
Mr dun from Manchester representing the
Roman Catholic bishop of Manchester
Roman Catholic bishop of Manchester Mr
dun are you with us yes thank you Mr
chairman uh and members of the committee
good morning I'm Bob done the director
of public policy for the Roman Catholic
dasis of Manchester and uh on behalf of
Bishop Peter lashi I want to
respectfully register our opposition to
sb61 and I've also submitted written
testimony um back in 1981 Pope John Paul
II issued an important letter that was
called on human work and he focused on
the Dignity of work and one of the
central points uh that he made in the
letter
a point that I think probably we all can
agree on uh was to emphasize the
priority of people over things and that
the economy has to serve human beings
and not the other way around um and in
light of that uh John Paul called labor
unions indispensable elements of social
life in modern society that have the
role of securing the just rights of
workers within the framework of the
common good of the whole society
um and with that in mind there are three
questions that we would offer up as a
useful framework for deliberation on
Senate Bill
61 first of all does it benefit the
common
good second does it provide a just
balance between the interests of workers
and
employers and third does it protect the
natural right of workers to assemble and
form associations
and because we think that
sb61 would diminish the ability of
unions to carry out their duties we
believe that these questions produce
negative answers uh and for that reason
we respectfully oppose the bill uh thank
you very much for your uh consideration
and for the opportunity to comment
today thank you Mr Don any questions for
Mr here
theis L see none any questions for Mr
thank you very much for your testimony
Mr D next up will be Sean Morrison Fall
by Greg Greg Moran and Janice
C
Mr Mr Morrison from fing former
representative that's correct can you
hear
me than
much uh good morning um I am sea Marrs
and former State Rep formerly on the
labor committee uh and representing
myself but I am from eping I I am a
union firefighter and a lifelong
Republican I'm speaking uh because I
believe that this is the most important
legislation facing New Hampshire and the
future political climate in New
Hampshire today uh what
sb61 actually is is the good old hi I'm
from the government and I'm here to help
um and I believe this is absolutely true
because in this case not one taxpayer
dollar will be affected by this bill uh
because as we all know with the Jan
decision teachers firefighters cops and
every other federal state or Municipal
Employee already has right to work um
and also like to note that you didn't
see any mass e-lux of any union workers
when that did pass um just for the
record I'd like to say that uh I believe
the Nea is one of the worst institutions
in America and needs a lot of fixing but
uh this is not the way to fix it as a
Republican state rep I put on three
trade career affirs uh involving all of
the trades and I'm going to put on more
and I would I got I would say 40 to 50
New Hampshire residents lifelong careers
for which they paid not one dime to
obtain and uh these careers pay $100,000
after five or six years these careers
are also much needed as we know if
anybody's ever tried to get a plumber or
an electrician in in short time um more
than likely because you had uh the
school systems telling our kids that
they need to go and get a bachelor's
degree even if it's in basket weaving in
order to be successful uh those poor
kids are riddled with debt right now but
none of the 40 or 50 workers that I
helped get lifelong careers are in any
debt at all uh the trades I'd like to
focus on the trades uh these you the
plumbers carpers electricians iron
workers Etc they offer New Hampshire
residents a chance to show up on day one
not even know what a screw driver is and
get paid on that day one uh and while
they begin their their career they're
while they're getting paid on day one
they're trained in these apprenticeship
programs and these apprenticeship
programs are funded by the unions not
only do they get this free training uh
rather than pay for a trade school but
you also have a business agent for these
unions going out and getting the actual
work for these
workers um just wanted to point that out
as well um a vote for this bill is a
vote to kill that free training in these
lifelong careers for all of our New
Hampshire residents because they're not
going to be able to put on these
apprenticeships that many people that
you most of them are uh many of them are
Associates degrees programs now and you
could do this or you could go and you
could pay for your own schooling uh
there's your choice there the big
argument is that no one should be forced
to junor Union but uh that statement is
fake news and I have laws to back that
up this isn't hyperbole or opinion um
federal law no one can be forced to join
Union that is communication work is vers
Beck that provides that there are agency
fees uh that an employee can pay in lie
of joining a union those fees are paid
for representation at the negotiating
table because as we all know per the
Taft heartley act uh in 1947 all unions
must represent all employees whether
they are in the union or not and nobody
wants preloaders correct um federal law
the National Labor Relations Act if an
employees of any company do not wish to
have a union representing them
all it takes is 30% of those workers to
demand a vote to abolish the union and a
simple majority to abolish that Union no
one is forced to stay in or to join
these unions um Talk politics here uh
per federal law no union dues can be
used for political purposes unless the
employee signs a paper donating to the
political action committee I in fact
don't donate to mind but that's a fact
if you think you can prove that a union
does use dues for politics illegally
just press charges because the law is
there um I'd like to speak to my fellow
Republicans without trying to offend
anybody um right now but this is about
politics uh 36% of union workers in New
Hampshire are registered Democrats the
rest are either Republican or
independent
um this bill is a loser this this
concept is zero for
48 in the state of New Hampshire and I
just want to point out if you I don't
know if I'm on camera here can anybody
see
that no okay so in the last time we
passed this bill in the House of
Representatives it it got killed in the
Senate but Republicans lost 109 seats in
the House of Representatives that's the
definition of trying to win a battle and
losing the war
um also I have a flyer here that back in
1956 I guess you can't see it so it
doesn't have its impact young
Republicans salute labor and it tells
the best working conditions in history
please go to your union meeting and
register to vote Republican so uh in
closing I just want to say to my fellow
Republicans I do not know one iron
worker plumber electrician or Carpenter
who wants no borders uh or wants uh uh
illegal aliens frankly coming over the
border and working undercutting Union
contracts down south which it happens
every day um so these I I think it's
critical why I'm I'm passionate about
this bill at this time is uh on my side
I am a republican um I I I believe that
now is the time uh to get these
red-blooded bluecollar Americans back
into our party and to just leave them
out of politics uh if you wish to
restrict what unions can do such as say
the Nea being able to uh sit at the
table designing curriculum well fix that
this bill does not fix that um but right
now these red-blooded bluecollar
Americans are ready to back whoever
backs them and the Republican party
needs them in our party in order to
remain in the in the majority
um we're at a very critical time in our
history here I believe we're living
under under many many socialist laws if
we pass this we're going to lose the
majority and me and my kids and my
family are going to live under more
socialist laws so please think about the
war as opposed to the battle if you
don't agree with any of the I said we
got to think tactically and with that
I'll close thank you very much it's nice
to see you all by the
way thank you any questions here at the
lob for this for the presenter
representative
turot thank you Mr chairman good
morning representative or former
representative Morrison how are you how
are good how are you I'm doing well Sean
hey uh one question actually it's
probably take a couple um
are you are you still active in the
firefighters I I didn't know if you had
retired yet no no no I'm still working
okay uh then the question is I've been
trying to get this question answered now
for quite a while and nobody seems to
have a a number or idea of the effects
since you're still effective in your
firefighters Union could you tell me
since Janice occurred in 2018 what
percentage of your fellow firefighters
have uh elected to uh not pay uh belong
to the union and not pay union
dues well as far as I know that the
answer to that is zero because we want a
representation at the negotiating table
um and I'll leave it at that I just had
another thought that uh left my mind I
apologize thank you that was perfect you
have a followup Reserve turot no I'm
good all right any other questions for
Mr Morrison
I don't see any
online none in the L thank you very much
for your testimony be safe thank
you Greg Moran followed by Janice Kelby
and Lisa
Shapiro Greg Moran from Spring pel
Virginia National Right to Work
committee yeah thank you uh glad to be
here with you I appreciate you giving me
a moment to speak with you I have some
prepared remarks that I'll submit online
I'm instead going to use this time to
address a number of misconceptions that
I've heard over the last few minutes uh
the twin sources of Big labor power are
Monopoly bargaining and force dues and
while you have heard from New
Hampshire's Union leadership and others
and will continue to hear it um it is a
it is absolutely misinformation to claim
that federal law does not require
requires them to represent all workers
the truth is that Union officials are
perfectly free under federal law to
negotiate a contract that only sets the
terms and conditions for their own
voluntary members but instead of
exercising this perfectly legitimate
option today's Union officials
consistently take advantage of the
provisions of federal law that give them
the tyrannical power to force every
worker to submit to their Monopoly
representation whether that worker likes
that representation and thinks it's
doing well for him or Not by exercising
this power they forbid individual
workers to represent themselves and then
these same Union officials turn around
and falsely complain that since they
represent non-paying workers the very
same workers whose right to
self-representation the union leaders
have just Stripped Away they should then
be entitled to forc dues the truth of
the matter is the Union contract is not
a universal benefit to all employees a
contract that benefits seniority works
against employees who want to work
harder smarter or longer and be
compensated and rewarded for it a
contract with a goldplated Health Care
Health Benefit system works against a
younger healthier employee who might
prefer to uh have an extra dollar an
hour instead and a a a stripped down
health care benefit system I'm not
arguing one way or the other for for or
against those proposals I'm simply
saying that if the employee is not happy
with the job the union is doing
representing him he shouldn't be forced
to pay for it a number of other
misconceptions that I have heard um
specifically from uh representative
abrahamson that I wanted to uh to
address uh the biggest one uh was also
addressed by the gentleman from the AFL
CIO about union hiring halls and the
apprenticeship uh training that they do
the fact of the matter is say this right
to work law would not affect union
hiring halls in any way U csection d134
of the bill explicitly says the bill
does not apply where preempted by
federal law and of course even if that
section was there wasn't there it still
couldn't apply where preempted by
federal law and federal law has long
since said that state right to work laws
do not apply to union hiring Halls so
all of that concern is is does does not
even exist anymore it's no more valid
than than the concerns of public
employees who are already covered by
Janice and already have right to
work
um representative abrahamson mentioned
uh concerned about the section seven uh
notice posting requirement every
employer is already required to post a
number of notices by the federal
government and probably by your state
government as well this where what
whatever system they already have for
that this notice is simply going to have
to go alongside those and to say that
that you can't bring it along to a job
site is is really just not a valid
concern um section six talking about
Union boycott uh forbidding a boycott uh
it's not a generic boycott it's I'll
read you the section any strike
picketing boycott or other action by a
labor organization for the sole purpose
of inducing or attempting to induce an
employer to enter into any agreement
prohibited under this chapter is
declared to be illegal in other words
you can't do a boycott for the purpose
of trying to get a forc dues Clause uh
it's as simple as that uh the criminal
penalties are there uh as they are in
most other state right to work laws
because if you don't include a criminal
penalty then the union is going to push
for a a right to work law uh I'm sorry
the union is going to push for a forc
dues Clause they can pressure employers
to sign it and just pay the fine as and
consider it cost of doing business so
without a without a criminal penalty the
right to work law really has no teeth uh
the Mandate on Investigation again uh is
what puts teeth into this right to work
law and you can talk to the Attorneys
General of the right to work states have
statements from several of them we'll be
happy to send you that the extra cost
imposed on them is is really di Minimus
on this uh uh the other concern I heard
was about a subcontractor who was uh
joins into a grandfathered Force dues
Clause uh that uh supposedly would be uh
then uh in Jeopardy of criminal
penalties no if they're forced to work
under a grandfathered Force Do's Clause
the grandfather clause applies to them
as well so that also is really not a
valid concern uh the truth of the matter
is that a a
a employee unhappy with his Union
representation is uh is is not looking
for a free ride what they really want is
to get out they can't get out because
federal law lets the unions force them
to stay in but it's just rubbing salt in
the wound to to say you have to accept
representation you don't like didn't ask
for and think you'd be better off
without and now you have to pay for it
too so uh that's uh that concludes my uh
remarks I'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you representative uh Adent do you
have a question for the presenter I do
thank you for taking my question um
you're calling us today from Virginia a
state that is built not New Hampshire
and is 503 miles away from New Hampshire
but you're 70 miles away from Charleston
West Virginia uh where Republican
Governor Jim justice has gone on record
to saying that right to work was a bad
idea for West Virginia and that the mass
influx of jobs and opportunity that were
promised by folks representing industry
never came why do you think the governor
of a state that has an elected a
Democrat for president in 25 years would
say that he regrets a right to work
law uh he doesn't actually regret the
right to work law if you read that whole
uh interview that you're s pulling that
from he actually says that he does
support the right to work law and he's
glad they have it uh regarding my
presence in Virginia I I'm representing
the national Right to Work act we have
members in all 50 states and I am uh
before you today representing all of our
members in New
Hampshire
representative representative
kahill uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Morad for taking my question so
you're as my colleague said you're
you're not presenting the national
rights of work and so you're thinking
that 27 states have right to work and
here in New Hampshire you know we we
don't have Right to Work 42 states have
income taxes and 45 have sales taxes
would you say that any of those are good
for new hamper should we just follow the
lead because what someone else has done
jump off a bridge as your might have
asked
representative uh I have no opinion on
sales taxes versus income taxes as a
spokesman for the national Right to Work
committee that's uh not my job to
comment
on helpful thank
you any additional
questions thank you Mr morand for your
testimony next up next up is Janice kby
followed by Lisa seiro and Dave juet
Janice I tried to get you in as quickly
as 11 as you requested are you with us
yes thank you so much for taking my
testimony uh my name is Janice Kelby and
I'm a retired postal worker I now live
in hooks at New Hampshire when I was
first hired I was a single single parent
and I wanted a job with good benefits
that the union had negotiated for Postal
Service career employees with the Postal
Service it was crystal clear that the
union was responsible for making this
the job that I desired because the
Postal Service had another category of
employees called casuals these were not
necessarily short timers some had worked
there for over 10 years were not a part
of any bargaining unit and could not
belong to a union their wages were far
less than mine although they often did
identical work they got no sick leave no
health benefits and no retirement
benefits folks were not knocking the
doors down to become
unrepresented casuals they wanted career
jobs complete with all the benefits that
had been negotiated by the union I don't
believe that any worker who tells you
they want nothing to do with the Union
is telling you the whole truth they do
want the benefits achieved by the union
otherwise they would probably be looking
for work somewhere else sadly these
benefits don't just fall out of the sky
you can go ask a postal casual about
that sadly working for the USPS is
somewhat like being in a right to work
state people who choose not to join a
union don't share in the cost of
representation most postal workers do
join but not all having some enjoy
contract benefits without helping to pay
for them causes Division and resentment
it doesn't benefit F the workers or the
employer and certainly does nothing for
productivity the union is obligated to
by law to represent these non-members
who pay nothing not even for their own
personal representation I remember my
local defending a non-member in
arbitration 15 years ago and the cost
was over
$1,500 back then the bigger issue is the
considerable resources required to
negotiate our contract if National
postal negotiation reach an impa the
dispute goes to an arbitrator I once
testified at a national arbitration
about the duties of a male processing
clerk I heard testimony from The
Economist and other experts listening to
The Economist I wondered how many hours
of research and preparation went into
her testimony the union paid for that
work without her testimony we never
would have convinced the arbitrator to
upgrade the pay for that job the gains
from that arbitration benefited us all
all even the guy who didn't pay his fair
share people have a real right to work
right now in New Hampshire we have the
right to work in a place that has a
union shop or to choose a new a
non-union shop even in Union workplaces
not all work Union workplaces have a
fair share Clause employers have to
agree so if an employer negotiates a
fair share as a condition of employment
the state has no business interfering
just as it has no business interfering
with a dress code policy in the work
workplace if a person doesn't like a
company's fair share employment policy
or doesn't like the dress code they have
a perfect right to work somewhere else
without such a policy my union struggles
to meet the financial burden caused by
those who refuse to pay their fair share
if enough people decided not to do it
then the union would be seriously
weakened lessen lessening our ability to
negotiate decent wages and benefits this
would have a serious negative impact on
our state without the benefits negotia
by my union I could not afford a house
and I couldn't afford to support local
New Hampshire businesses the way I do
now s sp61 does nothing to expand
anyone's right to work it would serve
only to weaken unions to lower our
standard of living and to hurt the New
Hampshire economy the state should not
interfere with collective bargaining and
the employer's decision to negotiate an
employment policy that requires workers
to pay their share of the cost of
services that they enjoy and I just want
to add one other quick thing and that is
when I started my job and I'm definitely
tell telling my age here but when I
started my job in the mid 70s I remember
the death of a postal employee Michael
mcdad I still remember his name he was a
young father who got sucked into a
conveyor belt in New York on the docks
of a post office and our Union mounted a
huge saf campaign that changed the laws
that stop the deaths and stop people
from being sucked into conveyor belts
they made that difference and that's
what they do for safety so that's why
it's important for me to keep the
strength of our Union thank you so
much thank you for your testimony any
questions in the
L sing any questions
online sing n thank you very much for
your testimony Mr chairman thank you is
it in order to take 20 seconds of Point
personal privilege to correct the record
from a couple minutes
ago
um yes go ahead repres thank you Mr
chairman I just want to clarify because
in the discussion I had with the fellow
from National right to work there was a
disagreement on the quote from Governor
Justice and I got the source so I just
wanted to read that the record this is
from the metro news uh the voice of West
Virginia uh that was the moment Justice
a republican told citizens that the key
policies put forth by state officials in
recent years haven't paid off those
included right to work in the
elimination of prevailing wage both top
priorities of the Republican wave that
swpt into swept into the legislature
just a few years ago quote really and
truly let's be brutally honest the
governor said we passed right to work a
lot in West Virginia we ran to the
windows looking to see all the people
that were going to come and they didn't
we got rid of prevailing wage and we
changed our tax structure and we've run
to the windows each time and they
haven't
come thank you representative I will
remind all the representatives um that I
would like everyone to have some
courtesy toward our presenters there was
criticism made about someone being from
out of state uh would you like me to uh
criticize other people uh opposed to
this bill uh that are from Boston and
out of state as well I think not so
please show some courtesy to our
presenters
I will continue with Mr pero followed by
Dave juv and Richard Galia Mr pero are
you with
us good morning Mr chairman members of
the
committee you can hear me okay yes we
can thank you my name is Dr Lisa Shapiro
I'm Chief Economist at Gallagher
Callahan and gar tril in conquered New
Hampshire
I am here today on behalf of the AFL CIO
in opposition to Senate Bill
61 Right to Work Advocates assert that
right to work states
outperform non-right toor states that's
what we've heard this morning these
arguments should be rejected for four
reasons and I'll be succinct first
economic growth data shows that
economies in non-ri to work States
outperformed right to work states by
nearly three percentage points during
the most recent expansionary period
prior to the pandemic furthermore
economies in non-right to work states
like New Hampshire outperform the five
newest comers to Right to Work by more
than six and a half percentage points of
economic growth now looking just at New
Hampshire New Hampshire's wage growth
during this this period exceeded the
average for all the right to work states
we produced more
apprentices apprenticeships lower worker
fatality rates and on the productivity
side New Hampshire produces nearly
$1,650 more in Gross State product per
worker than a right to work states
proponents Overlook these key
performance metrics of worker safety
poverty
life expectancy benefit coverage and
wage and economic
growth second there are better
explanations for why some right to work
states are performing well for example
electric prices on average are 50%
higher in non-right to work states like
New Hampshire and the tax climate on
average is more favorable to businesses
overall in right to work states compared
to non-ri to work states these are well
documented factors in States economic
performance but proponents fail to
control for these
explanations third Right to Work hurts
workers while helping bosses and
investors based on peer reviewed studies
so so far we've just been talking about
statistics on both sides States versus
States right to work versus non-right to
work but now let's look at the peer
reviewed studies and in the Journal of
financial economics just last year um
academics uh business professors from
Georgia Institute of Technology reviewed
data from over
18,000 collective bargaining agreements
as well well as corporate data both
before and after right to work was
adopted and across different states over
time the findings include the following
that post Right to Work wages and job
security for unionized workers
decreased while dividends and corporate
executive compensation
increased fourth there is a strong
libertarian argument against Right to
Work Milton Freedman and other prominent
Libertarians have been consistently
against right to work so in conclusion
right to work is a new and dramatic
intervention into the private sector
contracts while the evidence suggests it
will have negative impacts in New
Hampshire um uh Mr chairman members of
the committee I'll respond to any
questions thank you very much for your
time I appreciate the thought you're
putting into this important issue thank
you for your testimony any questions for
the presenter in the
L seeing none are there any questions
online see see uh yes representative
Sullivan who's still on
mute thank you Mr chairman um Dr Shapiro
um we've heard a lot of uh economic
statistics thrown around uh already
today and I'm sure there there will be
more um but I believe you're the first
Economist to throw around economic
statistics could you give us just a
little bit more about your background so
we know whether uh just know more about
your background sure uh thank you uh
representative Sullivan um in the uh
early 1990s I completed my PhD in
economics from the John's Hopkins
University and uh moved up to New
Hampshire with my husband uh who's from
New Hampshire in the early 90s and I
wrote my doctoral thesis on voting
behavior and taxes in New Hampshire in
the 1990s for the last 25 years I've
authored numerous economic and financial
impact studies especially during the
first 15 years of my career up here
including the Statewide property tax
study you've probably heard the word
donor I put that in my report donor tax
donor towns I've looked at the impact of
business and um industry and the uh
various uh proposals over time to
increase taxes I've done work for
Community Development Finance Authority
Housing Finance Authority a number of
other public policy programs on the
economic impact I've been an expert
witness on local property taxes and many
different energy proceedings in New
Hampshire and around New England and I
represent mostly uh business and Health
Care clients and I have uh represented
the AFL CIO a few years ago when Right
to Work came up last time my Approach as
an economist uh in this issue was really
to look at both sides and I I think
that's where kind of you see statistics
on both sides uh pointing to New
Hampshire doing better doing worse and
that's why I really think it's important
to look at the academic literature where
you have to stand up to peer review and
see what actually happens and here when
we look at the actual facts in published
articles I was able to determine that
there is the consensus finding that
there is these both negative and
positive impacts from right to work and
that's what I'm sharing with you here
today thank
you any additional questions of the
committee members on
Zoom see none thank you very much oh
there is there's one here in the
committee room uh representative H
you're recognized thank you Mr chair um
Dr
sharo you mentioned uh some of the
successes uh that New Hampshire
enjoys um and without going over all of
them um I'm just curious It's my
understanding and correct me if I'm
wrong but in New Hampshire uh Union
employees are around 11% and non-union
employees workers are around
89% is it your position that the success
that New Hampshire enjoys is brought
about because of the Union the
11% instead of the 89% that are not
un I my testimony today was about the
facts of the economy and the facts that
have been put forward about the
relationship between right to work and
success and New Hampshire's the the data
is very clear that the response to right
to work is lower wages lower
benefits higher executive compensation
and
dividends that's what the data shows you
folks have the public policy choice of
whether you think that's going to
improve New Hampshire or not when the
findings are very significant negative
impacts
the um 11 it's actually around 10% of
unions and it's actually less when
you're just looking at private sector
and it varies across Industries the
current New Hampshire economy reflects
the union representation and the union
presence in the trades and utilities and
other industries that you've heard about
today that's part of the myu I'm not I'm
not taking a position on the factors and
I didn't perform a study on New
Hampshire's uh role of the unions we can
look at the facts of New Hampshire's
economy and look at the facts of what
right to work has done in other states
to wages and benefits and to the uh the
the successes of the businesses and who
gains from those successes and what
we've seen in the literature is there's
a shift toward executive compensation
and dividends in when right to work is
adopted and uh the collective bargaining
agreements go are reduced the number are
reduced as well as the
wages thank you follow
follow thank you for your answer um the
followup
is are those benefits that you're
talking about you mention um are those
strictly for U the shops the employees
uh in those uh States or is that for the
overall of all uh
businesses
States the uh the only mention I had of
benefits was in one of the statistical
comparisons and that's not just of union
jobs that's in terms of the penetration
rates for the percent of total workers
in a state that have benefits so that
that was state level data not based on
whether it's a union job or not a union
job thank you a question for thank you
chairman and uh thank you Dr sh for the
question um you mentioned the shift
towards uh CEO compensation over the
last several decades we had a rep
earlier uh that testified the same thing
um American wages for the longest time
have been stagnant uh since about
1970 um very con very coincidentally uh
no state in the United States
has more Union participation as Alabama
did in 1946 you believe there's a
possibility of correlation
there um as an economist I think it's
really really important and what I've
tried to provide for you today by the
analysis of the statistics on both sides
is oneoff statistics are nice
observations but they're not based on a
model or conclusion or rigorous review
so you know one State's success or
failure is a uh an interesting
observation but I can't comment on
correlation or causation because that's
not a model that that that's not
something that try to based on how firms
behave how they make investments what
are the incentives so whether Alabama
did this or Indiana did that um is not
an economic model it's a comment so I
can't tell you whether it's correlation
or causation I don't know what part of
the analysis you know that that would be
I'm sorry I don't have enough background
to respond to that thank you
representative turot you're recognized
for a question thank you Mr chairman
thank you uh for taking the
question I I I guess I'm a little
confused are is your testimony in
support of right to work or against
right to work
I'm against right to work thank you no
that's fine thank you thank sorry any
additional questions uh in the
L seeing none any
online thank you very much for your
testimony thank you is Dave juv followed
by Richard Gula and Greg
Moore Mr
juv business industry Association thank
you Mr chair can everyone hear me okay
yes thank you for the record my name is
Dave juv I'm a senior vice president
with the business and industry
Association we serve as New Hampshire
Statewide Chamber of Commerce and we
have 400 plus company members that are a
part of our association I'd like to make
three very quick points one is um the
Janice decision has been raised earlier
by earlier people testifying but there
hasn't been a lot of conversation about
it and what that decision did from the
US Supreme Court in 2008 18 is
essentially create right to work for
public sector
employees and it hasn't proven to be an
Armageddon it hasn't proven to be the uh
death of of public sector uh employee
unions um it have we haven't seen a
flood of public sector employees uh
choosing to uh not pay union dues or not
pay agency fees it it it just hasn't
been the um you just haven't heard uh
the horrible effect that it has had that
that uh opponents are right to work are
suggesting what happen if you pass this
bill um we think that uh reason is
because uh public sector employee unions
are having to work hard they're having
to show their value and they are showing
their value and and in response union
members are are uh supporting them by
paying their Union does uh we think the
same thing could happen in New Hampshire
with private sector unions if Senate
Bill 61 uh passes and and I guess I
should say in passing that the Bia
supports Senate Bill 61 the second uh
point I'd like to make is that we do
believe there is an economic opportunity
here New Hampshire uh would be the only
state in the northeastern United States
to uh uh be right to work state if this
bill is passed and signed into law and
we think that's significant because we
know there are New Hampshire employers
and companies across the country that
will only choose to uh expand or locate
in right to work states and no it's not
the only factor that companies use but
it is an important factor and and one
that she we shouldn't dismiss so I would
urge uh the committee to
uh recommend this bill ought to pass um
and I would be happy to address any
questions thank you Mr juet are there
any questions for the presenter on
Zoom representative Susie recognize her
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr juv for taking my
question real quickly uh back in
February you tested before this
committee on Two Bills uh one dealt with
sick time and the other one dealt with
earned but unused um paid
leave and you testified and stated that
you don't think that government
interference government interference
should take place and privately held
businesses and you've said that on two
occasions so my question is if that's
how the Bia felt then what changes the
Bia stance on this bill why do we need
government intrusion on privately held
businesses well the difference
representative sus I do appreciate your
question the the difference is
um one could uh conclude that you're
absent uh right to work there's no
government intrusion on uh business and
labor relations and and you and I both
know that's not correct uh there's been
uh federal labor regulations stretching
back back to the 30s and 40s uh that uh
regulate how uh uh labor and management
can conduct uh their Affairs so to
suggest that this is some new government
intrusion on employers I think is is
incorrect secondly this isn't an issue
of whether it's um appropriate for the
company or appropriate for the Union to
have have this type of um Power to force
individuals to pay union dues or Force
individuals to pay agency fees this is
about the individual employee and
allowing them to make a decision on
what's right for
them followup follow up so I'll ask the
say I'll ask you the same question I
asked someone
earlier if a private held
business
decides along with the employees that
they are going to have this Union
represent them as the sole negotiating
agent for this
business do you really think that if a
company has 200
employees that the
employer recognizing the sole bargaining
agent really wants to represent every
employee and negotiate every contract
with every single employee do you think
that's beneficial to the company well I
can't answer for every employer but but
I I can answer that the employer can
still choose to collectively bargain
with with the union and that employee
would be a part of that uh collective
bargaining and one more followup Mr
chairman
followup Mr juv how many companies that
you represent are actual Union
companies well that's a a great question
and and honestly I don't know the answer
to that however I know we do have a
number of uh utilities and manufacturing
companies that uh do have unions and
there may be others I I honestly don't
know uh what number or what percentage
of our membership has unions and Mr
chairman if you can Doge me for one more
yes sir go ahead thank you thank you Mr
duv is it am I correct in stating that
Liberty
Utilities is part of your membership and
that Liberty Utilities is opposed to S
sp61 um it is correct that they are in
our membership and I would prefer for
Liberty Utilities to State their
position rather rather than me stating
it for them and Mr chairman if you don't
mind one
more because you're such a good guy
representative Susi one more thank you
very much and Mr juv this is going to be
would you believe would you believe that
I'm in receipt of a letter from Sue
Fleck that opposes sb61 and I think we
all got it in the committee I I would
believe that and I would support uh M
Fleck and Liberty Utilities from stating
their position on this bill that's
that's the kind of state that we live in
thank you very much
sir any other questions on Zoom seeing
none represented I see your
hand thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr J taking the question you testified
that uh there wasn't this
Armageddon um post the Supreme Court
decision and and I guess I'm I'm asking
in Earnest
because um if a right to work work law
wouldn't have a discernable impact on
Union membership Union
participation that why would not only
the the take position on it but why is
it a deciding factor for businesses if
it's G to have no impact on the unions
that we have to do
with um I don't know that it will have
no impact on private sector Union
organization rep representative I do
think it will require private sector
unions to to demonstrate their value
every day the way Bia and other trade
associations and Chambers do we can't
force any business to to be a member of
the Bia and charge the membership dues
even though the work we do we think
benefits all businesses in New Hampshire
in terms of uh why companies would
consider that important I think most
companies would prefer to uh have Direct
Communications with their employees
rather than through the layer of of a
union
negotiation thank you um you you also
mentioned that there were uh this would
be the only state um in New England that
would be a right to work state um and
because of that that there would be
businesses that would be intending to
come here uh do you know any of the
specific spefic businesses that consider
that or any specific industries that
consider that um or what that makeup of
the L of water
like I don't have the names of
individual businesses but I do know that
site location companies these are uh
companies that work with employers on
business location and
relocation list right to work as um a a
uh characteristic that some not all but
some
businesses uh use in terms of of uh
making decisions about where they will
locate or expand and I know from uh
companies within our membership that
they have suggested that they their
expansion would be in in right to work
states and and not in non-right to work
states one more followup thank you Mr
chairman um I'd like to use a metaphor
of Mr TR so you come see where I've
coming from on this um it is we have a
birthday on the committee of
Representative K Hill and in continuity
with that um I purchased a mystery box
I'm not gonna take it out because I
don't know the rules on props committee
but in my bag I've got a mystery box you
don't know what's in it would you be
willing to purchase that mystery box
without knowing the contents of it
first
um this seems a little far a field from
the public policy discussion we're
having I guess I will answer by first of
all um my good friend representative
kill a happy birthday please
hold I
appreciate the
question I think what you you you stated
that it was a
metaphor please ask the question
I think you're trying to ask and I want
to be specific
here since you don't know what's going
to happen with right to work why would
you be voting in support is that your
question yes thank you the box was just
an extension understood Mr
ju um I think we can look to examples of
uh uh how right to work is uh worked in
many other states and is it has been uh
mentioned earlier there are 27 other
states around the country that have had
this many for decades um and I think if
you look you you will find that the
experience has been positive um I think
unintended consequences is is something
that you as public policy makers wrestle
with on all kinds of
legislation but you you look to uh data
and and use that to try and make what
you think is the best
decision all right thank you very much
for Testimony I see no additional
questions so people know what's coming
up Richard ghoul is next Greg Moore
Viola or Jim Durkin
Viola Kimi so uh next up Richard gup um
are you with us Richard is from the sea
SEIU uh and is a lobbyist from Hillsboro
I am can you hear me yes we can great um
thank you Mr chair honorable
Representatives uh thank you for
allowing me to testif testify today in
opposition to s sp61 for the record my
name is Richard gulla and I am president
of the state employees Association SEIU
Local 1984 we represent more than 10,000
workers in the state County Municipal
and private
sectors despite its misleading name
Right to Work legislation is nothing
more than a union busting bill it has
nothing to do with increasing wages
benefits or safety for that matter for
working people and everything to do with
weakening unions and removing worker
protections Right to Work legislation
hurts the economy in study after study
the legislation has proven to be wrong
for workers wrong for businesses and
wrong for the economy recently the
online political website political came
out with a ranking of all 50 states
using a combination of Life quality
issues including crime rates per capita
income and education levels they
averaged the 14 scores create a single
ranking across the Spectrum I'm sure it
will be no surprise to anyone in this
room to learn that the Hampshire a
non-right to work state top the list is
one of the best states to live in
something that we can all be proud of
here in New Hampshire but what amazed me
was that four out of the top five were
all non-right to work working States and
that right to work states account for
eight eight out of 10 of the worst
states to live in including the worst
five states in which to live in fact the
majority of right to work states are not
only below average but in the bottom 20
of the 50
states how is this possible well let's
talk about that workers in right to work
states make an average of $1,500 less
per year and produce 15% Less in gross
domestic product than do workers in
states without these laws workers in
right to work states are less likely to
have health
insurance more workers are likely to be
injured or even killed on the job in
states with these right to work
laws communities lose jobs and Right to
Work legislation lower wages and
benefits seven out of 10 states with the
highest unemployment rates are right to
work
states we have a great tradition here in
New Hampshire of working together to
make it the best place to live in this
country let's continue that good work
and set aside this divisive and partisan
legislation by voting no it's bad for
our citizens it's bad for our businesses
and it's bad for our state let's keep
New Hampshire on top of everyone's list
of best places to live thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for the
representative in the L there is
representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr go for your
testimony um your organization as you
said represents public sector workers as
well as private
workers and um because of that I would
think you might be uniquely placed to
talk about how the portion of those
employees who work in the public sector
have been
impacted uh by the Janice
decision in ways that you're suggesting
Right to Work would also
private sector
workers well I don't think the Janice
decision necessarily is is is is
something of that's negatively impacted
us but this would because this is
effectively directing private sector
businesses which is going to affect the
spending power of workers in the state
which is going to affect revenues for
the State of New Hampshire which is
going to impact
um my bargaining ability at the table
with the state and it's also going to
impact what people are going to be able
to spend in business businesses in the
state and it's also as I've stated these
laws tend to also inhibit um worker
protections and I think it's just bad
overall um I don't know why government
wants to get metal in the business of
private sector um businesses um with
their with their
employees um that that's their business
that's government shouldn't be messing
with
that right thank you any other questions
here in yellow
be see any questions for the presenter
on
Zoom well representative turkot S I can
see you thank you Mr thank you Mr Feller
uh going back to something
representative C were touched on could
you give us what is uh the ratio of
private sector and public in the
SEIU we have uh we have one um one um
one unit one bargaining unit that is
private sector versus how many public
and ratio of number of employees I think
we have
um I think there's about I don't know we
represent but I want to say roughly we
have 35 bargaining units so there's one
private sector and the rest are uh the
rest are public County
Municipal I can tell you that that
private sector local is 100%
membership thank you followup followup
um also touching on what representative
Seward was uh talking about the impact
of Janice uh you just said you think you
have a 100% representation in the the
one unit that is private sector uh what
was the percentage of individuals in the
public sector uh units that you lost as
a result of Janice in other words how
many actually resign from the union are
no longer paying dues um I actually I
think our our membership went up but
that's not the point um I think you're
focusing in the wrong area the F the
focus of this is it's going to drive
down wages it's going to drive down down
citizens ability to purchase it's going
to drive down business's Revenue it's
going to drive down tax revenue by
passing these laws you're focusing in
the wrong
area thank you for your answer I think I
this is representative infantine I have
a question how does that happen how does
it drive down wages if you have a 100
people in a union and they're all paying
dues now
and you lose one person who refuses to
pay dues as a result
of If This Were to pass and become law
and one person says you know I'm just
you don't do it for me I'm not going to
pay the dues how does that affect the
bargaining and the salaries and
then again I think I think your focus
you no one's forced to join a union just
like um and no one's forced to pay dues
um what I'm what I've cited and what
other experts before you have cited are
the statistics in right to work states
that wages are lower they tend to be
lower because the bargaining power isn't
there for the workers and that drives
down revenue and that drives down
people's ability to spend which
ultimately impacts what you folks will
do at the legislature because you'll
have less Revenue
ultimately I'm just stating statistics
and I can get you those statistics if
you'd like to see them understood I have
a question representative h yes thank
you for taking question it's kind
of talk
about on those
statistics um is there any way in those
statistics that show necessarily other
differences or other um conditions of
those states that are being compared and
for example I mean folks that make money
say in New York at a certain
are going to make infinitely more money
in New York than they are in New
Hampshire and is that part of the basis
I mean
seems
support um I'll have to research that
and get back to
you see no other questions in the
L no questions online we thank you very
much for your testimony thank you next
up is Greg Moore followed by Jim jerkin
Viola Kimi and Joe reap Greg
representative Moes
sorry thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I appreciate the
opportunity to speak uh to the labor
committee today my name is Greg Moore I
am the state director with Americans for
Prosperity uh New Hampshire and I have a
long track record with this issue uh as
as the chair and vice chair and some of
the other veteran committee members know
I served as a chief of staff of the
house and we certainly had robust
discussions about right to work at the
time beyond that in 2006 I was working
as a director at the Department of
Health and Human Services when the sea
implemented the agency fee uh which of
course uh went away in 2018 but but uh I
certainly had to go through that it
didn't impact me directly as an
unclassified employee but certainly it
impacted a number of DHHS employees as
well as including some of some of the
ones who worked directly for me so
there's there's a long track record now
what I'm not going to do is go down the
same will warn path that uh every member
of this committee who's been on this for
more than a term has heard a gazillion
times um and trust me the Freshman
members of this committee will know
quite well by the end of today uh
instead what I'd like to do is talk a
little bit put this into context the
Right to Work legislation in context
with another public policy issue that's
that's also quite familiar and that that
issue is the issue of the individual
mandate under the Affordable Care Act uh
you see with the individual mandate
under the Affordable Care Act if you
didn't have employer sponsored Insurance
you had two choices you could either buy
through the government a third party uh
an insurance policy or you could pay a
penalty to the government for the
privilege of not having Insurance well a
similar situation exists in a 23 states
that that lack Right to Work protections
uh for for those individuals who work in
a unionized Workforce with an agency fee
they have two choices they can either
join a third party uh as a condition of
their employment the their Union or they
can pay a penalty to their Union for the
privilege of not joining and and
ironically the the sort of the arguments
made by opponents of Right to Work
mirror the arguments made by the
supporters of the individual mandate
within the Affordable Care Act they
frequently hear them say uh people need
to pay their fair share and we can't
have quote unquote free writers in the
system and and uh it's no surprise that
that the individual mandate was durably
the most unpopular provision of the
Affordable Care Act just as right to
work laws consistently perform well and
when when asked the general public their
opinion on the issue so what happened
with the individual mandate well in
early starting in
2018 the individual mandate as a part of
the tax cut and jobs Act was that
penalty was dropped to zero similarly
middle of the way through 2018 the
penalty for not joining a union uh for
government employees was dropped down to
zero what Senate Bill 61 will do is it
would drop for private sector and
nonprofit employees it would drop the
penalty for not joining your union down
to zero same with the other same with
the other two cohorts the the public
sector as well as now the individual
mandate and that's the reason why it's
so popular because it Embraces
everything that we support the ideas of
free expression
in free association and and and that is
why this is an important piece of
legislation and that's why we fully
support it and I'd be happy to take any
questions from the committee and again
we we we ask that you find this bill out
to
pass thank you for your testimony do we
have any questions on
Zoom seeing none we have a question
representa Nunes has a question thank
you representative Nunes uh recognize
thank you Mr chairman uh and thank you
Mr Moore for testifying before our
committee today uh Mr Moore we've heard
some information maybe you can clear
some stuff up for us or maybe you can
add to it about uh about income growth
in states that have or have not uh uh
instituted right to work as policy in
their states I know that we have about
23 States or 22 States something like
that right now that have right to work
uh maybe just a little bit more than
that uh but um
I know in the past decade more
information has come out about income
growth can you address income growth for
us certainly and as we stand right now
um as I'm sure as other members have
pointed out there are 27 states that
have enacted right toot work laws 23
States uh of course have not enacted
right to work laws since the TA heartley
act in
1947 uh I think it's instructive to look
at the five states that have passed
right to work laws in the last decade I
think that that's really where we should
focus our energies and look uh for the
actual results as to the basis of the
claims either by the supporters of the
people in opposition to right to work um
if you look at the data from those five
states that's uh starting with Indiana
in 2011 uh Michigan in 2012 Wisconsin in
2015 and West Virginia in 2016 and then
and then Kentucky in 2017 if uh looking
at looking at those States one of the
things that that absolutely did not
happen I think it's it's important to
point this out the very at the very
first instance one thing that absolutely
did not happen was in none of those
states did wages go down so so I think
that's important to point out in none of
the five states did the wages go down
now it's a little bit hard to get good
data from Kentucky and West Virginia um
largely because West Virginia was in
litigation so long that it's only now
actually being fully implemented but but
certainly in certainly in Kentucky in
2017 we can go back and look at and look
at States like Indiana and Michigan
which have had these laws in place for a
few years now and what what we found in
reviewing those data is that the income
growth in Indiana and Michigan is
greater than their Regional counterparts
and I think that that's important to to
keep in mind and and to consider now
it's it's something as we all know that
that whole area the the the so-called
Rust Belt where we're seeing these
states pass these laws are are frankly
frankly not doing as well as the rest of
the country whether it's right to work
laws states without right to work laws
but if you compare them to the regional
growth within within that same that same
region uh the states that are performing
better are the states that have recently
enacted right to work laws I don't I
don't know if that answers your question
but um is that is that what you were
looking for representative uh yes Mr
Moore thank you very much Mr chairman
can I have one followup on
that I apologize I'm responding to
another legislator followup yes just
looking for a followup Mr
chairman um uh thank you um as a
followup on that sometimes we see when
uh when income growth happens we also
see job growth happen particularly in
private sector are there any statistics
that you know of that can point towards
whether or not uh we have seen job
growth in right to work
states uh certainly there is a a robust
uh bit of information in that and I
think that the the job growth comes
before the income growth uh just from an
economic standpoint what drives the
income growth is a scarcity of Labor
much like much like uh here in New
Hampshire when we were seeing prior to
the pandemic some of the lowest
unemployment rates we've seen
historically uh that has a natural
tendency to drive labor so finding
policies that drive job growth is how
you drive income growth so I I'd say
that the income growth follows from the
job growth not the other way around uh
but there is a a robust bit of studies
that have been put together through the
years look at the specific issue of job
growth and comparing comparing uh right
to work states and non-right to work
states as as other people have mentioned
the the real challenge is controlling
for the right to work policy and that's
why I think it's so important to look at
the states that have passed these laws
recently uh and and and I would
encourage folks who are who are
particularly interested as I said the
two best examples would be would be
Indiana and Michigan because there's
enough evidence enough years of evidence
uh behind them invariably one of the
things you'll find is with the passage
of right to work you'll you'll see that
there is a protracted litigation so even
if we were to pass right to work in here
in 2021 I would expect that that you
might see this this bill in litigation
for uh who knows how long uh just as a
result of of that's the consistent model
that we've seen in other states that
have passed these types of laws and and
I also point out those five states
because the last to pass right to work
prior to Indiana in 2 2011 was was
Oklahoma back in 1983 so there's
obviously a big gap and comparing a lot
of the economies uh pre1 1983 with with
post 2011 uh can be a little bit like
comparing apples and
oranges thank you Mr
Moore any additional questions on
Zoom seeing none in the L represent ad
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Moore
for taking my question um you mentioned
the uh Affordable Care acts individual
mandate um as a comparable metaphor to
um have or as opposite right to work um
is it correct that the individual
mandate um was originally defined by the
Heritage Foundation in an effort to
undercut the calls for universal
healthcare in the
90s not in not in the exact form that it
appeared in the Affordable Care but
there conceptually it has been an idea
that was that was B bantered about um
for many years in healthc care circles
certainly when when I was working at the
Department of Health and Human Services
and and um when I was at DHHS
Massachusetts passed something similar
to that during my time there and that
sort of brought the debate here to New
Hampshire in the middle part of the of
the I guess we say the 2000s now uh
because Massachusetts had passed a Sim
similar piece of legislation uh there
that the idea has gone has been been
around for a while now and um and there
there are groups on on the right and the
left who historically have passed that
but uh it Still Remains durably
unpopular although who knows we might
see it come back again uh with the
current
Administration follow up thank you Mr
chairman um I don't want to
categorize um the economic status of
every email that we've received on this
committee because I don't know
everybody's personal finances uh but one
thing I noticed where I was going
through my legislative email is that uh
it appeared that the overwhelming
majority of people who wrote us opposed
to this bill were working class folks um
folks that come from that kind of
demographic maybe they worked in Union
before maybe they haven't uh maybe they
support unions because they believe that
um you know I Rise High f s votes um and
the emails that we got in favor of the
bill were from uh the Bia um some I
believe your organization sent one out
why why do I have that perception that
it would appear that those working class
folks will be opposed to this while the
industry folks would be in
support so just to clarify we we haven't
sent any correspondence uh out uh from
from Americans for Prosperity um ask you
a question representative one of the
things I've learned through the years is
is speculating on on people's thoughts
and motives is a bad bad bad decision
when testifying before the state
legislature so I'll I'll uh take an
opportunity to just simply say that I
don't
know okay any further questions for Mr
Moore being none is there any objection
to the members of the lob to taking a f
minute break to go to the uh
restroom we're going to take a f minute
break when I come back we will have Jim
Durkin Viola cimi uh Joe reap Peter
Peter y Ur and Hank zumas in order so
we'll be right back the microphones are
on no you keep them on send me quickly
microphones are
on
great Tommy my computer just froze up
can't take any notes anyways
uh the audio is still on in the in the
room just letting you guys know
you
know
for
that's
e
guess I was the
one what I
FR pilot I know one you KD I know
leg
thank you for uh catching me I was
trying to respond
to another state representative
see
that's
all
right
two more and we'll
start give you the one minute warning
for folks
online
minute
folks online please when you get back
ready put on your camera so we can see
everybody so I know who's
ready your faces pretty
pictures
start one more minute Jim
jerkin
[Music]
simy
Robert
you see representative attit in the
hallway I did
notes
kill
you guys on zo they bringing in a full
full meal for us today here four course
lunch Tre complet birthday yeah mik we
have Mike K's birthday cake here
so all right I'm going to start the
hearing uh reopen uh the hearing or
continue
on we're going to continue the hearing
here at this point I'd like to call on
Jim
Durkin to testify Mr
Durkin thank you Mr chairman can you
hear me yes we
can uh for the record Jim Durkin
legislative director for ASM Council 93
uh proudly representing more than 4,000
hardworking public sector workers here
in New Hampshire and I'm here today on
their behalf to testify in strong
opposition to
sb61 as you know a little over two and a
half years ago the Supreme Court
expressly prohibited agency fee in the
public sector thereby instantaneously
making us a right to work country for
the public sector labor movement get uh
here we are once again opposing this
latest effort to make New Hampshire the
first right to work state in our region
of the country an effort that didn't TR
originate here in this state but rather
within the offices of the national Right
to Work Foundation a group well funded
by corporations and right-wing
organizations and headquartered more
than 500 miles away in Virginia where
this legislation was drafted and
ultimately cut and pasted almost Reba
him into the bill before you today but
given right to work's been a reality for
us for some time now one may wonder why
we're here today to oppose the bill well
in addition to standing in solidarity
with our private sector Union brothers
and sisters is we know the diet
consequences that have followed when
States pass right to work laws it's our
belief the primary goal of this
legislation and its deep pocketed
corporate back is is and always has been
simply to drain Union resources and
weaken our ability to fight for decent
wages benefits and safer working
conditions when there isn't a strong
union president to fight for workplace
safety more workers are likely to get
hurt or even killed on the job and when
workers have less money in their
paychecks they're forced to increasingly
rely on taxpayer funded Public
Assistance programs like food stamps and
subsidized Healthcare and child care and
they also of course have less money to
spend in their local and Statewide
economies so while some businesses
prosper from cutting wages and benefits
more suffer especially smaller
businesses from the reduced buying power
of workers look I'm not going to repeat
all the statistics suffice to say it's
clear that these laws lead to lower
wages and benefits for Union and
non-union workers and have no
discernable impact on job growth but I
would like to talk a bit about the
question of fundamental fairness one
that's always been part of this debate
in my 18 years of doing this work for
ask me I found that many legislators
know that workers who choose for
whatever reason not to support the Union
by paying dues receive the same economic
Ben uh benefits included in the contract
but I've also found that very few are
aware that these laws also require the
union to provide free legal
representation to non-u paying workers
workers who may have been suspended or
fired or simply been denied a benefit or
protection included in the contract
unions are legally bound to provide a
vigorous defense of these workers which
can amount to thousands of dollars
especially if the case ends up in
arbitration so I can't help but wonder
how many current New Hampshire uh New
Hampshire lawmakers uh particularly the
the new uh members are unaware of this
fact and if so how many have chosen to
accept as Undisputed Truth all of the
arguments put forward by the individuals
who drafted this legislation and
accounting on you men and women
essentially serving as volunteers true
citizen legislators to hurriedly pass
this legislation and watch as it's
signed into law if this bill does become
law I'm sure you won't hear again from
the people over V in Virginia who
drafted the bill but you will see the
many faces of the New Hampshire
residents your neighbors your friends
and even your family members who are
hurt by it and you'll see its negative
impact in the communities and your
districts many years to come I know it's
a busy day I'm going to close there I
just want to say on behalf of all asme
members and their families I thank you
for your time and consideration today
and for your continued dedication to
Public Service during these
extraordinarily challenging
times thank you for your testimony any
questions here in the
L seeing now any questions
online this is representative infantine
I have a question for you is it your
opinion that is it your opinion that uh
states that have Right to Work have less
safe working
environments uh look when you unions are
always at the Forefront Mr chairman of
fighting for these types of of issues uh
and I believe uh uh Mr bracket in early
testimony talked about when you're not
protected by a union if you bring some
type of a safety concern uh forward and
you and you push that it's more than
likely not going to turn out well for
you as a worker um so yes we we do
believe that we it's it it it's all kind
of uh flows together when you weaken
unions you weaken the ability of
individual workers and the Union as a
whole to fight for uh good safety
practices and to and to bring to the
attention of management safety issues
I want to I have my own fall I don't get
it I didn't get it when Mr bracket said
it and I don't get it when you said it
if you have a right to work law that
passes and you have a small percentage
of the IND individuals refusing to pay
the the dues or the
fees the union is still a union the
union still takes their
concerns to management that doesn't
change correct
but Mr chairman if the as I said earlier
we believe the ultimate goal of this
legislation is to weaken labor unions
and as you you may not see an immediate
impact but over time as unions are
weakened these are the type of problems
that you
face I'll be happy again sir I didn't
want to get into you you're going to
hear this all day you're going to hear
statistics and I'm sure you've been
inundated with uh documents uh via email
email um but you know we would be happy
to to get you some solid statistics on
this from our from our
national no I appreciate that I was
gonna ask you a question about a mystery
box but I'll I'll I'll that
um sorry trying trying to be trying to
bring some levity my apologies was
trying it's always good to have it's
always good to have Mr chairman thank
you very much for your testimony any
questions uh in the L any questions
online seeing none thank you very much
I'd like to call thank you
sir i' like to call Victoria I don't
know why I can always have a problem
with
Viola Kat Simi followed by Joe reap
Peter and uh Hank zumas VI are you with
us she's there she needs to
unmute you may if you're there make sure
you're off
mute I don't see her on my screen
got hello can you hear me yes we can
hear you oh good afternoon sorry about
that uh good afternoon members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Viola ksim I want to thank you for the
opportunity to speak I'm here on behalf
of the Granite State organizing project
we are a grass rate organization that
unit States labor Community groups to
work towards a more just world I'm here
today to express our opposition to
sb61 uh over the decades we have seen an
attack on organized labor by corporate
interest and we've seen that as unions
have declined income inequality has also
increased so curtailing bargaining power
for working people has contributed to A
reduced middle class um and that and
while incomes of those at the top
continues to Rise um a 2016 report by
the Center for Public Policy research
shows that unions help to breach the
racial inequality Gap particularly for
black workers in the union they receive
16% higher wages than their nonunited
counterparts similarly they are 177%
more likely to have employee health
insurance and
18% more likely to have an employer
retirement plan and additionally Union
standardized wages for workers who are
in the same position bring the racial
and racial wage Gap the middle class is
the backbone of our economy and without
the voices of workers and unions racio
and income inequality will exagerate I
want to call on our elected officials
today you all who are listening to focus
on policies that create good paying jobs
policies that boost the local economy
policies that increase consumer spending
and strengthen the middle class rather
than considering Right to Work flows
that want to lure in low wage paying
jobs and industries who have an agenda
to to reduce benefits for workers uh to
weaken workplace safety standards and
then undermine their right to band
together so I want to ask this committee
to please
uh vote no on sb61 thank you so much for
your
time thank you for your testimony are
there any questions uh for the presenter
online seeing none any in the
L seeing none thank you very much for
your
testimony thank you next up is uh Joe
reap followed by Peter I Hank zumas and
Robert Burr uh
mrve Peter RVE from Raymond Carpenters
Union are you with
us yes I'm here good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the committee uh
proud resident of Raymond and uh I'm
here in opposition to
this as a carpenter with over 10 years
of experience I had grown accustomed to
looking for side work in order to make
ends meet as there never was enough
money to take care of all our needs such
as clothes car repairs Insurance rent
food Medical Care you get the picture
years later I joined the carpenters
union and found myself being a full-time
single parent to two young boys it was a
very difficult thing to do as it meant
having to get my sons up around 5: in
the morning and dropping them off at a
friend's home by
5:45 so that I could start my commute to
work being in the construction industry
often means traveling an hour or more to
get to the job site and results in very
long
days while those eight years as a single
dad were tough they would have been much
much harder had it not been for my union
membership I was able to support my
family without any public
assistance at one point one of my sons
required a lengthy brain surgery that
resulted in nearly
$250,000 in medical
costs I did not have to stress and loose
sleep over this as my family enjoyed
good medical coverage provided by my
union and my
employers I was able to pay off my
portion of the costs within a
year my membership helped me to survive
a challenging time in my life and it
continues to pay off to this day my
membership has afforded me thorough and
ex extensive training to succeed in my
industry the employe ERS that I have
worked for strictly follow and adhere to
all the federal guidelines regarding
worker safety this also benefits my
family and myself as construction is a
very dangerous
industry the employeers that I have uh
worked
for really believe in in that safety
because they treat
us as the most valuable asset that they
have um
my membership is improved my quality of
life in many ways is I no longer am
forced to seek a second source of income
and can now devote that time to being a
better father husband and friend to
those around me before joining the
Carpenters Union I basically lived to
work now I work to live and there's a
big distinction there and I want you to
think about
that um I ask you to please vote against
this measure as it will inevitably erode
the the standard of living for thousands
of New Hampshire families unions are
advocates for the American worker and in
their history have contributed immensely
to the benefit of the American worker
every single worker both Union and
non-union in this country enjoys many of
these contributions today thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for the presenter
online
sing none any in the
L sing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you next up is Hank
zumas Follow by Robert Burr and Vincent
Verio Mr
zumas hello Mr chairman can you hear me
yes we can thank you uh good afternoon
to you Mr chairman and members of the
House labor committee uh my name is
Henry zumas of Penacook New Hampshire
I'm represented the electrical
contractors Business
Association we are in favor of Senate
Bill
61 uh Freedom of Choice seems very
natural as being an American all
employees in the state of New Hampshire
should sh should have the right to
choose and I know you guys had a long
day today so I I'll I'll end my remarks
here and I thank you for your
time okay thank you very much any
questions for Mr zumas
online thing done any questions in the
lb representative turot thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for the question
just simple uh simple question could you
say who you were representing uh here in
favor of again I didn't catch it oh sure
it's the electrical contractors Business
Association we're a New Hampshire based
outfit okay thank you
sure
seeing no additional questions thank you
for
your your um
testimony next up is Robert Burr
followed by Vincent Mar vermio and Donna
Morris Mr Burr are you with
us Mr Burr International Union of
operating
engineers yes sir can you hear me Mr
chairman yes we can hear you very well
ahead
CH thank you very much uh good afternoon
thank you chair infantine and the entire
labor committee for giving me an
opportunity to speak to here today on
behalf of my business manager William D
mcgoffin in our local union we strongly
oppose s
sp61 I'm the business representative for
the international Union of Opera
engineers local 4 we represent men and
women that operate heavy equipment
mechanics survey equipment equipment
house employees Wastewater technicians
and apprentices
we have nearly 5,300 members more than
600 of whom live and work here in New
Hampshire those men and women love the
work they do and love calling the grand
State their home I'm here today to vo
our opposition to S sp61 socalled Right
to Work legislation unlike the name
Right to Work legislation denies New
Hampshire workers the freedom to join
together to form a strong strong unions
if they choose to unlike what outs say
corporate interest may tell you this
isn't a freedom issue it has always
always been fly illegal to force anyone
to join a union in fact Right to Work
does not increase worker freedoms or job
creation it does the exact opposite if
this bill passes New Hampshire will be
the only state in Northeast to pass this
anti-worker legislation it has been
proven that the states that have already
pass rate to work laws have low wages
and incomes have higher poverty and
infant mortality rates invest Less in
public education and have increased
workplace injury and fatality
rates our members work hard highly
skilled in a highly skilled industry one
that depends on safety protocols and
regulations to keep them safe this bill
would DET be detrimental to their safety
and yes it would put their lives at risk
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics workers in right to work
states are 227% more likely to die on
the job than workers in New
Hampshire I couldn't believe it when I
first heard this statistic but when I
thought about it there's a reason our
state's workers are so safe and it's
because union members spend millions of
dollars on a year to train and ensure
our members are skilled and safe on the
job sites y local Force strongly opposes
this legislation and we hope that you
will help keep New Hampshire safe and
Free By voting down SP sp61 I thank you
for your time
today thank you for your testimony could
you please please this is representative
infantine could you please
um repeat that statistic of the more
likely to die I I I didn't quite catch
all of
it I was I I got these stats too myself
Mr chairman I was a little I I didn't
believe it at first when I heard it but
here it
goes
the according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics workers in right to work
states are
227% more likely to die on the job than
workers in New
Hampshire that answer a
question um it is it does thank you very
much
um do I have any other questions for the
presenter yeah on yellow be
representative turock you recognized
thank you Miss uh Mr chairman thank you
uh Mr bur for the question just
following up on uh chairman infantine
question um I realized 200% sounds like
a large number that's roughly twice the
number um do you have the actual numbers
actual numbers of workers who have been
killed I mean are we talking two or
three or are we talking hundreds or just
just so I can get a uh more accurate
assessment of what that 200%
means so uh thank for your question one
is actually too many I'd be happy to get
you those stats um and and send them
over to the committee if that would
work I'd appreciate
that any other
questions see none
online so you no additional questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank thank you next up is Vincent Verio
followed by Donna Morris and Reverend
John Gregory Davis um Mr vermio are you
with
us yes yes I am can you hear me yes we
can okay Mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you for giving me the
opportunity to testify here today my
name is Vincent vuco and I'm a senior
fellow with the MAA centers workers for
opportunity project I'm here to testify
in support of
sb51 uh right to work so before I get
started you know there's been a lot of
talk about statistics a lot of back and
forth but you know really just want to
get down to right to work is so before
we get started I just want to Define
right to work right to work simply means
that a union can't get a worker fired
for not paying them and now as you've
heard with the Janice versus asby
decision all public employees across the
country have right to work what we're
talking about today is simply right to
work for private sector
employees meaning that private sector
unions can't get Workers fired for not
paying them it has nothing to do with
collective bargaining workers unions
they can still negotiate with employers
over wages hours benefits anything they
could before a right to work law they
can negotiate for after a right to work
law except for the ability for the union
to say pay us or you have to lose your
job now you heard uh one of the previous
uh people testify saying that no one has
to join the union they're absolutely
right no one right to work state or not
has to be forced to join a union they
have a First Amendment right to choose
to join or not the difference is that
non-right to work states those workers
have to pay the vast majority of their
dues in what are known as agency fees to
the union so we're not talking about
joining we're talking about being forced
to pay and pretty much being forced to
pay almost the full amount of dues to
the union not having that option not
having that choice so now we've heard a
lot about income and you know I don't
want to bore everybody with Statistics
if we want happy to get into that in
question and answer um but in all of the
most recent right to work states that
have passed the law incomes have gone up
we were just talking about right to work
in
safety safety has increased in all the
states that have just passed right to
work um we've heard a lot about private
contracts now let's step back we're not
talking about coming in and getting
between an employer to employee to a
completely neutral
environment labor law is complex and
there is a myriad of
statutes on the books federally that
give unions privileges unlike almost any
other institution in America unions can
force employers to bargain with them
they can force workers to accept the
representation and they're even exempt
from some
laws what right to work is doing is it's
leveling the playing field a little it's
doesn't make it completely level and if
we want to talk about eliminating Force
riders or Free Riders that's a great
conversation we should do that but right
now we're simply saying that a worker is
forced to accept this representation
they shouldn't be forced to pay for it
in addition especially if they do not
want it one of the other um presenters
talked about political money I think it
was uh the representative well he's
right 40% a third to 40% of union
members typically vote Republican the
problem is that almost all Union money
and almost all Union support usually
goes to Democrats now I'm not saying
that's right or wrong and I'm not saying
Union support is right or wrong but what
I am saying is that there is a
disconnect between the union membership
and the union leadership that's why we
need right to work that is why it's so
important because if workers do not feel
like they're getting value for their
money with right to work they can hold
their leadership accountable they can
say you're not doing a good job we don't
want to pay you or you know what you are
doing a good job you deserve our dues
and you've heard other people testify
union leaders testify saying that even
with the Janice versus abme decision
that when workers had the choice they
saw the value and they stayed in right
to work is simply about Freedom we're
going to hear a lot about statistics and
in right to work states there is lower
unemploy there's lower unemployment
there's higher job growth there's higher
income growth and the benefits go on but
at the heart of it it's simply saying
that a union can't force a worker to pay
them simply to keep their job it gives
the worker the choice so with that thank
you for your time and happy to take any
questions thank you for your testimony
are there any questions here in the
L seeing none do we have any questions
of members of the committee on
Zoom seeing No Hands thank you very much
for your testimony thank you I may have
made a mistake uh did I I believe I
skipped over someone unless I'm totally
losing it Joe reap from associate
builders and
contractors I know I was gon to call on
you then I did not uh yes I'm I'm here
chairman thank you for that uh and for
the record it's uh it's Joshua reap but
um as far as uh full paw and uh uh
mistakes on Zoom I'll take it so that's
the worst we got to deal with today but
um well anyway uh Ed thank you very much
committee members for the opportunity to
share my views on Right to Work by way
background I the president and CEO of
associated builders and contractors New
Hampshire chapter uh live and work here
in the conquered area I'm here to
express our support for
sb61 um but first I want to set the
record straight about safety in training
commitment um safety is not exclusive to
Union or non-un um in fact uh our
contractors here which are predominately
non-union in New in New Hampshire uh
spend millions of dollars a year on
training and investing in their talent
and keeping people safe and uh the em
and if you want to look talk about
safety safety uh is one of those things
that uh we track and one of the there
are many indicators you could do to look
at safety of a company of of employees
and one of those is called The
Experience modification or EMR and among
our high performing members in the state
um you'll find one is the industry
average well in our in our state um on
average we average below 1% around 7%
for a safety standard and that is in
part because of our commitment to safety
and training um our association
represents over 250 companies uh here in
the granite state our employers
employees are committed to that safety
culture training and provide high
quality of life for their employees and
what we want to share with is that right
to work uh the the right of a worker to
join participate in or financially
support a union is certainly a
fundamental right that should never be
infringed upon the same goes of course
for the worker who decides to make a
different Choice the right to exercise
such a choice is the essence of economic
freedom the right to work protects both
of those rights no American should be
forced to join a union just to keep a
job no required to pay dues to an
organization they don't believe in Right
to Work allows workers to freely decide
whether or not to join a union now more
than ever individuals are better
informed highly educated and able to
make decisions about what is right for
their economic future at the same time
unions are more active than ever
communicating their value to the
membership such laws are not about
eliminating unions nor Outlaw their
right to organize rather than looking at
the sky's falling situation I'd
encourage union leaders to instead look
at the work they're doing to try to
better communicate the value they
believe they're providing to their
members every day uh and also uh
something that I would like to also make
a note of is in construction most
workers in New Hampshire choose to be
non-union and we lead the uh region in
terms of wages and benefits in fact uh
construction unions in the state U
represent less than 10% of the
construction Workforce here and we
believe that number is unlikely to
change under Right to Work economic
growth has been talked about a lot about
other right work states so I'll forgo
those comments
and I just say I encourage you all to
please uh put the individual first in
support s sp61 and thank you very much
for listening on what's turning out to
be a very long
day thank you for your testimony we have
any questions for
Josh uh in the
L seeing none do it be
online see none thank you very much for
your testimony and I apologize for
skipping you no troubles thank you
everybody up next Donna Morris Reverend
John Gregory Davis and Reverend Dr Gail
Kenny uh Donna Morris are you with
us Donna
Morris I do not see Miss Morris she's a
member of the greater Salem Chamber of
Commerce if she comes back on please let
me know Reverend John Gregory Davis
sorry I had to figur how to unmute
myself yes Reverend John gregy Davis
co-pastor of the Meridan Congregational
Church here in Meridan and um you will
you have received already testimony from
um the New Hampshire Council of churches
in opposition to sp61 I I joined them
and and my colleague Reverend Gail Kenny
will say more following me so I don't
want to be redundant but what I want to
Simply say is to really ask us to look
at the the morality of sp61 and it's one
rarely have I seen a bill that is so
avowedly immoral from from its beginning
so the the um creators of this bill
obviously rightly I I presume believe
that we care about workers and so they
falsely disingenuously called it a right
to work knowing full well it has nothing
to do with the right to work but
thinking people will respond well to
that and in fact everybody I've talked
to the vast majority of my congregation
when it's explained that right to work
isn't about right to work really that
it's really about uh uh limiting the
power of labor unions is not in
supportive of it so it's really I would
ask you to consider why is it that the
presenters can't be honest with you and
tell you this is about the right to
exploit workers maybe you'd still vote
for it but at least you'd know what you
they wouldn't be lying to pretending
that they're supporting they're helping
workers someone asked earlier why is it
that the majority of workers we hear
from are opposed to this the majority of
employ and and many employers are for it
that tells you something as
well the what are what are we afraid of
Are We afraid that if people have the
right to organize and and uh for for
better working conditions they'll
achieve them I would hope so labor
unions are not over represented in this
country of anything that they're they
power is weaken and yet many of the
advantages we take for granted wouldn't
be here if it were not for active
organizing and the silly argument about
people having the right not to pay I
mean that's as crazy as if I I go up to
a toll booth and I say you know what I
believe in the right to ride I'm not
gonna pay you know I I should have my
choice the highways are here I should be
able to ride on them whether I pay it's
a silly argument you know that as well
as we do that this is not about the
right to work it's not about freedom of
workers it's about and the only reason
that so many employees and and so much
money is pouring in from outside of the
state is because of an an active an
understanding that the more we can limit
the power of workers the more worker
power can be limited limited the more
business can Thrive that's not right for
New Hampshire New Hampshire has defeated
this time and again and I urge New
Hampshire because right to work is
morally wrong for New Hampshire it's
morally wrong for anyone and I strongly
urge that you vote it I think it's itl
inexpedient to leg
thank you so
much thank you for your testimony there
any questions the presenter
online seeing none in the L
representative
turot thank you uh Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Davis for taking this question
you mentioned the large amounts of money
that are flowing in from the state do
you have a dollar figure on that exactly
how much is coming in to support this
that's a good question I do not I think
my colleague who's following me may may
have more information on that it's a
good question thank
you thank
you additional
questions seean thank you very much for
your testimony thank
you um Reverend Dr Gail Kenny followed
by Arie Alpert and James Baldwin
representative excuse me Reverend Dr
Gail Kenny are you with us um yes I
and um Mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you very much for
hearing my testimony for the record my
name is Gail Kenny I'm a resident of
Canan I'm a pastor with the United
Church of Christ and I speak today on
behalf of the economic Justice team of
this particular New Hampshire
denomination and we are the largest
Protestant denomination in the state of
New Hampshire leaders within multiple
Faith Traditions from Protestants to
Catholics to Jews and more have been
vigorous in their opposition to these
bills for multiple reasons and you heard
from the the Catholic dasis already this
morning um our faith leads us to
understand that all work has value and
that all workers have a right to dignity
and respect our faith leads us to
understand that workers deserve to have
a voice on the job and the right to come
together collectively we also believe
that New Hampshire employers involved in
collective bargaining have the right to
deal with their workers at the
bargaining table without the heavy hand
of the legislature interfering in very
specific contractual decisions U but
that's exactly what this bill would do
so our faith is grounded in some
foundational Commandments and one of
them is Thou shalt not bear false
witness but unfortunately you've heard
some false witness about this bill not
just on this time around but for the
last four decades and no matter what is
claimed by the Bill's proponents the
primary purpose and the primary hopes um
behind this bill are that workers would
be divided and that somehow that this
could help Union strength and
the effectiveness of collective
bargaining by encouraging workers not to
pay union dues even though they might
benefit mightily from a union bargain
contract or Union handle workplace
grievances so this bill comes to us year
after year from the well-healed Virginia
lobbyist and um we've heard again over
the decades wild claims about employers
just waiting at New Hampshire's Gates so
to speak to set up shop in our state if
such a law is passed
but no one has ever been able to
legitimately identify a single business
that has that intent that's just again
waiting at the gates so if the out ofate
architects of this bill want uh want to
come to you bearing the total truth they
would divulge the history of where this
policy and where this concept came from
and I would just ask do you know the
history of so-called right to work and
if not I believe you should before you
vote and the truth is um the historical
truth is the right to work laws bubbled
up in the Jim Crow South in the 1940s
and Beyond these laws were all about
trying to put a a divide between black
workers and white workers when there was
any hint that they might come together
to unionize and one of the key
architects of of these laws was a
wealthy industrialist and lobbyist from
Texas named Vance Muse academics have
described his efforts as an anti-labor
Crusade on in a US Senate hearing Mr
Muse once said proudly I'm a southerner
and I'm a white supremacist and his
literature promoting these laws included
a sickening statement and I want to ask
for your forgiveness in advance for
repeating his words U but I think that
you need to hear them um he said that if
right to work laws were not passed then
quote white women and white men will be
forced into organizations meaning unions
with black African Apes whom they will
have to call brother or lose their jobs
and that's the end of the quote that is
where this law comes from that is where
it bubbled up and early on The
Architects of these laws decided to very
deceptively label their concept right to
work because who could be against the
right to work to their you know total
Delight their idea about these laws
worked these laws pit workers against
one another and drastically diminished
workers ability to collectiv bargain
effectively because they were divided
between people who chose to pay and
people who didn't want to pay and again
starting out with dividing black and
white um so what did that mean after
workers were divided it didn't happen
overnight but when those divisions occur
over time it meant lower wages because
of weaker bargaining power fewer
benefits less safe workplaces and so
ever since Vance sm's day corporate
interests that want to keep wages is low
and want to keep workers voiceless have
spent untold amounts of money and I
don't have a figure but thinking about
just 40 years focused on New Hampshire
with all the mailings all the all the
efforts um all the the Slick materials
um is been a lot of money and we are
just one state of many that they've
targeted so these out of sters again for
the past 40 years have believed that you
New Hampshire legislators are
particularly susceptible to their false
witness um so we hear words about
Freedom that's part of the false witness
so I want to close by just saying a few
things about Freedom so workers already
have the freedom to vote democratically
on whether or not they want to have a
union if they vote to form a union in
their workplace they have the freedom to
vote democratically on whether or not
they want to fair share an agency's
clause in their contract New Hampshire
workers have the freedom to choose
whether or not to seek employment in a
place where there already are democratic
democratically formed unions and they
have a freedom to choose um to whether
or not to seek employment in workplaces
for example where there's a drug testing
requirement or a background check
requirement or other very significant
requires for going to work there uh it's
already been legally established that no
worker can be forced um to become a
member of your union and the freedom
exists even for relief from agency fees
in certain circumstances and employers
has the freedom to choose whether or not
to have a clause in their contract that
addresses addresses agency fees or fair
share clauses
construction contractors have the
freedom to choose whether or not to
enter into Partnerships with the
construction unions so that the the
union Bears major responsibility for
employee screening and training in a way
that makes the contractor more
productive and more competitive so if
you prohibit these agreements one
question I have and you should ask
yourselves how are you going to
compensate the negatively affected
contractors for what you're taking away
from them and I'd say no New Hampshire
employ employers with unionized
employees are running to you pleading
Save Me From Myself I'm incapable of
making good decisions in collective
bargaining so I implore you please do
not be swayed or manipulated by false
witness or from out of state spending I
pray that you take to heart where this
bill comes from and what it's really all
about and that you vote inexpedient to
legislate and if the truths the many
truths that you hear today from so many
witnesses don't affect you then at least
recognize that this bill has a real cost
factor in terms of prosecutorial costs
and investigative cost and it lacks a
fiscal note so for that flaw alone I
would just suggest that you send this
bill packing and I thank you for your
time thank you for your testimony there
any questions for the presenter
[Music]
online seeing none of there any in the
L see none thank you very much for your
your testimony ladies and gentlemen we
have had 20 presenters and it has taken
us 2 hours and 45 minutes we have now
passed the uh the the group of uh
lobbyists and um represent or and
lawmakers we're moving into the list of
individuals uh who are willing to speak
so please uh uh be succinct with um and
we are going to start continue to
enforce the limits I was about to um
stop the other most previous speaker so
um Arie Albert James
Baldwin uh James Burke
mad shanen Carpenter and Alex Lloyd in
that order Arie Alpert are you afternoon
Mr chairman my name is Arie Albert I
live in Canterbury New Hampshire uh I am
retired and I'm uh really here really
for myself but I have the opportunity
today to present to you a statement from
Mark Dixon who is the a professor and
chair of the sociology department at
Dartmouth College and is unable to be
here today so I I'll read this into the
record and then afterward I'll send you
a copy of Professor Dixon is the author
most recently of Heartland Blues labor
rights in the industrial Midwest
published last year and he says uh I
have been writing and teaching on labor
issues for the last 15 years my research
on Right to Work provides an historical
perspective on Senate Bill
61 Right to Work Advocates sometimes
presented as a job growth strategy or a
means to protect the rights of
individual employees historical evidence
suggests otherwise Right to Work
originated as a tool to curb new Union
organizing efforts and to destabilize
existing unions in the 1940s as well as
today the financial support for right to
work has come from those more interested
in weakening unions than in job growth
or considering how labor law might
effectively balance the interest of
employers employees and labor
organizations the first state campaigns
for Right to Work were in
1944 when unemployment dipped below 2%
nationally and average workers had real
economic leverage anti- Roosevelt
organizations at The Fringe of American
politics were the first to take up the
issue following World War II mainstream
business associations such as the
Chamber of Commerce and the National
Association of Manufacturers
increasingly pushed for state laws to
slow down a growing union movement union
membership had grown fivefold between
1935 and the end of the war in my
research I find that states were more
likely to adopt right to work laws
during the 1940s and 1950s if they had
active Union organizing campaigns
particularly in the south were
organizing brought the potential of
integration and if employers themselves
were organized and active in politics in
short the emergence of right to work was
about weakening a political
adversary there is little historical
evidence to support right to work as a
means of protecting the rights of
individual employees and union members I
just want to repeat that line there is
little historical evidence to support
right to work as a means of protecting
the right
of individual employees and union
members for example the Taft heartley
Act of 1947 originally mandated their
workplace elections be held in non right
to work states to determine whether to
Grant unions the ability to enter into a
union shop agreement or to withdraw from
Union shop agreements negotiated before
the act more than 90% of workers voted
in favor of the Union shop the Mandate
was dropped in 1951 after the near
uniform support from workers the next
uptick in Right to Work activity
followed the merge of the American
Federation of Labor and Congress
industrial Congress of industrial
organizations in
1955 again driven by business fears over
the strength of a unified labor movement
it was in this context that the National
Association of
Manufacturers popularized the term Big
labor the latest push for Right to Work
comes in a much different environment
the percentage of workers belonging to
unions has declined considerably since
its mid 20th century Peak a large body
of research now documents how Union
decline has contributed to increases in
economic inequality and working poverty
and to diminished social Mobility so why
Target unions now consistent across both
periods however different is that right
to work has been an important tool for
organized business it is a clear way to
defund and destabilize a poli itical
opponent whereas the National
Association of Manufacturers took the
lead on providing model language on
right to work in the 1950s the American
legislative exchange Council has taken
up the mantle in recent decades the
historical record on right to work's
primary use is clear and it is not the
protection of employee rights uh thank
you much Mr chairman uh I'm afraid I
can't answer any questions directly on
behalf of Professor Dixon but I will
send to you the statement and you can
get a hold of him uh if you would like
to draw more on his expertise and uh
I've I first testified against right to
work in
1983 possibly before any of you were
even in the legislature uh so I could
say a word or two on my own behalf if
you had any other
questions thank you for your testimony
are there any questions for the
presenter in the
lb see none are there any
online
not seeing any thank you very much for
your testimony thank you very much next
up to speak is James Baldwin followed by
James Burke mad and Shane Carpenter Mr
Baldwin are you with
us James
baldwi Christina do you see him in the
queue give me just a moment I don't see
the last name but
maybe I don't see Jim
Baldwin he was a James Baldwin from
Kensington um all right we're going to
uh James Burke
mishad from Webster New
Hampshire
James Burke
mad from
Webster Shane Carpenter from forsmith
are you with
us Shane
Carpenter don't see a
Shane
there's an Alex Lloyd from Milford who
states their staff state agency
staff Alex
Lloyd hi yes can you hear me yes I
can thank you chairman other members of
the committee uh my name is Alex Lloyd I
reside in Milford and am a lifelong
Granite stator I do work for a state
agency but I am here representing myself
today uh with experience I have about
this matter including my former time
working at the New Hampshire's job CP I
oppose passage of this Right to Work
bill my testimony will be condensed out
of respect for yours and the other
testifiers
time when reviewing the text of this
bill proponents State clearly their
intent is to maximize freedom of choice
and pursuit of employment
that Viewpoint in my observation is
short-sided and is a
disservice to Workforce Development
efforts being made in New Hampshire and
does not actually encourage an
employment climate conductive to
economic
growth my role was to network with
businesses across New England and to
assist trade graduates with obtaining
employment their trades range from
manufacturing Medical
Hospitality electrical construction
other
trades we had goals for which targets we
should expect graduates to be able to
hit considering the importance of adding
those skill sets to our state's
economy New Hampshire is primarily a
small business State uh it's no secret
the manufacturing industry is aging and
is in desperate need of younger workers
in most if not all of the job placements
I was involved in uh in order for our
graduates to hit program wage goals uh
which in New Hampshire are lower than
some of those goals of other neighboring
states in New
England um they would have to work
overtime overnight with differential pay
or relocate to other
states
um
whereas the union jobs that the
graduates would uh would
get um would tend to be some of the the
best job placements that we could
find what they've offered to the workers
and what effect uh unions have on our
economy outweighs the supposed negatives
uh with uh you know as stated by other
people that there is no forced uh union
dues uh it's not surprising to see right
to work taken up in the legislature
given the current composition however I
would implore you to consider these
economic
downsides uh I'm available for any
questions but I can't guarantee I have
information sufficient uh to answer them
as I'm uh no longer in that kind of a
role this time but I do appreciate you
calling on me and hearing me
out thank you for your testimony any
questions here in the
L present seeing none any
online I don't see any thank you Mr
Lloyd for your testimony thank you take
care
everyone next up is Mark Rocco followed
by Tyler
Eaton and then
Brenda
fter Brenda falter do I have
Mark
dco do I
have was it
eaten yes you have no Mark dco online D
capital r
CCO
no I do not hey Tyler Eaton or excuse
me tiller it says T yeah t l e r Tyler
yes I'm here thank you you recognized to
speak okay uh thank you for giving me
the opportunity to speak today uh again
my name is Tyler Eon I live in notingham
New Hampshire and I'm an international
rep for the
ibw and it's no secret it's it's been a
tough year for uh New Hampshire
Electrical Workers throughout this
covid-19 pandemic thousands of members
from International Brotherhood
Electrical Workers have shown up each
day to ensure the light stay on our
members have been regarded for decades
as some of the highest quality hardest
working linemen in the state and for
good reason every year dozens of
hardworking union members graduate from
the ibw local 104's apprenticeship
program located in barington New
Hampshire the program is part of a
longstanding partnership with the
northeastern apprenticeship and training
once members who also are paid during
the duration of their apprenticeship
graduate they are fully prepared and for
a rewarding career as a journey and
lineman not only do they guaranteed jobs
with one of the uh ibw signatory
contractors they also have the
opportunity to travel with their
nationally recognized do
certificate um why am I telling you this
because New Hampshire lawmakers are in
the process of hearing a bill that would
directly weaken this program and
programs like it across the
state if sb61 is passed Right to Work
bill would dramatically weaken private
unions such as ibw 104 we have worked
for over a century at no cost to
taxpayers build relationship with
contractors across New England who know
when they hire workers from us they are
getting highly skilled hardworking
employees
um I have other stuff but you've heard
all of it about the statistics so i'
just like to say also as a a line
worker um our members perform work for
several
utilities that not only uh have uh
property in New Hampshire but also have
property in other New England states so
when one of our contractors was awarded
a a pro a contract say from eversource
that contract is for the entire property
and my concern is if a uh employee from
New Hampshire decides to become a
non-paying member and then while working
on a project in New Hampshire what
happens to that individual when the next
project is in
Massachusetts and thank you for
listening to my
testimony thank you I appreciate uh your
testimony are there any questions for
the presenter on
Zoom seeing none any in the
L Vice chairman seor thank you Mr
chairman and um thank you Mr eaten for
your presentation my question is if you
know if you have a sense of for the
contracts that you negotiate in New
Hampshire how many require agency fees
from
non-members as a percentage and
generally what
percentage uh would you say of the
employees that you represent are
non-members that pay agency
Fe I would I would say that on the uh
the hiring Hall part of uh Local 104
there's 100% union membership by choice
I mean nobody's uh request wed paying
agency fee or any of
that again my concern though is when we
again work for just say ABC Electric and
again the first project may be in
Manchester New Hampshire and that that
project's completed for ever Source you
could be assigned to a job say in
Hoppington Massachusetts so if
somebody's a uh non uh fee paying or
doesn't want to pay dues I mean the only
Al alternative for them is to be let go
when they move to the next
project and this happen not only osource
National Grid Liberty they all have
multiple State jurisdiction
now thank
you J did I see your hand raised yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Eaton um you mentioned you currently
have 100% union membership uh
voluntarily no agency fees uh if right
this current bill right to work were to
go through what do you believe your the
percentage of union membership would be
following passage Right to
Work Well I I would I would hope it
would be 100% but my again my concern
would be more for that a a New Hampshire
uh
resident could
be again only and if he's working for a
contractor the contractor can't say the
uh eversource or National Grid listen I
got some people that they can only work
in New Hampshire I mean the contract is
a blanket agreement that you work for
ever Source where they where they so
choose so my concern would be these
people would be left out they'd be they
laid off they could even be terminated
for not being able to fulfill what
they're supposed to in the
contract now go into an area where again
it's not a right to work
state you have f
yes thank you Mr chairman thank I guess
I'm just very confused on this issue um
it local four that is in Nottingham is
that correct Local 104 it's uh in
barington New
Hampshire with the out outside line
workers okay all right thank
you any other questions for the superer
seeing none thank you very much next up
Brenda falter rich jinus and Jeff
Hamill we have Brenda falter with
us Brenda
falter you
hi hello welcome hi my name is Brenda
fter and I thank you very much for
allowing me to speak
today um I'm speaking against the Right
to Work bill I come from a long line of
strong Republic Republican New Hampshire
Yankees dating back to the 1600s
and my husband our children and I are a
union family and we have been for over
years it was the union wages that kept
us above water during the tough
times because the union members fought
for higher Wagers better benefits and
improved working conditions Union and
non-union um households profited
remember no workers are forced to work
for a union company it's their choice if
they don't want to pay union dues don't
work for a union
company please don't send our state
citizens backwards when you cast your
vote please think about your neighbors
your friends and your Town's people can
they afford to lose income wages will go
down we see that in other right to work
states around this
country not all of them make respectable
living wages is that what you and your
good conscience and heart are willing to
do I hope not help the people in New
Hampshire please vote
no thank
you thank you very much your testimony
are there questions in the
lb representative turov
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Miss
falter for the question I have just one
really quick one was that your husband
you shoved out of the way a few minutes
ago yes it was and he's on the list to
come back and talk to you too okay very
good thank you but I wrote my own speech
that wasn't
him other questions
NE see n any questions
online all right thank you
uh very much for your testimony Miss
falter and as I see Thomas Walter is
also signed up to speak I assume you're
going to uh share the same connection so
I would recognize thas falter
next Mr chairman a question not related
to the uh and before you start yes
what's the uh do we intend on taking any
kind of a break at at some point or so
uh I slid in here the um because the
chairman had planned to take his lunch
break at once at one and I think that
was his plan for today rather than break
the session for lunch uh to leave that
up to individuals step
out thank
you um so again uh Thomas
falter go
ahead and you're muted again if you can
unmute yourself we can't hear
you how's that can you hear me that's
great you know we're not the greatest
with electronics here you know I thought
I was trying to be helpful but I guess I
wasn't now you've you've you've heard
from a lot of eloquent speakers today
and I'll probably not be the most
delegant but I have personal experience
um and I'm a construction worker have
been for over 40 years as Brenda told
you uh and you know I've never heard
anybody on the job site say you know we
need right to work this make a a life so
much better never once uh I'm from over
in Greenville in the whips switch area
and there's a lot of construction
workers there well we're not talking
about right to work you know some of the
things we are talking about unfunded
mandates big that's big controversy I
hope you'll do something about that as
well
uh you know schools you know those are
the important things this this is comes
up every year and and it drains a lot of
resources
so you know what what's the real reason
for this uh you know why why do we have
to uh listen to it every year I mean
there's choices to be made and the
Reverend made a good point you know we
have to pay our toll Greenville is still
a town meeting we come in we decide what
we want we make those choices and we
decide how much money it's going to take
and then we pay our taxes and those who
don't pay their taxes guess what happens
to them I'm sure you know I so in my
union I I pay for everything everything
comes out of my pocket
I decided what kind of programs we're
going to have I decide I get a vote on
my insurance I get a vote on my training
I have to do my own
training I I don't get any holidays no
holidays at all I don't get any vacation
pay all comes out of my money absolutely
no seniority I'm as good as my last
paycheck that's the way it works so and
I've done this for a number of years and
I you know are there complainers sure
there are you know this complaint is
about paying taxes this complaint is
about paying tolls but so what's the
right what's the real benefit how am I
going to benefit from this and you know
some of the
reasons I have uh I'd like to go into is
the right to work you know it it it's
really taking away my
rights uh you know and other and other
people from New Hampshire their rights
as well the federal law already
already is enforced it's through the uh
ta back and you know in my union I know
if you don't even like we have a
political action uh fund if you don't
want to pay into it if you have some
problems with uh with how they they're
being uh spent you don't have to pay
into it you don't have to work for that
Union shop up there there's always
choices so why why exactly are we
adopting it I mean other states have
adopted this and and and it's shown that
working families suffer all the time how
do they suffer they have lower pay uh
paying jobs much lower uh there's more
Glenn bracket Mr Brackett he talked
about it more fatalities in the
workplace so you have to ask you who's
pushing this I I don't see any I don't
see any workers up here saying give me
right to work I only see special
interest groups and they want to take
away our civil and workplace rights from
our families so the answer to the
question is they're just looking for
higher profits for themselves at the
expense of me the New Hampshire family
working person and even governor sonunu
in 2018 he said there's no need and I
heard that there's no need to pursue any
additional legislation so why so what
he's really saying is in other words why
should government get involved in legal
matters relating to the contract between
the employer and the employee why would
this body insert itself into the
marketplace with its thumb on the scale
against the Working Families of New
Hampshire so
why
why why do we need this that's really
and and what's it going to do for me
because that's really what it is there's
many more of me we're construction
workers what am I going to how am I
going to benefit from this tell me
what's the
guarantees and I I thank you very
much thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for the speaker on
Zoom I don't see any are there any
questions here in the
lob thank you once again for your
testimony coming up next
um we're going to have Rick jinus next
followed by Jeff Hamill followed by John
Judkins so if Rick jinus is on can you
hear me I can go ahead please thank you
Mr Vice chairman and members of the
committee uh what I've had to say has
been said by so many other people before
me today you have my written testimony
so I'm just going to try to touch on a
few brief
things
um uh take you know out of respect for
your time and the the committee and
everybody else's time uh what I'd like
to start with is I I I want to say that
I'm glad that Mr vermi in his uh
testimony in support of the
bill uh mind you that I am opposed to
the bill in his testimony and support of
the bill he
acknowledged uh that
uh that nobody can be forced to join a
labor union and he also acknowledged the
fact that that that this bill
would uh create the existence of free
free what he called free writers or I
would refer to as Free Loaders but I'm
glad that he acknowledged that the other
thing I wanted to touch on is I believe
representative turkot had asked the
question um regarding uh money and money
coming into the state to oppose this uh
and nobody has spoke on it yet but do
believe the union leader had some
extensive reporting on the fact that Mr
Baker's
organization uh I believe spent 10 uh
$100,000 with $10,000 contributions to
10 uh members of the state senate uh in
support of this um so and then the other
thing I I wish the chairman was here
because he um he's he's
uh had a few questions regarding how um
Right to Work could affect us being a
more unsafe
workplace uh in the state of New
Hampshire and while I understand it's
anecdotal you know my daughter works for
a uh well-known nationally recognized
retailer that they're publicly traded
she uh had to clean up some broken glass
and she cut her
hand not only did they not even Pro
offer her medical attention they didn't
take an accident
report uh you know and and I can tell
you where I work and I've been a a union
member for close to 33 years where I
work that wouldn't have flown because
there's a check and balance with the
Union there there there's somebody
looking to make sure that the company is
going to follow the rules now where I
work I think the company's a great
company and they would follow the rules
but it isn't always the case uh as you
as you see here and so um you know
there's that check to make sure okay
this this employee is going to fill out
an accident report and um you know going
to get the Med medical attention that
that they need so those are a few of the
things that I I wanted to touch on uh
that I've heard here this morning and
like I said um I'm going to you've got
my written testimony but I I just want
to touch on some of the more personal uh
issues like I said I've been at my place
of employment for nearly 33 years in
that time I've been a member of my union
uh at times I've held various leadership
positions and in that time I've served
on the bargaining committee and
participated in the negotiation of six
collective bargaining agreements at no
time did my employer or a coworker ever
propose what this ill intended
legislation seeks to do which begs the
question why would the government want
to insert itself into this process why
would you want to alter this component
of the New Hampshire
Advantage thanks to my Union contract
and my employer I find myself squarely
in the middle class I was able to buy my
home at 23 years old I have the
disposable income to take my family
skiing or any number of other activities
I'm able to support my church I'm able
to contribute to deserving organizations
such as the New Hampshire Food Bank New
Hampshire Special Olympics New Hampshire
Public Radio New Hampshire public
television the nsha soup kitchen and
shelter the NASA Children's Home and
more it seems to me this bill is a
solution to a problem that doesn't exist
here in the 603
I ask you to consider the unintended
consequences of its becoming law and I
respectfully ask you to find it
inexpedient to legislate thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for um this speaker
on
Zoom I don't see any are there any
questions here in the
O seeing none thank you once again for
your testimony thank you coming up next
the next three are Jeff Hamill then John
Judkins then Mike
King is Jeff Hamill
available I don't see him if he is not
available we'll move on to John John
Judkins Mike King and Marco
lass
is John
Judkins
answer I do not see him coming up so
we'll move on to Mike King Marco laass
and Phil
ly is Mike King
on Mr Vice
chair yes uh representative K uh Miss
DWI asked me to take over and yet I
don't seem to have the ability to
promote people uh maybe we need to look
at that uh let me see if I can get a
hold of her and we can sort this
out okay do are uh are there people that
I called that are on but we can't
promote them right now I see Jeff
Hamill okay so Jeff Hamill is available
and we just we need to get some help
promoting him right
um Miss Dyer did you step away from the
screen yeah I think she
did
I'm sorry I did step away for a moment
um how can I
help uh I don't seem to be able to
promote the people that are on the list
is that am I in the wrong status myself
you may be let's do
that okay go right ahead head let me see
Jeff Hamill yes there we
go all right thank you um sorry Mr
Hamill for skipping over you uh
please it's Jeff H here can you hear me
now yes yes I can go ahead good
afternoon my name is Jeff Hamill I'm a
registered Republican voter from
Kensington New Hampshire I'm also a
proud Union member of local 1202 4 for
the past 26 years I'm here today to ask
you to vote against
sb61 the right to work's misleading it's
all about union busting and it's an
attack on the middle class the right to
work is about increasing the power for
corporations and reducing the power for
union
workers right to work states have lower
wages less Health Care coverage and
higher workplace fatality is this
something we really want in the
603 our hardworking Union families of
New Hampshire do not need unnecessary
government interference in our
employment
decisions lastly I would kindly ask if
Mark Mi the president of National Right
to Work committee out of Virginia is on
here to please stop sending me mail
asking for donations up to
$500 thank you for your time and please
vote no on sb61
thank you very much are there questions
for this speaker in
the seeing none anyone online have a
question I don't see any hands so thank
you again for your testimony thank you
um next up will be John Judkins followed
by Mike King followed by Marco laass is
Mr Judkins on the uh Zo
I don't see
him all right um so moving on we'll uh
look for Mike King then Marco laass and
then Phil ly is Mike King
available
not seeing Mr King
either all right next so we'll move on
to Marco laass followed by Phil ly
followed by
Joe we have Marco
laass all right and then third up is Joe
morazzi so so Mr
laass please can you hear me yes I
can thank you uh committee members for
having us uh testify here today uh my
name is Marco laass I'm the business
agent for ibw local 490 here in cona New
Hampshire uh and uh I'm uh testifying to
oppose s
sp61 uh defendants of Right to Work
argue that it is about practicing
protecting the freedom of whether or not
workers can join a union well the truth
is that always has been legally
federally illegal to force anyone to
join a union the real Freedom comes from
the opportunities you get when you join
a union you get better wages health care
benefits and
more because of what union members have
provided for our state we get to live
free free with the ability to stick up
for ourselves on the job
free with knowing union dues not taxes
are paying for apprenti ship programs
and job training and yes free with the
ability to choose whether or not to join
a
union in February West Virginia governor
Jim Justice said the following on camera
during a town hall the bottom line is
really
simple we want out we want we went out
and passed right to work we got rid of
prevailing wages
we built Fields all over the place
thinking corporations would come and
they didn't come did they right now the
same law that Governor Justice is
referring to right to work is up for the
House vote in New Hampshire and here we
have an elected official Governor
Justice saying in plainest possible
terms that we have known in New
Hampshire for Generations that right to
work is a law that provides neither
rights nor work
New Hampshire state motto is live for
your
die so let's stick by our motto and I
ask you to reject Senate Bill 61 thank
you thank you very much are there
questions for the speaker in the
O I don't see any anybody on Zoom have a
question seeing none once again thank
you very much for your testimony we'll
be moving on
um if he's available Phil lery followed
by Joe morazzi followed by Chuck
McGee is Mr lry
available hi yes Mr lry coming
up good hi can every can everybody hear
me yes we can how you doing um I'd like
to thank the chair and the committee for
letting me speak today
uh my name is Phil Larry I'm a resident
and taxpayer in the state of New
Hampshire and a member of the district
council 35 painters and Alli trades I've
been involved with um organized labor
for 20 years being a part of a union and
always knowing that the union has my
back and Bargains on my behalf for all
the great wages and benefit benefits I
receive for myself and my family is the
greatest failing to have knowing that I
can retire at a decent age is what I
strive for every worker already has the
right to either join a union or not the
New Hampshire motto is Live Free or Die
being in a union and paying dues is for
the union to collectively bargain on
your behalf it's no different than any
other membership fee you would have to
pay to a golf course gym Costco BJs Etc
or the Chamber of Commerce and I quote
to get started complete your application
and we we will collect your $25
application fee once we review your
application we will invoice you for your
membership dues and we are of and
running right to work actually has
nothing to do with worker freedom and
everything to do with breaking organized
labor and strengthening corporate
control over politics workers have very
little bargaining power in the United
States in most developed countries
workers have more say and working
conditions tend to be better in America
unless you're in a union the workplace
Dynamic gives all the power to the owner
the business interests if business
interests are not checked by the
bargaining power of labor unions and
other worker groups then we will become
a developing country the safe
the safest most um trained and skilled
labor is that of union labor we fight
every day not just for union labor but
for labor in general this so-called
Right to Work bill is nothing as it
reads it is a right to work for Less
studies show that workers in right to
work states make 10,000 less a year
while the CEOs get 320 times richer off
the back of the workers unions make up
7% of the workforce in this country in
the construction field it's about 4%
this country was built on union labor
it's because of organ organized labor
and the right to collect collectively
bargain is why we have eight hour work
days 5ay work weeks and 40-hour work
weeks sick leave Etc this is why we have
the safest workers and work sites going
today and this is all factual
information working people in right to
work states have consistently lower
quality of life when you compare right
to work states and free bargaining
States the differences are not
comparable they have less Access to
Health Care poor education systems for
children the poverty rate is higher and
the risk of workplace fatalities is 49%
higher when working people can't freely
speak up together they can't negotiate
for higher safety standards better
training Fair wages and health benefits
and this will impact all of us Union and
non-union alike right to work will lower
wages cause higher workplace injuries
and increase poverty will this make our
will this make our state more attractive
I don't think so I urge you to vote no
on S sp61 right to work is wrong for New
Hampshire and I'm open to any questions
if anybody has any all right thank you
very much does anybody have questions
for this speaker on
Zoom I don't see any any questions in
the
LLB seeing none thank you again for your
testimony thank you
very you're welcome um up next we have
Joe morazzi followed by Chuck McGee
followed by Jennifer
Perry morazzi available morazzi coming
out Mr morazzi you there you
go Mr Vice chair and committee thank you
for the time
today to testify I want to tell you guys
about a work stoppage I was involved in
that lasted 210 days me Union member
that lives in Salem New Hampshire and my
union and I were fighting against a
greedy international
corporation it was a work stop which
related to them pretty much trying to
take what we already had we weren't
asking for anything they were just
trying
to take what we
had if it wasn't for my union my family
and I as well as all my other Union
members would not have been able to
sustain for seven
months if sb61 passes it might not
happen tomorrow but down the road you
will Blue Collar middle class
Working
Families that's all I wanted to say and
again thank you for your
time thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for this uh
individual from inside the lb I see none
any questions
online seeing none thank you once again
um we'll move on up next we have Chuck
McGee followed by Jennifer
Perry followed
by um Sean
roach so Mr mcke if you are
[Music]
available
I don't see him unless it's a phone
number all right if
I'm accidentally skipping over you
please raise your hand so we can so we
can see you um if not we'll move on to
Jennifer Perry followed
by Shan roach followed by Tony
Sapienza um is Miss MC or Miss Perry
available not seeing that name
either all right if Miss Perry is not
available we'll move on to Sean roach
followed by Tony Sapienza followed
by David
spul is Mr roach
online
I see Tony Sapienza how does that how
does that work for
you let's move on
to uh Mr
Sapienza and we have on Deck then third
in line will be the Reverend Jason Wells
so you can uh get ready if you're
available and Mr
Sapienza please give your
testimony
hello and thank you for uh allowing me
to speak my name is Tony Sapienza and
I'm the elected business manager of ibw
local
1837 I was elected by the members who
work in the electric utility industry
these are the people who restore your
power after storms disable the electric
distribution
system safety and training are our top
priorities we work cooperative with the
electric utilities in the Manchester
Community College to build a Workforce
for New Hampshire through the best
apprenticeships
available s sp61 is simply wrong for New
Hampshire let's be clear nobody can be
forced to join my union that's already
against the law that's a simple fact
remember as others have told you already
nobody can be forced to join my union
that's against the
law however unions are required to
service non-members at the expense of
the existing
members that's just patently
unfair uh negotiating administering
contracts and protecting workers wages
and benefits cost
money why why would we want to force
some people to
pay and allow others to ride for free it
just just it's just not the New
Hampshire
way currently non-union members can only
be required to pay their fair share for
these vital
Services what's wrong with paying your
fair share when you're when you're
getting the benefit of the
services the only purpose of this bill
is to increase corporate power at the
expense of working
people obviously wages and benefits will
erode faster or grow slower if
corporations are empowered and
collective bargaining rights are
eroded we've heard this the statistics
but the point is
obvious Corporation corporate power
wants to reduce the unions and that will
hurt Working Families and hurt working
people across the
state I ask you to reject sb61 as New
Hampshire has done in a bipartisan way
every time it's come up over the last 4
40 plus
years for 40 years we've been working
bipartisan to to defeat this bad
legislation please continue to do
that thank you for your
time thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for this speaker in
the
L seeing none anyone online have a
question for the
speaker I don't see any hands so thank
you once again for your
testimony
um we'll move on
if David spui is
available followed by Reverend Wells no
we have
David R right I see him there you are
muted Mr
SPI
[Music]
Mr spula you are still muted if you can
take yourself off
mute we can hear
you
I am going I don't know if um Mr smuli
is having technical issues or if maybe
he stepped away from his
screen um so what I'm going to do is
move on to the next speaker and then
we'll come back and see
if see if he can resolve his issue there
the next
speaker oh I see he raised his hand um I
can't see the chat
here there he's on there we
go hello yes we can hear
you sorry about that can you hear me yes
okay sorry um yes I would like to uh say
I'm David Puli um from eping New
Hampshire been a lifelong New Hampshire
resident um used to be a student for Mr
uh Donald Bard one of the
representatives so hi Mr bushard uh I'd
like to oppose uh s
sp61 um we had this back in um 1945 in
the state of New Hampshire and uh it was
repelled in
1947 um I just don't think it's good for
New Hampshire Working Families as you
guys know there are a number of people
who have signed up in opposition to this
that far outweigh the um people who are
in favor for it and you know
Representatives you know I represent
with uh another local in New Hampshire
nearly a thousand New
Hampshire union members and families and
uh you know we we the voice of what
we're supposed to be for our halls and
you know as Representatives we're voices
you guys are voices for the people of
New Hampshire I just don't think it's
good for New Hampshire um you know
there's been talks that businesses can't
engage with
their union members um once they have
them on the job site that's who they do
engage with so it's not like Union
business managers
are keeping contractors away from the
employees that they employ um already in
state of New Hampshire NH hrsa
275-1 States union membership no person
shall coers or compel or attempt to coer
or compel any person into an agreement
either written or vable not to join or
to become a member of any labor
organization as a condition of securing
or continuing in any employment so this
is kind of already redundant uh people
have the option not to join so i' ask
you to uh itl SPS
61 thank you for your testimony are
there
any questions
online seeing none any here in the
L seeing none thank you very
much next up is referend J uh Jason
Wells followed by Mark
ataran is the Reverend Wells with
us I don't see him unless it's a phone
number which I case I wouldn't
know all right Mark ataran
a Andrew Beamer from
conquer uh Mr Beamer wrote to say that
he did not want to
testify Daniel
bodden from
marac
John BNA pay from Melrose
Mass I think we have that
one Sor repres kill yes here we are we
have a
winner Mr chair can you hear
me hello just a moment John yes just
just a quick question um I I noticed we
going two people kind of fast so I just
want to make sure that like if somebody
has a step off for a commitment and they
come back later they signed up to
testify they'll still get that
opportunity want make
sure see your
friends yes we're gonna let anyone who
um I'm writing um a little notation next
to everyone's name uh that was not able
to so if they come on we'll go through
those again okay
um Mr
uh thank you very much sorry for the
delay you recognized to speak well thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for
members of the committee appreciate this
opportunity to speak my name is John
bonani I am a staff representative for
the United Steel Workers Union the steel
workers represent thousands of people
throughout the country in Canada who
work in a number of different industries
from steel utilities Health Care law
enforcement um you could probably name
almost any industry in the Ste or
because have people who who work in it
um I live in Massachusetts but um
probably like many of the state reps
attending this hearing today I've spent
a big chunk of my career representing
good people good working people in the
state of New Hampshire I was actually a
gas worker for over 30 years in the
field um I was a president of a local
Amalgamated Union which had members in
both New Hampshire and M Massachusetts
so I have a lot of friends and I
represent a lot of people um who live
and work in in the good State of New
Hampshire um many of these
people cross the Gambit as far as
political persuasion um but I can say a
majority of them in the state of New
Hampshire are registered Republicans um
and I can tell you whatever their
political affiliation and I continue to
talk to the people I've represented um
they all say right to work isn't good
for them it's not good for them it's not
good for their families it's not good
for the State of New Hampshire um
they've said this now 39 times um as
it's been stated previously through the
representation um through you through
their body um voted down 39
times I I've continually asked what's
change why this legislation why is it
being considered again you look at the
other states that have passed right to
work I can get you all the data you want
anything you want to see it hasn't
helped any of the Working Families in
those States it hasn't helped the states
themselves um it it hasn't helped them
financially and it and I can tell you it
certainly hasn't helped their reputation
a as a state that is concerned about
their employees
the people who work in those States for
the different companies that operate in
them um I continually ask people um what
they what comes to their mind when when
you hear a right to work state well
what's the first thing you think of and
I get all kinds of different answers and
none of them are good uh people
say struggling population cheap labor
exploited
Workforce um companies taking advantage
of their states and the government um
that that's what's on people's minds
when they hear the words right to work
state and again I can get
you any data you think you need because
it all supports these opinions as as
accurate um I have to ask respectfully
um do you want to see the good
reputation of this state tarnished um
this is how people will see this state
moving forward if this legislation
passes do you want to know that
hardworking New Hampshire people um feel
proud to live and work in this state I I
think everybody does and I I
respectfully ask you to
please um like the good people before
you the 39 times before you um say no to
this legislation do not let this pass um
make this the 40th
time and and just to leave off
respectfully um this legislation it's
not it's not in the best interests of
never mind the state but the country
it's it's unamerican to force an
organization to provide service without
payment it's absolutely unamerican and
should not be taking place in this good
State thank
you thank you for your testimony
are there any questions for the
presenter
on live on
Zoom seeing none any here in the
L seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony thank you next in line
the next three people James
cardillo Mike
desario Cheryl
ferello James cardillo are you with
us
Mike
desario from plastow are you with us
bring up James cardello just a moment
please yep James
cardillo Mr cardillo you're here on the
labor committee we can hear you please
free to
testify good afternoon and thank you for
allowing me to speak
my name is Jim cadillo and I live in
Londoner and I oppose this bill it seems
the majority of States who have been
right to work the longest are failing
they have the highest poverty rates in
the country and looking at the states
that have been right to work the longest
made more sense to me than looking at
the most recent I live in London Derry I
have two kids we love the town and the
schools I work in New Hampshire now but
there were years that I couldn't I had
to work in Massachusetts it's not that I
couldn't get a job in New Hampshire I
could I just couldn't make the same
money and I couldn't get benefits the
companies that I did work for in New
Hampshire that did offer benefits I was
paid too low to actually take advantage
of them so I did that commute every day
losing hours with my family sitting in
traffic and I wasn't alone in 2017 there
were over a 100,000 people that made
that
commute Massachusetts isn't right to
work it's a very Union Den State and
business was booming there enough so
that it was is taking care of a large
number of families in our state so when
people talk about business coming here
if we're right to work what kind of
business and do we even want them here
if they're coming here just to pay low
wages and with terrible benefits if any
benefits at all um business in mass is
there because there was a well-trained
Workforce and the reason for that is
unions spend a lot of money on training
their members the people I talked to in
New Hampshire that are members of a
union are proud of it they do better
better pay and better benefits I do I
joined a union later in life I was by
far the oldest Apprentice at that time
joining a union in the training that got
me changed my life the only regret I
have is not joining earlier I own a home
in New Hampshire now and I work in New
Hampshire now and I'll tell you what
working both non-union and Union in my
life trying to negotiate with a business
owner by yourself is can certainly be
difficult as a construction worker Union
reps listen to their membership about
their concerns before they
negotiate well let me leave it at this
today we have heard from people
representing business owners and out of
state interest in favor of this bill and
all your constituents that you represent
seem to be against it so please do the
right thing and kill this Bill thank
you any questions from Mr cordillo on
Zoom seeing none any here in the
lob San thank you very much for your
testimony next up is Mike desario Follow
by Cheryl
fillo is Mike with
us
hello hello yes uh this you're yes Mike
we can hear you
um how you doing um thank you for your
time my name is Mike desario I'm from
plast down New Hampshire um I've been in
the Union for um about eight years now
and uh to me right to work is
disrespectful to myself my family and my
union brother and
sisters this this bill is blatant union
busting
um I have tremendous pride in paying my
dues and having my Union's
protection and
um and uh I'm not from a union family
but I'm trying to build one with my wife
and I won't be able to if right to work
uh passes so um I reject right to work
and hope everyone else will also uh
thank you for your
time any
questions online for Mr
desario any in the L I have one this is
representative will infantine you just
said that you won't be able able to do
so a union family with your wife if this
passes could you explain why you feel
that
way um because I feel with right to work
there won't be a
union if I can't pay my dues then there
is no
Union understood thank you very much for
your answer are there any other
questions so thank you very much Mr
desario next up is Cheryl fillo followed
by Patrick RAM and Blain
Hansen Cheryl
ruer from Newton New
Hampshire Cheryl followed by Patrick
Graham followed by Blaine Hansen
followed by Ken
white hello Cheryl onute needs to be
M Cheryl you're on can you hear me now
gentlemen yes we can thank you good
afternoon chairman and members of the
service committee my name is shff Rulo I
am here today in opposition to
sb61 I have lived in Newton New
Hampshire for 14 years I'm a proud
member of UFCW Local
144 Cheryl we can't hear you
Cheryl Cheryl we can see your face but
we can't hear
you know I say better through the years
of contract
negotiations my union has fought for
higher wages health care and day-to-day
safety on the job collectively we come
together to ensure that the workers have
the resources that we need to survive
and thrive we are a family at local 14
45 and look out for each other no year
has been tougher than the last year of
the pandemic when others were told to
stay home we were told to show up at
work initial protocols on how to stay
safe were unclear but my union worked
with the employer to put safety Pro
Protections in place and to Advocate to
elected officials for workers
protections if this legislation were in
place workers would not be able to stand
to fight for their protections for
higher wages and benefits in the health
care that every family
needs and all the benefits that we need
for good jobs in New Hampshire and good
jobs that support our communities State
W states with so-called right to work
laws have lower wages in higher
accidents and death rates on the jobs
than States like New Hampshire that
enable workers to come together to
negotiate for protections on the job
over the last year essential workers
have stepped up to keep our community
safe take care of the sick and make sure
our food supply is safe and secure these
workers should have the ability to use
their Collective voice to ensure to
ensure on the job
protections with higher wages and
benefits I'm asking you to please do not
take the work as collective voice away
at the workplace a voice we use to make
sure we have resources to provide for
our amilies similar so-called Right to
Work bills have come before the
legislature over the years time and time
again elected elers like you put the
hardworking people of New Hampshire
first and voted down these so-called
Right to Work
bills right to work was wrong then and
it is wrong now now is time to help the
workers who have been on the front lines
of this pandemic stay safe not weaking
their voice at the workplace I ask you
to please vote note on
sb61 thank you for your
time thank you for your testimony there
any questions for the presenter online
on
Zoom seeing none any in the
L seean thank you very much for your
testimony thank you gentlemen is Patrick
gram followed by Blaine Hansen Karen
hoit and Scott carlberg Carl's carlberg
is Patrick Braham with
us Patrick
Graham how about Blaine
Hansen from marac
Mr chairman yes sir we can hear you all
right this is Blain Hansen uh I am a
member of local 352 Carpenters out of
Manchester New Hampshire I am a resident
of marac New
Hampshire um I'm here to voice my
opinion uh in opposition to this
legislation um today I've heard many
people speak uh the vast majority in
fact the entire majority of people
speaking in favor of this legislation
have been uh business
organizations uh some from inst State
some from out of state uh I have not
heard one single person who represents
workers speak in favor of this
legislation uh everybody knows that this
is union busting legislation and that's
it it does not bring in quality jobs to
the state of New Hampshire it doesn't in
the other state that it's been inacted
um New Hampshire doesn't need meat
packing plants or low wage manufacturing
jobs New Hampshire needs careers I drive
to work every morning down Route three
or Route 93 and across 128 into
Massachusetts and I see a veritable
who's who of the Fortune 500 the NASDAQ
the S&P all those companies are in
Massachusetts which some of you folks
and Conquer tell us is over taxed and
over regulated yet all these businesses
go there my question to you folks is why
would you pass a piece of regressive
legislation that's going to make working
conditions in New Hampshire even worse
you folks should be spending your time
trying to figure out why those companies
do not come to the state of New
Hampshire we supposedly have the New
Hampshire Advantage we continually top
out polls for quality of life and best
places to live
yet all these businesses locate a mere
50 mes south of us and as the gentleman
stated earlier you've got a 100,000
people who get up every single morning
and drive into Massachusetts which is
the total antithesis of a right to work
state so you gentlemen and ladies uh in
the legislature have some things you
need to figure out and figure out why
these companies don't locate in New
Hampshire we have an educated Workforce
which is actually shrinking because our
young people are leaving the state in
search of higher wages and better
benefits the cost of living in New
Hampshire is outstripping the wages in
New Hampshire so we're going to continue
to you lose our smartest and youngest
people to other
states I graduated high school in 1985
and more than half of my graduating
class lives outside the state of New
Hampshire and several of them I have
spoken to and they mentioned one thing
the money's better elsewhere and the
benefits are better elsewhere this
legislation is not going to make job
conditions in the state of New Hampshire
any better than they already are it's
going to make it worse thank you for
your time and I appreciate the
opportunity to speak on this
bill there any questions Mr Hansen
online any questions here in the
see none thank you for your testimony Mr
Hansen thank you Mr chairman
and next up is Karen hoit followed by
Scott carlberg and Sarah
kooi is Ken Hoy with
us
if not Ken hoit Scott
carlberg Scott carlberg from Hampton New
Hampshire or Ken hoit from
Rochester I don't see either
one up there he is
hello hello yes we hear you you are free
to testify okay thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Scott calberg and I am opposed to S
sp61 I think that the right to work
movement is misleading it says that in
states that support Right to Work
employees have more spendable after tax
money and I have a hard time believing
that 23 years ago was working for a
non-union company on a bridge project
and had the opportunity to join the
operating engineers which I did I went
from making 12250 an hour with terrible
Insurance to making $21 an hour in
excellent
Insurance within a short time I was able
to buy my first house and at the same
time I watched my friends at the
non-union company I had worked with
continue to struggle just as I had we
all had small families to support and
over time they had some success at the
jobs all of them got raises and did a
little better some better than others
and some not as much I on the other hand
had benefited from a collective
bargaining agreement where we received
what amounts to a regular cost of living
wage in decent working
conditions in short I was doing much
better than they than my
friends what I had that they didn't was
someone who interceded on my behalf that
was Adept at negotiating I likened it to
buying a car if you can negotiate well
you do better for yourself and if you
aren't a good negotiator you do poorly
most people aren't Adept at negotiating
so there are varied results I have a
friend that owns a landscape business in
New Hampshire and he say says he pays up
to a $10 an hour difference for the same
position for employees because of this
practice this shows what happens when
you make your own
deal I was once told by Mr Ed Fish who
was the owner of suff construction which
is a nationwide building contractor that
a true deal is when he pays more than he
wanted and the subcontractor didn't get
all that he wanted he followed that up
with saying the deals are really evenly
worked out Mr Fish was a billionaire an
expert negotiator that worked with
unions and non-union companies
alike I believe it believe that if you
don't want to be part of a union you
don't have to so don't seek a job that
is Union if you do want to a job that is
Union has a union connected to it you
should take that into
account asking why the job has the pay
the conditions and the benefits that you
are seeking it didn't get to be a
sought-after position because everyone
fought for themselves it was the union
behind it that made it appealing to you
and you should support that if you don't
like unions seek out a non-union
position and apply for that right to
work vilifies unions but the leadership
in a union isn't about being in charge
it's about taking care of those in your
charge right to work claims a monetary
benefit to workers on their website but
no other claims of workers rights all
workers union and non-union should thank
a union for these things Family Medical
Leave Act unemployment insurance 40-hour
work week paid vacation paid overtime
sick leave minimum wage sexual
harassment laws whistleblower protection
laws and employer healthc care uh
workplace safety standards which would
uh be OSHA uh wrongful termination laws
workman's comp veterans employment and
training services military leave
Americans with Disabilities Act among a
list of other
others and where has the right to work
helped any employee I can't seem to find
a similar
list um it was a observation I had uh
listening to all the other people who uh
test
ified that uh the right to work lobbyist
was saying that they are protecting what
seems to be a a very small minority of
people who don't want to pay these union
dues or fees and um which amounts to a
couple hundred dollars as they claim uh
for each of these people so why are they
spending millions of dollars to save me
$200 uh just seems like there's a little
bit more uh going on than my
$200 uh thank
you okay thank you for your testimony
there are any questions for the
presenter
online he's gone seeing none any here in
the L representative turot thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr carlberg for
taking the question you mentioned that
the beginning of your
testimony that uh you went from 1250 an
hour to 20 150 an hour by joining the
union which I think is awesome um I'm a
36e union
member many people don't know that um
could you do you have any idea why your
friends remained at 1250 an hour when
they had the opportunity to go to 2150
and
hour Mr chairman uh I believe it's Scott
carlberg just left he signed off without
oh there he is hello yeah we hear you
yeah it had to reconnect I don't know
what happened um well not everybody had
the same uh position I did
uh I I was I was doing a a typical um
you know one day I was a carer one day I
was the equipment operator I I my whole
uh history is as an equipment operator
so not everybody had the same
qualifications uh but uh a few years
later there was a a job
uh that was actually on the other side
of the bridge and uh two or three of the
um of my friends actually went to
different unions uh for the same reason
I went to the to my
union uh they had that
opportunity followup yeah uh okay but uh
you mentioned that M you were able to
buy the house you were able to do a lot
of stuff and yet the other individuals
your friends didn't have that same
result uh that was uh the guys that
stayed doing that job um for the next
three or four years uh when they were
there they didn't have that opportunity
uh when they did go to uh the pile
drivers Union and the Carpenters Union
uh they very quickly uh were able to um
uh accomplish what I did in the same
same time
period
sorry if that wasn't
clear set representative thank
you question for you not
for okay that is uh we have no more
questions for you thank you very much
thank
you felon named Mark ataran got skipped
his hand rais didn't know if you saw
that he get skipped he didn't answer he
I was now informed by Christina that's
what I do on here Christina and I talk
uh Christina has for me he is there has
his hand up so we will call
markarian Mark atarian from o West oapi
New Hampshire hi can you hear me you
can well thank you Mr chairman um I was
in the shop working so I didn't hear my
name called so I apologize for that no
worries um and I want to thank the
members of the committee also my name is
m jeren I'm a proud citizen of the State
of New Hampshire and a member of the
United Brotherhood of centers local
349 I'm also the coordinator and Lead
instructor for our Manchester Training
Center I'm coming before the committee
today in opposition of Senate Bill
61 week after week myself and other
instructors train men and women in the
proper skills they need to be successful
in the construction IND
industry as always our focus is on
safety and
production I want our apprentices and
journey persons to go home safely and in
one
piece and I never nor I hope never does
anyone on the committee have to make
that life-changing phone
call we've seen the studies in states
where right to work law
exists these states have a
54% higher rate of job site
fatalities and that's according to the
BL
L I just want to say that again right to
work where right to work laws exists
there's a
54% higher rate of job site
fatalities as far as I'm concerned one
fatality is too
many so what's behind this increase in
workplace
fatalities as the economic policy
Institute notes right to work laws are
designed to hurt Union I and lower
wages unions give workers a voice in the
workplace allowing them to speak up
about hazards on the job without fear of
retaliation when right to work laws
weaken this system of checks and
balances workers May no May no longer
feel comfortable about speaking up about
safety the capy Union is focused on
workplace safety and
training when we're not able to provide
training through
apprenticeship workplace safety
suffers Michigan State University did a
study and it says for every
5% that Union
increases states can expect a 1%
decrease in depths on the
job the C is the C is Union Prides
itself on safety and so do I the
companies we work for know when they
need a safe dependable and quality
Workforce they call the copers
union I'd like to thank the committee
for this opportunity to speak on this
matter and hope you'll join me in saying
Senate Bill 61 is wrong for New
Hampshire thank
you thank you Mr terion you have any
questions for the presenter on
Zoom say none any in the
L none thank you very much for your
testimony thank
you the next up is Sarah canoy followed
by Richard lton and Mike Lynch Sarah
canoo from
Manchester
Richard
lton we do have Sarah canoy on the line
she just needs to
unmute thank
you Sarah are you with
us
Sarah we cannot hear
you could she be away from her
computer okay I can bring up the next
person and uh hopefully she'll come back
is Richard lton
available
Richard
lton there we go can you hear me now yes
we can thank you thank you very much for
taking my
testimony uh let me introduce myself my
name is Richard lton I'm from Durham New
Hampshire I'm here to speak against
Senate Bill
61 I would for those who are listening I
would like to say ditto to Mr falter who
spoke earlier I thought he had the best
testimony of the day but let me continue
on I'm I'm presently a business agent
teams's local 633 so I'm a union
official I'm not a union boss I don't
know where that terminology comes from I
I run for election every three years I
don't know many bosses I'll there that
have to run for election every three
years so um we get elected every three
years at teams's local
633 we represent 5,000 members here in
the state of New Hampshire New Hampshire
voted New Hampshire taxpayers people who
live here every day and work here every
day I was born in Dover went with
Douglas Hospital went to do schools got
married at St Mary's Church so we are
the voters here in New Hampshire who are
speaking to our Representatives my
wife's a small business owner who just
suffered through covid in Dober I spent
25 years driving concrete trucks I
poured concrete into the uh floor of the
first unit reactor at seab Brook station
I worked my whole life in the
construction industry now I'm lucky
enough to represent people I'm from here
as our our members we're not from
Virginia we're not from any place else
we're from New Hampshire I just want to
correct a couple of uh uh statements
earlier in the day um from Senator Regan
a couple of them was when when he first
when he first introduced his bill in the
Senate his words were exactly you will
not hear from any New Hampshire
businesses supporting this bill you will
not hear from any New Hampshire citizens
supporting this bill and that that Rings
true today I don't hear any New
Hampshire citizens who are voters who
put people in office who are rep who are
asking you boy could you please fix all
these wrongs here in New Hampshire with
the working system I can't wait to go to
Louisiana or Mississippi or or Arkansas
because they're right to workstat and
they've got such great wages and
benefits of course their wages have come
up they're at the bottom of the barrel
there's nothing broken here in New
Hampshire there is nothing wrong what's
going on here in the state of New
Hampshire so what are we looking why are
we trying to fix a problem that doesn't
even exist so I I truly believe that
it's from out of state influences who
gave tens of thousands of dollars
reportedly to some New Hampshire
Senators as reported by the union leader
uh Senator Regan this morning also said
you know he and I quote him again dues
going to pay politicians it's against
the law for dues to pay politicians it's
against the law we have political action
funds which people have spoken about
today not dues please re researchers
only a couple more points because
everything else has been covered we have
to represent people whether they pay
dues or not go to the National Labor
Relations Board website Google failure
to represent and see what that says we
have to by law represent people the nlrb
will have a charge filed with them for
failure to represent so we have to take
care of everybody whether they pay dues
or not we here at the local have both
public sector and private sector people
so we know both sides of the Janice
issue we also know both sides of right
to work when the last election came
through we realized this bill was going
to come up again like it does every two
years to fix a problem that does not
exist the problem in the state of New
Hampshire is the high cost of electrical
and the high cost of doing business here
it's got nothing to do with whether
we're right to work or not our employers
can't find members now can't find
employee as it employees as it is so I
won't uh continue on but again I just
want to reiterate if it's not broke what
are we trying to fix the right to work
states consistently come out at the
bottom of the barrel why would we ever
want to be anything like that so with
that I'd be glad to answer any questions
I can but thank you very much for um
taking my questions and my my testimony
I should say and I'll Stand ready for
any
questions thank you Mr lton any
questions the presenter
online
seeing none any here in the
lb seeing none thank you Mr Lon for your
testimony is Sarah canoy with
us not want to ask any questions
today Sarah
canoy Mike
Lynch Mike Lynch from Londonberry Mr
chairman can you hear me
again real quick for you Mr chairman I
wanted to clear up uh safety things that
have been brought up uh before I read my
statement being a part of an organized
uh labor force it actually gives for my
company gives us a seat at the table um
when it comes to safety we have safety
committees uh not all companies are
required to have these safety committees
where the employees are involved uh our
company it's actually negoti you within
our CBA that we are required to be at
the table with our company uh and it's
things like that that
um you please mute me thank you I
apologize for that Mike Mr Lynch there
was a someone else talking go ahead you
can resume uh no worries um I was just
stating that basically when it comes to
safety because you had asked multiple
times that uh this organized Labor uh
gives us a seat at the table especially
within my company uh gives us a seat
where we can uh fight for better PPE and
fight for better safety uh whereas if we
we were not a organized Union that might
not be the case so I just wanted to
quickly start off with that for you um
but ladies and gentlemen the committee
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to testify before you today in
opposition as s sp61 not only am I a
Union steward within usw local
12203 I'm a born and Brad New Hampshire
citizen that people who know me would
agree when it comes to things political
I try to steer as far as away as
possible s sp61 is a topic unfortunately
I couldn not ignore as it has the
potential to directly impact the way I
provide for my family I grew up in a
union household my mother was a a US
postal worker for 30 years my father a
union electrical engineer coming from a
union household As I Grew Older I was
anything but a full-blown Union
supporter I would jab at my dad about
the typical Union stereotype how many
Union guys does it take to change one
light bulb de this didn't change until I
starting my first job after
college this job was for a top financial
company based in New Hampshire for an
entry-level wage that even after seven
years with top end of the year reviews I
barely received $10,000 in salary
increases I decid at that point to make
a change that to this day was the best
decision I ever made for myself and my
family I accepted a job at Liberty
Utilities who I would like to add is on
record in opposition of this bill seven
years ago they explained to me up front
that i' be joining the US Steel Workers
Union and they explained what exactly
came along with working for that Union
our being a part of that Union I saw the
instant benefits the union would provide
me thanks to the years of negotiations
and sacrifices of my previous brothers
and sisters I've been able to buy a home
in the town I grew up in which in this
current housing market I would never be
able to afford with my previous
job thanks to the union my wage is more
than doubled my health care costs aren't
crippling and on my current path I'll be
able to retire
comfortably I've I've also seen our
Union save the jobs of many of my
brothers and sisters sisters whereas if
they had worked without union
representative representation they most
likely would have been terminated
instead theyve been given opportunities
to prove themselves in closing the state
of New Hampshire Prides itself on not
being like most other states it's why
unlike the state to our direct s our
Senators and representatives don't
receive tens of thousands of dollars as
salaries to represent the great people
of our state although the senator who Co
co-sponsored the bill thinks we may cry
babies and doesn't know doesn't think we
know what's good for us you have a
chance to show that we are above these
types of people and these Outsiders
these Outsiders that have now come 30
plus times trying to bring this bill to
our state that definitely does not
benefit the working citizens yet only
seeks to slowly bust unions from the
inside out I implore you to ask yourself
this one question who do you claim to
represent the interests of hardworking
men and women of New Hampshire that
vastly oppose this bill or the outside
interest and big corporations that say
they won't come here unless we become a
right to work state thank you very much
for your
time thank you m l your testimony there
any questions for the presenter on
Zoom any in the
L seeing none thank you very much thank
you I believe I saw next up uh Sarah
canoy
yes I'm here thank you welcome to labor
cre thank you thank you for the
opportunity to testify and thank you for
calling me again I'm sorry I missed it
the first
time um my name is Sarah Jane canoy I'm
testifying today as a private citizen I
am a resident of Manchester I've lived
in New Hampshire for 14 years I'm very
against
sb61 and my reasons are based in my
personal experience um for about 10
years when I was between high school and
college and just out of college I worked
in several different nursing homes uh
taking care of elderly people the first
two nursing homes I worked in were not
unionized the first one was an
absolute disaster the kind of place
you'd rather die than have your loved
parents or grandparent live in the
second one was a little bit better but
constantly struggled with problems of
lack of sufficient staff overwork of the
staff resulting in injuries of the staff
because it can be very hard on your back
to be uh helping people picking them up
and moving them around the third nursing
home that I worked at was unionized and
the difference between the unionized and
the non-unionized nursing home was
nursing homes was unbelievable not only
were the workers treated better and the
workers schedules um more appropriate
for care the care for the residents was
night and day so much better at the
unionized nursing home it was better
care because the workers made a decent
wage and didn't have to work two or
three jobs to support their families it
was better care because there were
always sufficient numbers of staff that
were working each shift and if someone
called in sick there was always someone
who came in to um fill in for that so we
were never short staffed um and this
nursing home won national awards because
the care that we provided there was so
good and we were all proud of our work
and proud to be a part of the
team after I'd been working there for a
few years well actually a few months I
realized that the difference was in
large part due to the union so later I
joined the union committee and got
active in the Union as a volunteer um
did some meetings and actually helped to
negotiate a contract uh for the union so
for this reason I'm completely against
the so-called
misnamed uh Right to Work bill as a
person who volunteered to devote time to
my union to make sure that my fellow
workers had better working conditions it
would have been completely unfair to the
Union to my work to my volunteers
to allow people to benefit from that
work without having to pay their fair
share I know you've heard from many
speakers today about how this is not a
new hampshire-based idea it's an idea
that's coming from a think tank outside
the state it's an idea that's been
defeated many times and I encourage you
to please defeat this very
ill-considered idea again thank you for
the opportunity to testify and thank you
all so much for your service to our
state and to our
communities thank you miss canoy any
questions for the presenter
online any in the
L Say Non thank you for your testimony
thank
you next up will be Peggy McCarthy
Richard metf Larry moin and William
Perry Peggy McCarthy with
us
[Music]
Peggy McCarthy Richard meta Larry
moochin William Perry hi I'm Peggy I'm
here hello Peggy welcome to the labor
thank you um good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Peggy McCarthy I am a former member of
New Hampshire house I am a
telecommunications professional I am
vice president of ibw local 20320 in
Manchester and like over a third of the
20,000 plus union workers in the granite
state I'm a republican I grew up in a
union household I'm the oldest of the
five Murphy kids and when I was 14 my
37-year-old father underwent one of the
first heart transplants in
Massachusetts unfortunately he passed
away a month later the surgery was
considered experimental at the time and
insurance didn't cover much of it his
Union ibw 2222 in Boston held
fundraisers for him and later for us to
help with expenses at his funeral there
was a procession of telephone Vehicles
all around the cemetery and the line at
his wake was out the door of dar's
funeral home and around the block I will
never forget it when I started with the
company myself and began attending Union
meetings my dad's former co-workers
would love to tell me about how smart he
was and what a great technician he was
and I love to hear them because I felt
like I got to know him as an adult
through their stories I I know you're
thinking cool story Peg what's your
point my point is this our Union is more
than our job and our paycheck it's our
family my story is real and it's
emotional but what it is not is rare
union membership is often
multigenerational we grow up in a union
household and then raise our children in
one so I hope that helps illustrate why
when this issue is pushed time and time
again when colorful mailers featuring
smiling models who look like they think
law is a yoga practice arrive in the
mail and when the public talking point
is freedom but behind the scenes it's
break the back of organized labor when
union members are denigrated
simultaneously as both Thugs and
crybabies it gets our attention and not
in a good way this is a highly emotional
issue and voting is a highly emotional
action it's insulting and infuriating
when our elected leaders simply refuse
to listen to us they try to tell us we
don't understand understand the issue
it's for our own good as though we are
instead of essential service
professionals And Trades people we're
children who need to be protected from
ourselves I've been in the room I've
heard the real story I understand the
true intent of this legislation
perfectly and so do my 20,000 voting
brothers and sisters it's disheartening
when our Representatives side with out
of-state lobbyists over their own
constituents and
neighbors the suits are going to get on
a plane the minute the vote is taken but
the folks wearing carheart will still be
here keeping you warm and safe plugged
in and connected we will always do our
jobs we're simply asking you to please
do yours by representing us and our
wishes it's really that simple thank you
very much for your
time thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for the presenter in
the Y um
[Music]
online saying none any in the lob
representative turot
you're recognized for a question thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Miss
McCarthy just one uh quick question um
if Right to Work were to pass in the
state would you resign your union
membership and stop paying news of
course I wouldn't because we provide
wonderful service to our membership
thank
you any further
questions thank you for your testimony I
appreciate that Richard metf has let
Christina know that he is unable to
testify so up next is Larry moin
followed by William
Perry and George Pratt answer the
question
that's Larry moin williiam Perry and
then George
Pratt I see Larry
moin's on yes we can hear you well thank
you for letting me speak um I'm gon to
uh use my time to submit testimony for
David and Nicole Garza who couldn't be
here who live in Raymond and our
business owners they submitted it but
wanted it on the
record um my name is David garzen I live
in Raymond New Hampshire I'm writing
this testimony on behalf of myself and
my wife Nicole Garza since 2015 we have
owned and operated Lupe 55 Cantina
located at the beach in Hampton we are
here today in opposition to s sp61
because this bill will
negatively affect our business we have
done our research in the difference in
quality of life between free bargaining
Estates and right to work
states and we have no idea why the
legislature thinks that this is a good
idea for New Hampshire why are we trying
to fix a problem that doesn't exist our
business is dependent upon people being
able to enjoy themselves and that
requires disposable
income research shows that medium
incomes are substantially Less in R tour
States and that alone should show the
legislature that New Hampshire doesn't
need or want this
legislation our state funds education
through property taxes the room and
meals tax are business pays helps fund
the rest of the state if incomes go down
in the room and Mills Revenue goes down
how are we going to keep the quality of
life Granite Staters have without
raising property taxes to equalize the
shortfall
finally who does right to work really
help from everything we've read it
really looks like legislation that will
only benefit large corporations that
don't need the help and hurt small
family-owned businesses like ours
neither of us are economists but with
the few hours we took to do the research
we found that this is a horrible piece
of legislation that will undoubtedly
hurt our business and many other small
businesses in this state please do the
research and find as b61 itl thank you
Nicole and David
Garza all right are there any questions
for Mr
moin I see none on
Zoom I see none in the L thank you very
much for your testimony Mr moin thank
you next up is William Perry followed by
George Pratt and James
scannel William
Perry hello Representatives uh thank you
for letting me testify here
today um I am a 25e member of ibw Local
Union 490 that is based here in Conan uh
we uh we represent uh the electricians
uh workers here in the state of New
Hampshire um I live in Londoner New
Hampshire I have a wife and three
children they have gone through the
school system uh and Londoner uh and
um it is a beautiful state to live in we
love this state and uh I remind my state
reps um whenever I possibly can that I
can't thank them enough uh for the job
that they do to represent this
state um I am not in favor of Right to
Work Senate Bill
61 and I ask you to
consider um what it could do to this
state um
by I think hurting unions across the
state and not just unions but companies
in general um I think that is bad for
this state uh it has failed several
times as you know on moving forward I
think that um you as Representatives
have a job to do and continue to vote
this down because it is bad for
Hampshire so thank you and uh I cannot
thank you enough for all that you do to
represent us here in New Hampshire thank
you thank you Mr Perry I'm sure you had
a lot of fun when the Chicago Bears were
uh on top of things I'm still called
Refrigerator Perry
today very well very well any questions
uh from uh uh members on
Zoom
I see Brian Sullivan are you speaking
with us Brian or representative Sullivan
did you have a question no um any on
here the L saying none thank you
Refrigerator Perry for your testimony
you're the best thank
you George Pratt James scannel and Mike
Smith it's Mr Pratt
available
Mr Pratt from Rochester don't see Mr
Pratt I just want to remind of folks who
are calling in on the telephone that to
raise your hand please press star n so
that we know that you were
there in the event that that's uh
someone on the phone but I don't see him
otherwise oh we see I do have someone
who raised their hand that was on the
phone two people well there's a lot of
George pratts
um that we missed prior up to you Mr
chair um you know
Christina I don't know uh just pick one
of the individual who we we do we think
one of those is uh Mr Pratt or Mr
scannel um I don't know I have no way of
knowing
um we can certainly ask and um see why
don't you just pick one and and have
them introduce themselves all right I
think Mr Pratt was on earlier and and
must have given
up all right so we have a caller ending
in 267 if you want to unmute that's star
six
hello yes go ahead sir
ince
yourself let me just try to get away
from this uh the feedback on the
computer can you hear me okay yes and
you are please yes uh my name is Edward
Foley uh I'm a retired sheet metal
worker uh Local 17 and I'm a past
business representative and also uh past
uh former president of the New Hampshire
State Building conr construction trade
Council I've been a Catholic for my
whole life and I'm 69 years
old I'm also a member of the kns of
Columbus as a Catholic I want to lift up
to the committee the social teachings of
the Catholic Church which not only have
influenced my life but are also the
reasons why this committee should oppose
Senate Bill 3 Senate Bill 61 the
so-called Right to Work act Catholic
School teaching beginning with Pope
Leo's and cyclical rayam Noam in
1891 call for the protection of the weak
and the poor affirm the Dignity of work
and there has been over 130 years of
unbroken tradition within the Catholic
Church supporting the rights of workers
to organize unions as essential for
economic Justice and the Dignity of the
human person in the
workplace the US Catholic Bishops and
their pastoral letter economic Justice
haral said that the Catholic Church
supports the rights of workers to form
unions or other associations to secure
workers rights to fear wages and working
conditions and teaches that no one may
deny the right to
organize unions without attacking human
dignity itself Pope St John Paul II in
his encyclical on human work states the
experience of History teaches the
organizations of this type unions are an
dispensable element of social life
especially in modern industrialized
societies he went on to say that modern
unions grew up from the struggle of
workers to protect their just rights and
that thanks to the work of their unions
workers will not only have more but
above all be more in other words that
they will realize their Humanity more
fully in every respect Pope Benedict the
16th and his encyclical kitas and
veritate uh which translates charity and
Truth concluded the repeated calls
within the church's social Doctrine
beginning with Ray novarum for the
promotion of workers associations that
can defend their rights must be honored
today even more than in the past Senate
Bill 61 does nothing to advance the
human dignity of working people or to
protect the rights of workers to
organize and maintain effective unions
it is meant to keep
unions weak in and effective all in the
nature of some economic benefit that
might Ur we know all too well that in
the states where it has been adopted
this legislation has led to lower wages
fewer benefits for working people such
as Employer Health Care pensions more
dangerous workplaces higher infant
mortality rates and higher poverty rates
Senate Bill 61 is called the right to
work act but is it is misnamed because
it doesn't create any new rights for
working people this law seeks to impede
work of solidarity and create divisions
in the workplace it sets the economic
interests of a single individual against
the common good of the group as a whole
Cardinal Blas kopich of the ash dases of
Chicago observed that history has shown
that a society with a healthy effective
and responsible labor movement is a
better place than one where powerful
economic interests have their way and
the voices and rights of work is
undiminished Senate Bill 61 does nothing
to enhance the Dignity of working people
and it sole purpose is to weaken unions
so necessary to the common good of New
Hampshire Working Families members of
the committee right to work is morally
wrong for New Hampshire I call on you to
vote this bill as itl and ought not pass
and Mr chairman I thank you for your
time uh uh and all the committee members
for your time I know it's a long day for
you but I'll answer any questions you
might have and uh it just seems I'm
retired and I'm still coming back here
to ask you folks to uh don't hurt the
workers in New Hampshire folks is Spill
down it doesn't do anything for us at
all God bless you all and I'll answer
any
questions thank you Mr Foley any
questions here in the lob from Mr
Foley any questions on
Zoom see none thank you very much thank
thank you sir announcement for committee
members the alarm system for the L is
being tested at 5:00 pm so uh if the
alarm go goes off at 5: PM don't be
startled it is a test we have
approximately 16 more individuals on the
list to speak uh I'm going to go back to
my list here if people were waiting and
before I hit another phone George Pratt
D James
scannel Mike Smith Stefan Gonzalez
Gonzalez George
Pratt Mr Pratt are you with us I don't
see Mr Pratt but I have brought on Mr
scannel Mr scannel if you're with us you
are um welcome to testify welcome to the
labor committee
Mr
scale you're
unmute still
onute Mr scand I don't know if you're
with us or you can hear us my screen
indicates you are on mute I don't know
if you walked away from your
computer
Mr
scan well I guess we're gonna have to
put him on hold here he may have walked
away from his
computer I don't see a picture but I do
see a that his computer is muted do we
have a Mike
Smith from Alton Bay New
Hampshire one of the more beautiful
places in New
Hampshire hello everybody hear me yes Mr
Smith welcome to the labor committee
well thank you very much for having me
uh hello and thank you to all the
committee members for their endurance
today uh it's been a long hearing for
all of us um and thank you for allowing
me to speak my name is Michael Smith I'm
a New Hampshire resident I live in
beautiful Alton Bay and you're correct
and we're finally we're going to be out
of mud season in a couple of weeks and
it's going to be great again but
uh business agent for iron work is local
7 I cover New Hampshire um that's my
paying job and that's my greatest source
of Pride I I joined local 7 20 years ago
and uh it's given me and my family a a
spot firmly in the middle class um that
my job uh but I also serve as the
president of New Hampshire Building
Trades currently and I sit on the New
Hampshire's aflcio executive Council as
well as sitting on the board of new sure
committee on occupational safety and
health so I have a lot of uh volunteer
experience and I and I will take on any
job that will help workers and my
members um today um you know I as a
union member I think all of you pretty
much well know where I stand on Senate
Bill 61 it's I am firmly against Senate
Bill 61 I think it would be a terrible
thing for New Hampshire to adopt this
legislation um instead of going into to
my testimony um I had a a company owner
reach out to me and tell me that he
wants to testify but he couldn't make it
today so I would like to read his
testimony into the record if I may yes
you may my the on Senate Bill 61 Right
to Work testimony of Mark ganard
presidentowner of New Hampshire Steel
Fabricators LLC and New Hampshire
LLC good morning my name is Mar and I I
am the founder owner and president of
New Hampshire Steel Fabricators and New
Hampshire Steel Erectors both of which
operator out of GS toown New Hampshire I
want to thank this house committee for
allowing me to speak about Senate Bill
61 New Hampshire steel has been a very
successful construction subcontractor
for over 40 years so I would like to
address this bill from the perspective
of of an employer between the two of
them my company's employee over 100
people at our facility in gtown and on
nearly two dozen active construction job
sites around New England proudly
including my employees um included among
my employees are over 50 Union ion
workers out of local 7 very early on in
the life of my company back in the 20th
century I realized that if my steel
fabrication operation was going to be
successful grow and continue to thrive
into the future I needed to improve the
the service end of it because that's
what general contractors demanded I knew
immediately that I would need the help
of iron workers the Iron Workers Union
to provide the kind of trained and
reliable Workforce that would bring
success that's when I established New
Hampshire steel directors as a union
Ting company I made that decision freely
and of my own accord clearly it was one
of the best decisions I ever made for my
company and its employees but I want to
reiterate the important thing is that I
made the decision as my own choice I
believe this bill would interfere with
my right as an employer or any other
employer's rights to choose how to run
his or her business and how I negotiate
with my Workforce I made my decision
based on my knowledge that when I use
Union Union iron workers I am putting
well-trained safety-minded professionals
on my job sites who will do the job well
the first time that makes my customers
happy allowing me to secure more work
and protect my body botom line allowing
me to grow the company and hire more
people I do not believe allowing
government into the middle of my
negotiations with workers which is what
this bill does will do anything to boost
employment or grow the economy right to
work will force me to change the way I
negotiate with my workers because the
government decided it can set terms
better than I can for my own projects I
know I made the right choice when I
chose to work with the Union the proof
is in the pudding New Hampshire steel is
one of the largest strongest most
well-respected miscellaneous metal
subcontractors in New England we have
seen consistent growth through our
Inception since our Inception and have
weathered three deep recessions and a
pandemic thriving when many of our
competitors went under I can honestly
say that signing a Union contract was a
major part of that success if this
so-called right to work law had been in
effect all this time I cannot say we
would have done as well as we have I
will let others testify as to how right
to work laws depress wages stifle growth
and slow Economic Opportunity in closing
I'm here to say that as an employer I
don't want the government getting into
my business and in interfering with my
ability to hire quality employees that
help my business grow that should be my
right to be a union operation or not
just as it's the op the employees right
to work at a union shop or not it's just
not fair that an employee for an
employee to enjoy the benefit benefits
of a negotiated Union contract without
paying paying their fair share of what
it took to secure those benefits this
bill is a bad idea it it's not good
policy please reject Senate Bill 61 and
don't interfere with my right to choose
how to run my business thank
you thank you Mr Smith have any
questions for the presenter on
Zoom any questions here in the
l s thank you very Mr Smith for your
testimony thank you I'm just going to
read off the names of the individuals
because people starting to email me and
text me am I on the list am I on the
list um the individuals that have not
been called on so far are I thought it
was Stefan Gonzalez I read it backward
it's Gonzalez
Stefan uh Dan
Brogan
Alfred
Jahara David
D delola mark Hansel hope Hutson Emanuel
Kramer Dan L clerk williiam
lbrand
Lance magello or mazarello excuse me
Mike McCarthy George Pratt and Dan
Bogden those are individuals I have left
I'll look again after I call the next
few people to make sure I haven't missed
anyone representative do you have a
question no okay so
um again the way it is written
that your first name is Gonzalez and
last name is Stefan S D A A N from Salem
are you with
us hello yes I am um can you hear me yes
we can thank you welcome to the labor
committee Mr chairman members of the
committee um my name is stefen gonzalas
I am a father of three and a 20-year
resident of Salem New Hampshire and a
proud member of the usw
120204 in the past 20 years I have seen
much change in my town and most of it if
not all for the better even during a
pandemic our businesses growth is
through the roof home values at the
highest
ever why I ask would we let a
misleadingly named Bill to be passed in
our state right to work is wrong for New
Hampshire
ask yourselves where is this push coming
from when I was at the farmers market
this weekend spending my money in my
local businesses do you think I saw
anyone from Virginia there I don't think
so I see men and women of New Hampshire
working men and women spending their
money supporting our businesses and
that's what we want to keep we want to
keep supporting our businesses let's
keep the Deep
pocketed people out of our
state this is coming from a special
interest deep pocketed group this bill
just the bill was just voted down in
Montana and I ask you to join Montana
and vote down s sp61 let's keep our
state growing and moving forward without
so-called Right to Work Live Free or
Die let's not make another another state
or another area of our country vote for
us I ask you to vote no and I appreciate
your
time thank you for your testimony there
any questions of the presenter on
Zoom any questions in the
L seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony thank you have a great
day thank you next up is Dan Bogden
followed by Alfred
jar
Jara and
David delis
Sola Mr Bogden are you with
us Daniel Bogden from
maram Alfredo
Jahara
oh
Jes Mr Bogden hello yeah hello Mr Bogden
welcome to the labor committee hey good
I'm glad to get through thank you very
much um just let you know I talk to
several St WS over the course of
time sir we can't hear you very
well all keep fading In and
Out Mr
Brogden one
[Music]
second can you hear me
now yes we can okay um basically there I
asked about 20 Representatives if they
were for or against uh the right to work
and most of them said they were for it
and I said okay what are your reasons
and two reasons they basically gave me
was being forced to join a union and
being forced to pay dues so with that
said I give you my history uh back in 84
I worked for a heating company and I was
making a good wage I thought everything
was going good friend of mine hit me up
and said hey Union's looking for a guy
would you like to come over so I checked
out and said where you offered basically
in a nutshell my wages were going to go
from $7 an hour back at 84 to 12 my
insurance for health was going to go to
something called a JY plan which was the
Cadillac of everything back then I was
going to get uh a dental plan I was
going to get a pension I was going to
get a couple of extra paid holidays five
sick days in an extra week after 10
years it was like it was an no-brainer
it was only going to cost me about one
and a half% in Union dues so just to
raise a loan was going to cover that so
I jumped nobody forced me and I went in
there with both eyes wide open I am a
registered Republican have been for
years I didn't know there so many of us
out there also been a union officer and
a union employee for about 36
years the other thing is dues okay
everybody talks about having to pay the
dues not having to pay the dues
there are many places Boy Scouts Girl
Scouts Kanas clubs the Nights of
Columbus hobby clubs uh sporting clubs
and country clubs they all Childs does
is to run the organization or to do
charitable events imagine walking up
into the Manchester Country Club after
so many years and say hey I don't feel
like paying du anymore I'm done and I
still join and enjoy the the amenities
that go with it I don't think you'll
stay there that long
another thing about this thing is safety
I go to a lot of construction sites over
the years one construction side I won't
mention in town in Manchester that it
happened they had spotters and what
these guys did was they kept an eye out
for the oosha guys and the safety guys
while they put a guy down in the trench
about 15 feet below the surface to take
measurements Etc and when somebody came
up they yelled Don get out of the hole
because they didn't want to put Shoring
up Etc so I find that Union shops are
far safer than non-union shops not all
but the ones I see pick right
out and the other thing is I look at
people and I they talk about unions
donating money to one party or another
you got to ask yourself would you rather
have $200 in a donation or 200 votes I
didn't realize how many Republicans were
Union supporters at the same time I
thought it was just a a few of us but it
seems to be quite a bit in closing the
devil's in the details the simple Right
to Work bill would be a couple of
sentences here it is this is what you
have this is what we want this is what
you do it isn't until a bill has passed
it's been in the process for a while
that you realize the other ramifications
along with it and this is what I worry
about is down the road what happens you
watch a restaurant show they do
something they change the restaurant
around they go back a year later they
look at it okay and they see you know if
the guy followed it if things are going
good and if it doesn't when we pass
bills throughout the country the town
everything else nobody really looks at
what the ramifications are of that bill
years down the road you get bits and
pieces of it but it's like anything else
there's thousands of laws and bills out
there and they all go away you know so
with this thing here it seems like
nobody wants it that wants to you it's a
good worker nobody's forced to join a
union my Union's only seen two guys
leave over the course of the 35 years
and they both for personal reasons you
know they basically moved out of state
so everybody stays so going forward I'm
against the bill and I hope the rest of
you are you know take a long hard look
at the people out here that do work it's
not going to do any benefit to anybody
thank you for your time I appreciate
it thank you you Mr Bogden are there any
questions for the presenter on
Zoom seeing none any here in the
L have no questions for you sir thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you next up is
Alfred
Chiara and then
David
delola our either is Mr
Tara
on the
line Alfredo from Pennsylvania
Philadelphia
Pennsylvania all right David Delisa from
Dairy New
Hampshire
David can you hear me yes give feedback
[Music]
you see on
twice Christina hear
now yes yes we can you're welcome to the
labor
committee I want to thank the labor
committee for hearing my voice today my
name is Dave doas Sola my wife and I
reside in Derry for the last 15
years I am a proud member of the usw gas
workers and I oppose
sb61 our local represents the national
of gas workers at Liberty Utilities
unitel utilities and Aero gas in New
Hampshire as well as the National Grid
gas workers in L asbery and malder Ms I
am very pleased and proud of the
contracts that have been agreed upon
between our gas workers and all of the
companies that we work for those
Agreements are made up of a number of
proposals that our workers have debated
and agreed upon prior to bargaining with
our
companies those agreements between our
gas workers and our companies can
include a number of proposals whether it
be seniority language safety language
training
programs as well as many other proposals
up to and including joining a union as a
condition of employment
our group of
workers could have decided to be an open
shop where the workers can choose not to
join a union and not be covered under
any collective bargaining agreement our
group of workers decided that having a
union shop and working under the same
collectively BG and agreement is what
works best for us and our families our
workers as a group have decided that for
our local to have the most leverage to
collectively bargain everybody should be
part of the group and all operate under
the same agreement that's what we came
up with and we
decided as a group and that's what our
companies agree to state of thean should
not be getting involved in an agreement
between a group of workers and the
companies that they collectively bargain
with this right to work law would
effectively make those collectively
bargain agreements n in void just a few
of the questions that will come up is
what will happen to those negotiated
contra contct s how is this new law
going to be enforced who is going to
enforce this new
law are the taxpayers of enhance you
going to have to pay the fees associated
with the compliance of this totally
unnecessary law the law that this body
is entertaining will let a worker that
is covered under our agreement refuse to
contribute his or her fair share of dues
that are agreed upon by the workers in
the company that said worker would still
be covered under the same contract
contract as all the other workers has
anyone on this committee actually had a
constituent come up to them and say you
know what I don't think I want to pay my
dues but I want to keep my good pay and
all the benefits I also want the union
to bargain for me and represent me if
need be but I don't want to contribute
my fair share like everybody else does
why would this bill even be entertained
that would be like entertaining A bill
that gives employees the right to refuse
to pay health insurance premiums but
still be covered under the said policy
State of New Hampshire would certainly
not entertain a bill like
that I hear the argument that a member
shouldn't have to contribute if he or
she doesn't like the union
leadership the truth is your local union
leaderships made up of the co-workers
within your group our locals have a
simple Democratic solution to a poor
leadership issue you vote them out or
better yet you run for the leadership
position yourself if you feel that you
can do a better job you don't take your
ball and go home I.E I'm not paying my
fair share your union belongs to you and
your co-workers if there are issues
which there are in every local you work
them out the Democratic way you come up
with a compromise on the issues within
your group and or you put them to a vote
as I stated earlier your group can
decide not to be a union shop
not your group can decide to be an open
shot where joining the union is
voluntary
your group can decide to unite as one
voice and be a union shop that decision
should be totally up to the employees
and the employer again the state of New
Hampshire or the tax Bayes of New
Hampshire should not get involved in the
everyday Mutual decisions between a
private group of workers and a private
corporation that is simply not part of
the New Hampshire's modotto Live Free or
Die Another argument I hear is a new
worker should not have to join a union
company if they don't want to well they
don't the truth is there are many more
opportunities out there to work for a
non-un company than there are for Union
companies 90% of workers in New
Hampshire do not belong to a union as we
speak again 90% of workers in New
Hampshire do not currently belong to a
union so to say that a new worker does
not have the choice to work a job that
is non-un is very misleading in all
outfalls I know in my industry alone
there are numerous utility companies out
there that are not affiliated with any
unions and they do the exact same work
as my utility company
does most of these union jobs pay less
in the union jobs but they're still good
paying jobs because they have to compete
with the Union companies to attract good
workers doesn't take a rocket scientist
to figure out that passing right to work
will eventually lower the wages of union
workers which in turn will lower the pay
of all New Hampshire workers right to
work laws are
anti Union laws so as they weaken New
Hampshire unions they will also weaken
all the New Hampshire workers because
non-union companies will not have to
compete with union wages and benefits
anymore weakening unions in New
Hampshire will also make it harder for
New Hampshire companies to keep the
skilled workers in our state because the
skilled worker would just drive the 20
miles down to Massachusetts to seek
employment massachusett attracts
companies from all over the world partly
because the competitive wages and the
benefits set by strong unions they
attract the skilled workers to fill
those positions that are desperately
needed by these companies right to work
will do nothing for New Hampshire
workers but send our skilled Workforce
Force elsewhere to search for good jobs
there are many other forms of legisl
that can be passed to help the workers
of the hampsh if that's what we want to
do here the almost criminal
$725 minimum wage can be increase for
instance employee at will um laws the
paid medical leave laws law could be
more worker friendly these are some of
the issues that we we should be
discussing not not anti-worker union
busting bills I also want to take to
touch on another argument that union
dues are to support politicians I used
to support politicians that is not true
set the record straight federal law
restricts any using any Union from using
their union dues to engage in political
lobbying activities all pack
contributions are voluntary and do not
come out of union dues in order for a
union member to contribute to a pack
they need to voluntarily contribute from
their own personal bank account use of
local union dues for any reason or any
type of endorsement for a political
candidate are discussed and debated by
the union body and then they go through
a motion procedure at a monthly union
meeting it has to be passed by the
members having said that it certainly
makes no sense for any Union member to
endorse a politic ician that supports
right to work laws or any other
anti-worker law and lastly for those of
you that argue Right to Work do not
weaken a union are just playing
wrong sometimes it takes a little time
to infect the body so it doesn't happen
overnight but none of us should be naive
enough to to think that there aren't
some companies out there that would love
to exploit this union busting bill for
example your union could be very small
you could have a group of say 10 workers
and I want to stress that point you
don't need hundreds of thousands of
workers to form a union you don't have
to be in part of an international to be
a union a union could be five workers
could be two workers could be three
workers so those 10 workers can agree to
contribute Union duels and secure funds
for a number of different reasons
whether it be simple expenses like being
able to donate to a local charity
purchase t-shirts Union buttons um get
in the local Fourth of July parade they
could use those funds to set up training
facilities or safety classes or it can
be more serious issues like having to
hire a labor lawyer to representing
member in arbitration against the
company if a company decides that it
doesn't want David could you please wrap
up your Tes y f up if a company decides
it doesn't want to play fair anymore and
sees that TR those funds will weaken the
effectiveness of those workers it can
simply St to hire workers that they know
will not pay Union duals whether it be a
CEO's brother or cousin or what have you
if they can hire employees that they
know will abuse this right to work law
they will eventually weaken the Union's
Kitty to a point where it becomes
ineffective that union busting 101 this
example of union busting is hypothetical
but it could easily take place and most
certainly probably has in right to work
states here in New Hampshire what is not
hypothetical is the fact that right to
work already has weakened our unions in
this state without s sp61 even being
passed yet I say that because there's
all there's usually hundreds of
thousands of more union
workers voicing their opinion on this
but Janice took them already out of it
firefighters police teachers and public
union members have been taken out of the
mix by Janice decision so saying that
these laws have not affected unions
already is not true and this and if this
body passes right to work in the private
SEC you silence the voice of the rest of
us thank you for your time and your
patience and please vote no on
sb61 thank you for your testimony do you
have any questions uh for the presenter
from Representatives on
Zoom have any questions here in the lb
uh Vice chairman Mr seaworth thank you
Mr chairman um thank you for your
testimony during the early part of your
testimony you talked about how the
employees
democratically um decide what the
conditions of their contract will be and
decide who their leadership will be my
question is do members of the barting
unit who pay agency fees did they get to
vote Yes in my local is do we have
meetings we have surveys to what um the
most important ISS shes are and I have
never once heard anything about not
having to pay dues in my 30 years of
being a union member but no we we have
monthly meetings we have um Everybody
votes for we have voting every three
years with different um leadership so if
there's any issue that you want to bring
up to the board you can bring it up and
you can get enough support just like we
do for everything else in this country
you get enough support one way or the
other and you Vote or or you know you
make your point heard you you you can do
whatever you want the international
doesn't get involved with anything that
we do it's all about the workers in our
group and like I said it could be five
years
thanks any other
questions representative turot thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question uh you mentioned in your
testimony that there are businesses in
New Hampshire who want to eliminate
Union or bu UNS do can you give me a
couple of examples of those
companies I don't believe I said
that thank
you all right any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you up
next Mark Hil followed by hope
Hutchinson and Margaret
Fogerty mark Council hope Hutchinson and
Margaret fery is Mark council with us Mr
chairman yes um I just wanted to make
note that there are six people in the uh
uh participant box with their hands up
I'm not sure if they're on your list or
not but I uh understand that some of
them have been texting committee members
trying to get our
attention you know I don't know what to
do representative Sullivan we had 85
people sign up the last time I let
someone who called in they hadn't even
been they were on the list I hadn't
called them yet I feel that if I'm
letting people call in first they're
going ahead of the people that signed up
so I'm trying to do the signups first
and every single person who calls in
will be allowed to come in I have been
getting emails and I'm trying to add
people as as best I can um so thank you
but understood understood just wanted to
bring it to your attention thank you
thank you uh is there a mark councel
with us
I do not see Mark council is there hope
Hutchinson o Pinson from
pitfield I do not see hope
Hutchinson do we have I know marget
Margaret FY you emailed me uh she may be
under New Hampshire peace action
I believe she is yes I'm here thank you
I I wish I could control how I showed up
in Zoom but that this is Margaret
Fogerty Maggie Fogerty with the American
friend service committee thank you so
much for uh giving me a chance to
speak uh Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm here today as a person of
faith and as a union member to express
my strong opposition to
sb61 I am a Quaker I work for a Quaker
founded organization the afsc and I am a
member of Unite Here Local 66l and the
Unite Here New England joint board um so
both as a union member and with the
encouragement of my employer I res I
urge your rejection of
sb61 in our 104 years of existence as an
organiz ation afsc has been joining
workers in their fight for safety for
dignity uh and for an opportunity to
thrive starting back in 1922 when we
were providing assistance to unemployed
coal miners in West Virginia and
Pennsylvania in 1936 after President
Roosevelt signed the National Labor
Relations Act afsc issued a statement
that included this statement
collective bargaining by groups of
workers with employers is desirable in
order that workers may meet Management
on something like equal terms when they
bargain for rates of pay conditions of
work and security of employment and
since then throughout the country and
actually throughout the world we have
stood with people who are seeking
employment living wages and dignity on
the
job and within New Hampshire the ability
of working people to attain a decent
standard of living is under threat
according to the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority the Statewide median
rent of a two-bedroom apartment in New
Hampshire was
$1,413 a month in 2020 which was a
nearly 5% increase from the previous
year so that means it takes an income of
more than
$56,500 a year to afford a typical
apartment that's 3.8 times what a worker
makes at the current federal minimum
wage and 1.8 times what a worker earning
$15 an hour even would be able to
afford if the purpose of s sp61 were to
provide jobs at decent wages we would be
heartily in favor of it but right to
work is not about ensuring that people
have the right to a decent job it's
about undermining the ability of working
people to organize among themselves and
bargain
collectively by making it more difficult
for workers to organize Right to Work
forces down the wage levels of working
people in New Hampshire and the ability
to afford health care would be
threatened as well the ability to pay
taxes to support schools would be
diminished our housing crisis will
intensify more people will need public
assistance in the written testimony that
I'll submit to the committee I cite a
report by the economic policy Institute
that talks about the impact on low-wage
unun workers during covid-19 who have
been at considerable risk without
adequate Pro protective gear paid sick
leave and no protections for speaking up
so this pandemic makes even more clear
uh the benefit that our unions bring to
the safety of our workplace so please
listen to all of the workers who have
spoken up today New Hampshire workers
and recommend this bill be inexpedient
to legislate thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there any
questions on
Zoom seeing none any questions in the
lb seeing No Hands thank you once again
for your
testimony um next up I'm gonna ask for
Emmanuel krasner followed by Dan clerk
followed by William lron
is Emanuel Kesner
available he is there he's got his hands
up good afternoon can you hear me yes we
can go ahead please thank you very much
uh I know you have heard a lot of
testimony today I uh I admire your
fortitude I will try to keep my
testimony brief and make three
points one uh I am opposed to
sb61 it is is a remarkable piece of
government
overreach uh I imagine that most of the
people supporting it view themselves as
Believers in small government and so I
ask if you believe in small government
why do you want to stick the
government's hand in here I have run my
own small business in New Hampshire a
law office for the last 40 years I have
not needed the assistance of the State
of New Hampshire to tell me whether I
can for uh support my employees in
forming a union or oppose their forming
a union that's between me and them it is
not a matter for the state to try to
dictate to me how I will deal with my
own
employees and I believe that any
believer in small government would
support this position I know that one of
the uh representatives of one of the
national groups supporting the bill said
you well there's already plenty of
Regulation from the federal level and
other levels well first of all I'm not
sure that the Fe the Federal Regulation
pushes you one way or the other it just
opens things up but beyond that
logically even if you think okay there's
already a lot of Regulation why put more
in why add another layer and constrain
someone like myself in how he wants to
deal with his
employees my second point is
that I've testified against this bill
before uh I uh am not a union member but
for many years I have been general
counsel to the American Federation of
teachers but the first time I testified
against this bill was probably 25 years
ago I was not anything other than a
young attorney build up his business and
the lady ahead of me who was testifying
against the
bill was someone I wanted to thank
because she was very honest she said I'm
testifying against this bill because I
don't like unions and I think this bill
will undermine
unions and she was absolutely right and
forthright that's what this bill is
about it is an anti-union
bill you will hear that oh no we are
just trying to protect each individual
worker I ask you logically do you
seriously think that the people
funding
the national Right to Work committee and
the other right to work committees or
even Americans for Prosperity you think
they are interested in in individual
workers here in New Hampshire if you
believe that if any member of the
committee believes that uh I have two
lots in Rio Rancho Estates just sou
outside of Albuquerque New Mexico I will
happily sell
you uh so no this is an anti-union bill
that's what it's about it's designed to
undermine the unions it's designed to
break up the essential solidarity that
any Union needs to function
effectively it's essentially if you're
in the union if the Union representing
your bargaining unit we're all in this
together but if you start making those
kind of Divisions that this bill would
re virtually require
then uh you have definitely undermined
the union and you've done so through
government action which is exactly what
Believers in small government should not
do finally
uh it just in terms of unions themselves
you know if if there's no
Union the boss is one of the world's
last absolute monarchs I practice in a
small town
Farmington and I've had people over the
last 40 years come into me and say I was
just fired from my job and it was most
unfair and they described the situation
to me and I listened to them and at the
end of the conversation I say I hear you
it was unfair it was unreasonable and it
was even even foolish on the part of
your boss do you have a
union and they say no and I say I'm
sorry there's nothing I can do because
your boss can walk into the office can
walk onto the shop floor and if there's
no union he can say it's Tuesday and I
want to fire
you so that's one of the reasons I think
unions are a good thing in addition to
all the other things you've heard
today and this bill is designed its sole
purpose in life is to undercut unions to
make that breach in the Dyke that may
lead to further things it is an
unwarranted government intrusion into
the relationship between employers and
employees and I ask you to vote that it
is inexpedient to legislate thank you
very much thank you for your testimony
are there any questions for the speaker
inside the open seeing none any
questions online
you mean no one wants the Lots in Rio
Rancho I don't I didn't see any interest
in those lots either sorry thank you
anyhow thank you have a great
afternoon um speaking next we'll ask for
Dan L clerk after that William lron and
after that Lance
mazero and I probably killed all three
of those names and I
apologize is Dan with
cler
available I don't see anyone with that
name um he if he is on the phone I would
ask that he press star nine to raise his
hand May
well all right who is the next person
the next one is William and here we go
another French uh is it William lbrand
or William
lron oh uh Bill LR there we
go can you hear
me excellent hello okay hi good
afternoon Mr chairman and members of the
House La industrial reability committee
thank you for hearing my testimony today
my name is William lren son brother
husband father business representative
for the payers and Alli trade and
Resident taxpayer of straford the
Hampshire I strongly request you all
oppose this rather ingeniously named
legislation called right to work Senate
Bill 61 this bill does not create any
rights or any work the average wages in
right to work states are 10,000 year
less than a we B States the workforce
fertility
fatalities are 49% higher in rate to
work states New Hampshire does not need
to be included uded in those
statistics the number of union members
in the Hampshire is 10.3% only 69,000
according to us Bureau of Labor
Statistics which some of them are
members of the pan and Airi trades and
many are registered
Republicans I am asked directly by them
why are New Hampshire legislators
attacking workers right to bargain here
in New Hampshire where we already have
such an increasingly low opportunity to
work in the construction field for a
fair living wage which include Health
and Welfare benefits we are led to
believe out State influence from the
national Right to Work committee located
in Springfield Virginia in their very
generous $100,000 contribution to 10 C
and state senators is a reason for this
legislation as a voter I hope not
because dollars don't vote constituents
do government interference between
employers and employees are not
conservative values imposing burdens to
employers on jobsite postings fines and
imprisonment language legislators
seeking to imprison employers but wish
to make their own business decisions and
divide workers in the Hampshire are not
properly representing their business
owners or
constituents sb61 is misleading has
nothing to do with freedom or protecting
us from paying dues if that was true
then why would we Overlook dues assess
to be a member of the Chamber of
Commerce which have six levels of dues
starting at 575 to two
$2,50 annually and why not then include
the bu association fee golf cost
membership the list goes on but makes no
sense to go after any of them including
the unions my union located in brenwood
New Hampshire has a 4 half million doll
training facility our local dues are $42
a
month as a vure of New Hampshire I I ask
you to refrain from following outside
instructions on how our great state of
New Hampshire should live or work please
oppose Senate Bill 61 thank you for your
time and commitment to this great
state and thank you for your testimony
are there any questions on Zoom for this
speaker I don't see any hands anyone
in seeing none thanks once again for
your testimony thank you up next we have
Lance
mazero followed by Mike McCarthy
followed by Pat
Moran I see there we go hey folks can
you hear me you can well thank you Mr
chairman thank you committee for hearing
me out my name is Lance masello I'm the
president and one of the owners of
Finnish installations of New England a
New Hampshire union carpentry
company um I'm also a New Hampshire
homeowner uh resident of Derry New
Hampshire
um I I I heard I listened to
90% of today and I had something
prepared but I feel like everything that
could be said has been said here I just
I want to add some personal anecdotes
about being a union member being a Union
business owner the strength of my
company
is the union Workforce the ability to
Source highly skilled qualified
professionals to rise up and meet any
challenge that we encounter um we we are
engaged in projects throughout New
England including uh all over New
Hampshire we are building amazing things
transforming this entire region but the
the most incredible thing that we've
built is the lives of the people that
work for us and they've done it by
having I being able to negotiate for a
great wage excellent benefits which I'll
speak to more in depth in a moment um
and with the goal of achieving a
dignified retirement we we have come
through one of the tumult most tumultous
times in political history in the United
States um being a student of History
having uh been a part of the a part of
this this process the last few years
being in the union and being politically
active
um supporting candidates we believed in
uh we've seen we've seen so much but no
matter what comes up in the uh in the
political Spectrum there's a few few
items that eventually make it into the
narrative it's it's Health Care um it's
uh minimum wage uh it's it's benefits
it's all about they're they're all
components of the American dream you
know I heard so many numbers today I
heard uh statistics about mortality
rates on job sites and uh wage rates and
you know I think about numbers a lot too
I think about I so many numbers but one
of the numbers I keep in the back of my
head all the time is the number of
people that work for me who bought
houses uh in in a time when you know
we've we've spoken over the last decade
about how many people have been unable
to do that um how many of the men and
women that work for me have seen their
income above the $100,000 Mark uh how
many have had children how many have
been able to get married buy vehicles
how many have um have really built solid
lives through this this Union process
you know and it this collective
bargaining and this ability to uh
negotiate and I'm and I'm on I'm still a
card carrying Union member but I'm on
the other side of the fence because I am
employing these
people
um I'm also uh I'm a father of two young
girls uh in Derry and um when my second
daughter was three mon months old she
suffered a stroke and uh I there's a lot
of ways that that event could have went
for our family I'm thankful to say she's
healthy and she's active and she's a
wonderful little girl right now at three
years old going on four hopefully going
on 100 um but when I think about the
ways that that event could have changed
my life you know one of the ways
unfortunately in this country is
financial Rune she required over a 100
days of hospital stays multiple
MRIs uh testing of every facet every
every amount everything you could
imagine and I'm happy to say that you
know union benefits saved me that that
is and that is something that we bargain
for uh that is something I believe in
I I don't want to take up too much more
of your time I just want to tell you you
know from the business side of this
we're a stronger company because the men
and women are able to bargain because
the union is able to provide exceptional
training and the best-in-class workforce
possible um our clients are happy with
us I we're happy with our people and our
people are enjoying a wonderful life
because of it so thank you very much for
your time I am in strong opposition to
this bill it is wrong for America it is
certainly wrong for New Hampshire live
free and die or
die thank you thank you for your
testimony any questions members of the
committee on
Zoom questions for anyone
L see none thank you very much getting
down to the last couple I have a Mike
McCarthy we talked to a Peggy McCarthy
before Mike McCarthy's also from na Hamp
they do have different email addresses
is there a Michael McCarthy from
Nashville with us that's me Mr
chairman now originally it was going to
be good morning but we'll go with good
afternoon Mr chair chairman and members
of the committee my name is Michael
McCarthy I'm a 27e member of the
Republican Party 22-year member of the
International Brotherhood of Electrical
Workers and have served four terms in
the New Hampshire House of
Representatives my last term I was on
the labor committee so hello to anybody
I served with s sp61 like other Right to
Work legislation has been a perennial
issue in New Hampshire for decades time
and again the issue has been brought
forward and been rejected and during
most of this time there have been
Republican government Governors and
Republican majorities in the House and
Senate as a union member I oppose s sp61
because I believe it to be detrimental
to organized labor much the same way
people in the restaurant industry would
reject right to eat legislation that
required them to feed people who are not
paying
customers as a republican I reject SP
sp61 as unwanted legislative
intervention in Private
Industry the 2018 US Supreme Court Jan's
decision has already imposed Right to
Work language on public sector unions
bills like s sp61 would only be
impacting private
businesses normally Republicans would
say this is literally not our
business as a republican I also oppose
Right to Work legislation because I
believe there is no grounds full of
support for it in New Hampshire when the
issue was brought forward in 2010 and
2016 hundreds of people attended the
hearings in vocal opposition with very
relatively few people voicing support to
our detriment we ignored this leaving
the voters their only other option to or
displeasure and that was at The Ballot
Box in 2012 and 2018 there was a
reversal of Fortune for the majority
party we need not see a repeat of this
in
2022 at this point I'm going to depart
from my prepared statement to address a
question that's come up repeatedly
during testimony and that is if Right to
Work passes would you stop paying union
dues or do you believe members of your
union would stop paying union dues now
consistently the answer has been no now
the reason for this is because these
people like myself self when they went
looking for employment we took jobs
because of Union involvement not in
spite of them these were our decisions
freely chosen that was our freedom we
did that our concerns for our Union are
with new hires going forward when Right
to Work were to pass at this point left
people potentially taking jobs that
they've all along known about the
benefits of being in a union but they
never took a union job because they
didn't want to pay for the benefits now
these people as far as I'm concerned
it's not about Freedom it's about free
they want something for nothing and over
time that will bleed unions I don't
think that's an unintended consequence I
don't think it's an oversight I think
it's the intention of Right to Work
legislation now if what was being
discussed here today was absolving
people of their obligations to pay condo
association fees or homeowners
association dues be the same thing we as
Republicans always argue against
entitlement societies because we say
eventually there'll be more people in
the cart than pulling then the economy
crumbles Society fails same for unions
same for condo associations same for
anything where people get something
without paying for it it will eventually
fail now so it's not to go on too long
and I'm sure some of you were thinking
too late you already have in conclusion
if I know that s sp61 faces tremendous
opposition from the people that claims
to help and if I know the legislative
intervention in private business
is something that is not favored in New
Hampshire and finally if I know that
many perennial bills are said to have
had their day and right to work had
decades and should have been set aside
long ago but I now move as61 in
expedient to legislate thank you for
your
time thank you very
much honorable Michael McCarthy for your
testimony are there any questions
online see none we have one in L
represent
thank you Mr chairman and uh still
there yes Mr
McCarthy uh yes I'm here thank you you
disappeared for a second um I'm a
Democrat probably going to disagree on
most stuff um but I appreciate your
testimony today um we've heard from some
folks today who like yourself are into
right to work that one of the common
criticisms that they hear of unions is
that they overwhelmingly Z Democrats um
politically and we heard testimony today
that's gone against that but in that
hypothetical um do you think that
elected Republican officials might enjoy
more support from Rank and final union
members if those elected officials stood
more forcefully against things like
right to work in union busting
legislation oh I can say most certainly
and from people I know who are involved
in Union leadership like Peggy um they
see through their cope organizations
these people tell them how they vote and
I can say definitely at her local it's
just like New Hampshire it is a third
Republican third Democrat and the third
independent and as Representatives we
all live and die by how the people who
are The Independents feel about us so I
look it as an opport
you
know the most conservative thing anyone
can do is nothing just leave everything
alone and that's what people who are
Republican union members and independent
union members are really asking for here
it's not the I want a pony for Christmas
laundry list of legislative changes they
want they're really just asking you just
let it go don't do anything in this
particular situation and that's pretty
easy to deliver
on thank
you right see no other question
questions thank you very much for your
testimony so that's phase one that
concludes the
list this concludes the list of
individuals but I know we have one
individual Pat Moren was contacted
Christina and then we have individuals
on the telephone so I would
uh recognize Pat Moren if you are here
with
us hello Mr chairman can you hear me
okay yes we can okay thank you very much
for taking your time and the committee
members as well my name is Pat Moran and
I am a proud Union member and chief
steart of the International Brotherhood
of Electrical Workers Local
1837 the IB the IBEW 1837 is a utility
Union with members in both New Hampshire
and Maine I feel strongly that Senate
Bill 61 the so-called Right to Work bill
does not bring does not belong in the
Hampshire I believe this is a means to
break unions the name itself is a
lie Right to Work does not give anyone
any rights or any work it is meant to
hurt unions financially in the hope that
they will further wither and die unions
operate like any business a much needed
business for hardworking men and women
like
myself much like any other business when
a Bill gets introduced such as
sb61 that makes businesses work for
someone that is not required to pay
their fair share eventually that
business is not receiving Fair
compensation for the work that they
perform and that business faces
substantial Financial strains and like
any other business that do not get paid
proper
they face going out of business this
would be a major disaster to New
Hampshire Working Families this will
lead to low paying jobs for everyone
whether they are in a union or not jobs
with less benefits and in general
employees that have no care for their
employers I strongly urge you to not
vote for so-called Right to
Work vote no please
this will be devastating for hardworking
men and women in New Hampshire and their
families thank you for what you do and
thank you for taking your time to listen
to My
Testimony thank you Mr Mor any
questions members on
Zoom anyone any any questions members
here
committee see none thank you very much
your
testimony thank
you Christina how many individuals do we
have waiting on the
telephone uh we have three that we've
not heard from uh excuse me four and
then you have
another six people with their hands up
excuse me there are six people that have
their hands up from you said
64 no I didn't right um would you uh for
the four individuals on the phone please
just pick one and and have each and then
individuals just uh as you were chosen
please um introduce yourself with your
name and the town you're from
please all right so I have an individual
um with a 617 number ending in 443 um
you can press um star six to unmute
yourself if you'd like to speak
okay this is a phone number ending in
443 you were recognized by the
chairman you can press star six to
unmute okay did you want to move on or
did you want to wait a
moment why don't you just put them back
in the queue and uh move to the next
please come back
to CHR I think we may have heard from
the one ending in 267 earlier yes we did
thank
you we'll go to uh number ending in 757
area code
978 star 62
unmute all right someone um on the phone
with a number ending in
757 if you'd like to
speak okay then we can move to someone
who is on the phone and well it says
they're Galaxy Note 10
plus know who that
is hi there my name is Paul
Titus uh I live in stratum New
Hampshire I've been a Teamster for 31
years uh I'd like to say say uh good
morning actually good afternoon and
thank you for letting me
speak right to work is the name of a
policy designed to take away rights from
working people backers of this claim the
laws protect workers against being
forced to join a union the reality is
that federal law already does
this the real purpose of right to work
laws is to tilt the balance towards
corporations and further rig the system
at the expense of work and
families this law makes it harder for
people to form unions and collectively
bargain for better wages benefits and
working
conditions every freeloader that takes
advantage of higher wages benefits and
working conditions that unions provide
will not pay in any cost diminishes the
Union's ability to service all workers
it
represents I worked in a right to work
state and the only thing it did was
divide the workforce it was not a
harmonious place to
work please stand with the working men
and women in New Hampshire and say no to
this harmful
legislation thank
you thank you Mr Titus are there any
questions any members
online any questions for members in
LLB seeing n thank you Mr Titus thank
you all right next in the list we have a
Sonia
Prince
thank you Miss Prince you're uh welcome
to the labor
committee can you hear me yes we can
thank you for your patience it's been a
long day I appreciate all of you um the
right to work or as many call it the
right to work for Less bill sp61 is bad
for New Hampshire this bill is not new
and it's often been presented in all 50
states thanks to special interest groups
like Alec similar bills written by other
corporations or groups like The C
Brothers funded groups um I'm
disappointed that many pay forplay
legislators often Republicans have their
hands out to the corporations and C
brother billionaires to do their dirty
work so they can increase their offshore
bank account wealth and take advantage
of Labor workers by squeezing them
financially legislators often present
these toxic bills in exchange for
campaign donations or pen pushing high
paying future jobs when they leave their
political seats this sb61 bill hurts
hardworking Americans Martin Luther King
is likely rolling in his grave today his
goal of protecting the sanitation
workers who are getting injured on the
job in 1968 was accomplished by the
creation of a union this bill is a
disaster for New Hampshire and kind of
reminds me of the 2010 BP Oil explosion
type of event waiting to happen where
the company paid fines instead of fixing
the problems to protect workers who are
blown off the oil rigs unions negotiate
safety protections this bill would allow
corporations to offer below poverty
wages cut basic benefits that every
American deserves for a hard week of pay
of work without these labor workers
there would be no profits for the
corporate pen pushers at the top please
do not support this disastrous Bill and
yes unions sometimes endorse or support
support political candidates who protect
their values and workers instead of
allowing a schmuck who doesn't give a
darn about the safety or well-being of
our workers even more reason to support
the more decent candidates and I heard a
lady earlier mention um the origins of
these type of bills with racist tones
and I read the article and I was
appalled of where this began uh and she
was right about the the um people not
wanting to work with people who are
black or Jews so I hope you refute this
bill once again it keeps coming back
it's annoying and I hope you vote
against it and do the right thing for
New Hampshire I appreciate your
time just morning questions for the
uh
presenter seeing none
online seeing down in the L thank you
very much for your ctim morning thank
you
next on the list is Mike
thoron thank you CH members I appreciate
the time you're taking it's quite a
job I am Michael thoron 561 North River
Road Milford New Hampshire speaking for
myself I fully support SP
sp61 I was a longtime Union Steel worker
for the timkin roller Bearing Company
Columbus Ohio badge number
36111 the closed shop or compulsory
unionism cost me high union
dues they were often spent against my
wishes and detrimentally to my
beliefs the opportunity for overtime and
promotions was by senority only no Merit
considered those high costs priced
americanmade tempkin
tapered roller bearings once in every
car American made out of the market the
entire plant has gone most of the
company in in producing roller bearings
is gone from the United States all jobs
were
lost live free is an individual
motto Union ISM should be an individual
choice if I want to buy a gallon of milk
I can go buy a gallon of milk if I want
to work for a specific company I ought
to be able to work for the company and
if the union is supporting me and
something I believe in I should be able
to buy their services and buy
in so please allow individuals to choose
their
affiliation a union which is
delivering Services is going to be
supported right to work is going to make
more jobs available for the trainee
workers and allow employers to hire
people and promote them based on Merit
working together we can bring jobs that
have left America back and all of us can
work more profitably together Union and
non-union both have their choice nothing
in HB 61 needs harm any Union in any way
they can actually turn it to their
benefit I'm asking you to please find S
sp61
OTP thank you
all thank you for your testimony are
there any questions of the presenter
online
representative
buudy chairman uh Mr thoron what if the
company wants all their employees in the
union if the company wishes to have
their employees in the union and a good
job candidate steps forward and says I
choose not to be a union member do you
choose not to hire me that is
entirely their choice as long as it is
not based on a
prohibited like race color creed
something like that I would hope that
any company at any time would hire the
best candidate for any job regardless of
unionism race color creed anything
fair
enough additional questions for
Representatives
online seeing none any here in the
L Mr thoron thank for your thank you for
your testimony have a good
day okay next we have Kevin
Foley
good afternoon Mr chairman can you hear
me uh yes go ahead Mr goyk you very much
and thank you for returning my phone
call this morning I got got your message
uh and thank you to the members of the
committee you guys are guys and gals put
in a long day and I I would definitely
uh you know negotiate raises for you if
you are
Teamsters the record my name is Kevin
Foley I reside in Durham New Hampshire
I'm long New Hampshire resident I'm also
the elected president of Teamsters Local
633 located in Manchester New Hampshire
we represent over 5,000 dues paying
members at hundreds of New Hampshire
workplaces I started my 37-year career
as a Teamster as a UPS driver humping
bundles up and down the sidewalks to
various businesses and i' I've risen
through the ranks and became elected
president we get elected every three
years so we can uh uh understand your
plate getting elected every two years uh
I'm obviously in opposition to uh S sp61
I think it's a union busting scam and I
think it's it's a disaster for uh
working people of New Hampshire uh one
thing that is missing uh from a lot of
people testified so I won't go over my
PR prepared remarks I'll keep it short
uh I I haven't seen a list of all the
companies committed to come to New
Hampshire
uh once right to work for Less is
enacted no one's provided that uh that
list uh to
anyone as you know 10% of New
Hampshire's Workforce is represented by
by a union us Bureau of Labor Statistics
data show union workers earn higher
wages have better health insurance and
better workplace safety these are all
good for workers and good for New
Hampshire I don't know one working
person that I represent that wants to
earn less lose their Quality Health Care
or work at a place that's less safe in
conclusion please remember that the
5,000 New Hampshire Teamsters are
essential hourly paid workers during
this pandemic that silently stalks 350
million Americans killing over
400,000 most of us don't have the
ability to work remotely our ups members
are out in about delivering
prescriptions life-saving vaccines our
law enforcement officers are out there
putting their lives on the line
dispatchers are Manning the phone lines
to protect people's uh life and property
we've had your back during this pandemic
alls we're asking is that you have ours
I urge you to vote uh sp61 inexpedient
to legislate thank you very
much thank you Mr Foley do we have any
questions on line for Mr fo
seeing none we have any in the L seeing
none thank you very much Mr Foy for your
testimony thank you Mr chairman there's
a Dennis O'Brien who was contacted to me
Christina uh he he may be joining Zoom
as
well I do see him I can bring him up now
thank
you hello can you hear me yes we can
welcome to the labor
committee okay thank you very much uh
for your time today uh my name's Dennis
O'Brien from Deerfield um I'm a veteran
I've been also a proud UPS Teamster uh
I've been at UPS for 27 years and I am
in the minority as a republican uh in
the union however I do want to uh talk
about that uh like many hardworking
essential employees over the past year
during this pandemic
we've worked six days a week up up to 60
hours um we swayed this past election
the hardworking people uh based on you
know we we supported the governor and
how he was handling the pandemic uh we
were turned off by the opposition and
some of the things that were said um
after this past year I'm I'm kind of
upset that the timing that this would
come forward now but but being being uh
being an individual I see that the right
to work has the prime opportunity here
to take advantage of of the popularity
uh of the governor um I voted for
Senator Reagan and representative Spain
in 20120 and then I sat in the senate
committee and listened to Senator Reagan
uh basically tell the committee to
disregard my comments as a union worker
because I was only riled up by the by
the Union
he also stated that uh that this would
possibly attract companies he also
stated that the people that this will
benefit don't even know who they are yet
and like I said when in the senate
committee the people that this could
hurt we do know who we are this
continues to come up as a partisan issue
uh where the money goes to the
Republican Party a party that I
affiliate myself with a and they try to
move this agenda
forward as a hardworking six day a week
60h hour a week worker I don't have time
to be tuned into a lot and neither do a
lot of our other employees and I'd like
to thank Senator Reagan for tuning me in
um because I'm not going away and
neither is the four voters in my house
and the others who who he disregarded uh
and said we shouldn't have voice we work
hard I work hard for my money I have two
sons one of them went to college and is
an engineering manager the other one has
joined me at UPS my son that's uh an
engineer engineering manager uh has
$70,000 in college debt whereas my son
that's working with me at UPS has zero
debt um he used the money uh from his
his paying job at UPS and has gone to
Community College and and is going to
get his associates degree
um in 2017 this the the right to work
was defeated when 32 Brave Republicans
voted against it 32 in the house um
following that there was a lot of
Fallout uh Jeanie Forester uh in a press
conference at that time the state
Republican party chairman said for those
that supported the governor they will be
rewarded in the next election cycle with
campaign funds Greg Moore who you heard
from earlier from the Americans for
Prosperity uh in a uh speaking about the
defeat of the right to work in 2017 told
the union leader we're not going away
and as far as the 32 Republicans have I
mentioned we don't treat uh pledge
Breakers very well referring to uh
representative from Seabrook and I
believe the other one was from Derry I
fear the strong armed tactics could be
in place today and I I beg of you my
fellow Republicans to choose me choose
my family choose the workers over
corporations at UPS we have a we have a
a phrase it's it's called trust your gut
and when you're driving your vehicle and
something doesn't feel right and a
situation doesn't feel right it's
probably not right this right to work
this is not right please be brave
please support me so I can continue to
support the Republican party that I love
and thank you very much for your
time thank you for your
testimony my computer has finally gone
dead after eight or nine hours so I'm
using my telephone here are there any so
I can't see as
well are there any questions for Mr
O'Brien see none that legislative office
building thank you very much for your uh
L okay next we have Patrick
Burns Mr Burns welcome to hear me
yes yes we
can all right sorry sorry can you hear
me yes hi good good afternoon uh Mr
chairman and committee thank you for
taking time to hear my
testimony um my name is Patrick Burns I
am a proud uh Marine Corps veteran
father of three husband and a proud
Teamster of uh local 633 who happens to
be a registered
Republican I am here today to oppose
sp61 for several reasons there was a lot
of good testimony today that I had to
clean up my speech a little bit but
um just to go over what the way I feel
about this is that it's unamerican
you're trying to dictate to a business
being a union how they can operate on a
daily basis
um telling them that
you
you you won't be able to you know pay
union dues um you're not required to pay
union dues which is GNA hurt the bottom
line of the Union it is a
business okay just like in previous
testimony um regarding
memberships you know services are not
not going to be
rendered so s sp61 severely impacts the
future of the existence of our Union our
jobs and our benefits that have been
earned Through Blood Sweat and
Tears um this law being a big push for
Republicans was a big surprise to me
because historically speaking
Republicans are for limited government
regulations learning the national Right
to Work committee out of Virginia being
a special interest group has donated
money to various politicians so this
kind of made sense to me the union
leader just recently posted on
312 of this year that $100,000 was
donated to 10 GOP candidates okay in the
in the midst of a pandemic prioritizing
a bill that only helps a special
interest group politicians and hurts the
working class is
baffling politicians are supposed to
listen to consti
I think the one thing that we can learn
from today that we've heard a lot of
testimony and I can only tell you that
I've heard a handful of in favor of most
of the um testimony today was against so
you're all duly elected officials okay
you're supposed you you work for the
people of New Hampshire so with that
being said you're supposed to listen to
your
constituents I am a shop steward at my
at my at my place of work okay and the
one phrase that I say to my members is
that I don't speak for you I speak on
behalf of you so you listen to the
people that put you in in office
okay um you know the the in the last
committee all right um there was there
was very similar testimony but
if this bill passes as we know it our
dly elected officials I'll listen to the
spe special interest groups they're not
listening to the
constituents so the you know the one
thing that really has me concerned about
this bill is 273 D9 all right the
penalty
section right so you can say whatever
you want that this this you know is
Union Bus and which it is okay but this
is a this is an unconstitutional Bill if
you read it okay the penalties any
person opposing to someone not paying
dues can face a, fine or face prison not
exceeding 90 days or both so with that
being said this this law would would
allow a company
to you know like an HR upon orientation
could say to that you know potential
union dues paying member or not Union
who pay member that you know here are
your options okay but if if we as union
members say that to them we could face
jail time and a fine all right so I'm
asking you to please listen to the
constituents okay there was overwhelming
testimony today that was against this
bill please listen to the
workers okay and uh oppose S sp61 I
thank you for your time and let me uh
testify thank you Mr Burns for your
testimony are there any questions in the
L for Mr
Burns seeing none have any
[Music]
online Christina yes so next we have Jim
patrio
Petrillo Mr Petrillo P Trio uh you're
welcome to the labor
committee yes can you hear
me
yes thank you uh chairman and the
committee for letting me
testify I am uh 29 and a half year
Teamster member of local 633 here in New
Hampshire I am a registered independent
voter I was a sharp Steward for 27 years
at the company I worked for I am now a
field rep for the
teamsters this
bill in my mind and I don't want to off
anybody is
ridiculous you
hear people call in on zoom on the phone
against this
bill every time this comes
up you don't hear companies in the state
coming forward saying we want this bill
because it's going to bring jobs it's
not going to bring
jobs you know I hear testimony today
that people say well how does it lower
wages how does it impact
bargaining what happens is because I've
talked to people in right to work states
that over time the members that decide
not to pay Union does the companies know
who they are and that makes it weaker to
negotiate a contract the companies know
that that's how they divide and
conquer that's how it erods wages
benefits and drives everything down
that's why it's called a race to the
bottom for right to
work it makes no sense to me I'm going
to use an analogy that I used last time
your D driving down 93 in New Hampshire
you get a flat tire you call
triaa they're going to ask you are you a
member you paying a member dues you say
no you're gonna be sitting there all day
that's the same thing that this bill
does for unions this bill goes forward
unions have to represent the non-union
people in a group that's federal law and
I heard somebody say that that wasn't
the case it is the
case me being a steward if I have a
person that's not paying dues
and I don't represent him I get in
trouble the union gets in
trouble that's why this bill does not
make sense to me because that means
people are getting services for free
anybody that owns a company doesn't work
for
free I'm opposed to this bill and I hope
that all the testimony you hear
today lets people know that you're going
to vote this down this bill is not good
for New Hampshire no New Hampshire
person came forward to sponsor this bill
if it wasn't for Virginia right to
work I thank you for your
time thank you for your testimony are
there any questions the
present
see
online I do not thank you very much for
your
testimony we have Paul
Ells Paul
ell's
LS Mr ell's welcome to labor committee
hi good afternoon Vice chairman and
chairman French thank you for taking my
testimony my name is Paul Ells I live in
spafford New Hampshire with wife Gail
grandchildren great-grandchildren I'm a
veteran born and educated New Hampshire
homeowner master pass master from Mas
Sonic Lodge independent voter I've
worked for 21 years first student I love
this state what I don't love is yes I
resent is outside forces subverting our
way of life in this great state of ours
into a state of disrepair by causing a
high poverty rate low income High child
mortality rate lower education with
sb61 I resent legislators that are
passing bills that directly affect the
constituents
without letting them know without a note
a phone call anything on
sp61
$100,000 whoever took that money that
out ofate money should be ashamed of
themselves Right to Work Is A Lie
wrapped in Feelgood slogan it's not only
offensive and harmful to fi harmful to
5,000 of the New Hampshire Teamsters but
all working women and men of New
Hampshire I think you'll all agree New
Hampshire is a great PA to live and
raise a family it's where I choose to
work and live and raise my family for
decades New Hampshire is listed as one
of the best states in the country when
it comes to Economic Opportunity
education and quality of life as
Governor sonunu has said repeatedly New
Hampshire is open for business and
Governor cuno has told us he receives
frequent calls for businesses looking to
move to New Hampshire it's not
surprising then that US News and World
Report recently ranked New Hampshire as
a number two in the country up from five
in previous year we have a growing and
resilient economy our education system
is rated as one of the best when we have
a housing storage shortage because so
many people want to live here organized
labor isn't holding New Hampshire back
as supporters of s sp61 might have you
believe in fact organized labor the
hardworking men and women of New
Hampshire are integral are an integral
to our economy and quality of life would
it surprise you that 15 out of 20 States
uh the Right to Work For Less States
this data alone should be reason enough
to cause pause and ask passing this law
helps New Hampshire
how
uh I guess in
conclusion I want to say please remember
you were elected to office by the people
for the people for the people of New
Hampshire thank
you thank you Mr for your testimony
there any questions of the presenter
here in the lob representative turot yes
thank uh Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Ells for the question I've heard heard
this twice today and I'm trying to kind
of understand that somehow could you
explain the relationship between right
to work and child mortality
rates that's
correct the reason for that is because
you have less money if you don't have
the unions to get that money up there
you have less people that have
hospitalization less people more people
actually that aren't taking their child
to the hospital because they can't
afford to because they don't have that
insurance it all follows
through thank you you're
welcome any questions of our members on
Zoom
I don't see any so thank you very much
Mr Ells for your
testimony next we have the sea
organizing
Department there
individual I don't know hopefully
they'll tell
us welcome could you please give a your
name unmute
first is anyone on the line with the sea
organization
Pro hello can you hear
me yes and you are Sor sorry about that
um I'm actually calling in on my behalf
I just happen to be using my work
computer um hello uh thank you for
letting me speak uh my name is David
Holt I'm calling in opposition to S sp61
uh the right to work for Les Bill uh I'm
a lifelong New Hampshire native and
currently a homeowner and taxpayer in
the city of summersworth New Hampshire I
am a proud Union member belonging to the
Coalition of Union employees and a
member of our Labor Management committee
which is just one of the ways that
unions work with employers to improve
the workplace to make our organization
successful uh Right to Work For Less is
wrong for New Hampshire it is an attack
on working people in New Hampshire
because when you talk about unions you
are talking about working people not
some quote unquote other entity like the
organizations that are pushing these
bills the labor leaders that have called
in are working people that were part of
their Union and were elected to lead by
their co-workers uh can the people
trying to influence New Hampshire's
legislation from outof State
organizations say the same was the
director of the national Right to Work
For Less organization elected to
represent their members or were they
hired by and paid by multi-billionaires
that use their dark money to fund
organizations like right to work for Les
or Alec and others that attack working
people to make the rich richer uh New
Hampshire does not need to be told how
to run Itself by these big money
interests we need to protect working
people that is the true function of
government to ensure that all citizens
are taken care care of and are treated
fairly we must not pass Right to Work
For Less this is moving New Hampshire
backward you have been given uh evidence
over and over that it lowers wages and
makes work areas less safe if you do not
vote inexpedient to legislate on this
horrible bill then you are not serving
the people of New Hampshire but out of
state dark money interest thank you very
much for your
time I didn't quite get your name is it
David H Hol h o l t h thank
you
do we have any questions in the lb for
Mr
Hol seeing none any
online seeing none thank you very much
for your
[Music]
testimony last speaker I have is Beth
s Beth and what is the last
name hi it's Beth
scare sorry for the the name being wrong
um yeah I'm I'm calling to support
[Music]
sb61 um my husband was a member of the
Nea New Hampshire teachers union for 25
years and we were delighted when all the
public unions became right to work after
the Janice Supreme Court
ruling the teachers union suddenly cared
about the teachers and started reaching
out and asking him what he
needed and that meant as Republicans we
could stop giving money to an
organization that turned around and used
it to get Democrats elected and Lobby
for political causes we
despise I feel it's terribly unfair that
those who work under private unions
don't have the same Freedom we did why
should someone have to pay an annual fee
to an organization in order to get a job
it's like paying protection
money public workers already have right
to work and all the dire predictions
about union busting have not occurred
why should P private workers not have
the same rights please protect workers
rights and vote ought to pass on sb61
thank
you and I'm from nsha and I'm sending in
my
testimony thank you for your testimony
there any questions here in the LLP for
the
presenter seeing none any
online seeing No Hands thank you very
much for your testimony
Christina is there anyone else online
wishing to
speak no I don't see anyone
else members of the
committee are we satisfied uh with the
I'm ready to close the
hearing any opposition I close the
hearing on Senate Bill
61 thank you you very much for all of
your attendance today very
professional uh way you hand everyone
handle
themselves we will have a executive
session on this bill next Tuesday
there's been an amendment
submitted appreciate if all of you would
take a look at it and let me know your
um intentions so we can be prepared for
next Tuesday I am not aware of any other
Senate bills coming our way
prior
to the sessions on the 7th 8th and
9th if you have any questions as always
you can feel free to call me an email as
many of you do and I will see you next
Tuesday thank you very much everyone
enjoy your St Mr
chairman got a question
Michael uh sorry sorry Mr chairman just
uh waving goodbye and Mike sincerely
happy birthday my friend enjoy your day
happy birthday Michael it's been great
so far nice job Mr chairman tough day
thank you
bye